ONE MORE MEMBER LAFAYETTE TO
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. THEM WE
WILL SO THAT WE WOULD HOLD UP UP
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE.
THEY'RE WILLING TO TESTIFY
SO.
ONE OF THE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WE NEED YOU
HERE.
.
FIVE MINUTES AGO THANK
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE MEETING TO
ORDER.
.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
DISCIPLINE MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY.
.
FOR TESTIMONY ONLY TODAY.
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. NINETEEN
ELEVEN LACKEY.
AND ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FOUR FONG.
ITEMS THAT ARE GOING TO BE.
OFF CALENDAR TODAY.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN FOURTEEN.
WELL I'M SORRY ITEM NUMBER NINE
TWENTY SEVEN FOURTEEN.
ALAN.
A POLL BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO A. B.
THIRTY ELEVEN CHAO.
PULL BY COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE.
AB THIRTY SIXTY FOUR BAKER POLL
BY COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE RUBIO
PULLED BY COMMITTEE.
WHERE MATING FOR MEMBERS TO
COUNSEL AND START WITH A
SUBCOMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING GREAT WE CAN NOW
BEGIN AS A?
SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
ITEM.
OF WHICH MISTER CHAU.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY TEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LISTED ON PAGE
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS.
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD PROVIDE A
TO YOUR FACE AND PERIOD BEFORE
TAKING EFFECT. IN ORDER TO GIVE
COUNTY PROBATION AND CDC OUR
TIME TO PROVIDE TRAINING ON DE
ESCALATION AND CRISIS
INTERVENTION TECHNIQUES FOR
THEIR OFFICERS.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY TEN WOULD
LIMIT THE USE OF CHEMICAL SPRAY
IN JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES
AND REQUIRED THAT ALL
SITUATIONS.
INVOLVING ITS USE BE FULLY
DOCUMENTED.
CALIFORNIA LAW SPECIFICALLY
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION EIGHT FIFTY ONE PROVIDES
AT JUVENILE HALL SHALL NOT BE
DEEMED TO BE NO WOULD BE TREATED
AS. A PENAL INSTITUTION.
IT SHALL BE A SAFE AND
SUPPORTIVE HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENT.
ADDITIONALLY EXISTING LAW ALSO
PROVIDES THAT MINERS IN CUSTODY
SHOULD RECEIVE CARE TREATMENT
AND GUIDANCE CONSISTENT WITH
THEIR BEST INTERESTS.
THE USE OF CHEMICAL SPRAYS IN
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES IS
BECOMING A RARE OCCURRENCE
NATIONALLY.
THE MOST RECENTLY AVAILABLE
STATISTICS PROVIDE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE OF SIX
SPEAKS.
IN THE ENTIRE NATION THAT ALLOW
OFFICERS TO CARRY AND USE
CHEMICAL SPRAY ON CHILDREN IN
DETENTION FACILITIES.
THE THREAT OR USE OF CHEMICAL
AGENTS INCLUDING PEPPER SPRAY.
CANS SUBJECT YOU'VE TO PHYSICAL
AND EMOTIONAL PAIN.
IT ALSO CREATES A CHALLENGE FOR
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM SU
REHABILITATE OF A MISSION.
STUDIES ALSO INDICATE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WOULD. COMPROMISE
OUR RESPIRATORY SYSTEMS SUCH AS
THOSE SUFFERING FROM ASTHMA OR
BRONCHITIS MAYBE AT PARTICULAR
RISK FOR RESPIRATORY ARREST
RESULTING FROM CHEMICAL SPRAY.
EXPOSURE.
FURTHERMORE CHRONIC EXPOSURE TO
CHEMICAL SPRAY MAY RESULT IN
CHRONIC RESPIRATORY AILMENTS.
THESE RISKS MAY BE EXACERBATED
BY MENTAL ILLNESS INSUFFICIENT
AIR CIRCULATION AND REPEATED
EXPOSURE. ALL CONDITIONS THAT
MOST LIKELY EXIST IN JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE USE OF CHEMICAL
AGENTS INTERFERE WITH OF THE
REHABILITATION BECAUSE. IT
AFFECTS THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
YOU AND STAFF.
A SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THE
COUNCIL OF JUVENILE CORRECTIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS IN TWENTY ELEVEN
DEMONSTRATED THAT WORK CHEMICAL
SPRAY IS USED.
STAFF AND YOU FEAR FOR THEIR
SAFETY MORE THAN AVERAGE.
AND THAT STATES AUTHORIZING THE
USE OF CHEMICAL RESTRAINTS ALSO
TEND TO HAVE ADOPTED A MORE
PUNITIVE.
ADULT CORRECTIONS LIKE APPROACH
TO JUVENILE DETENTION.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY TEN THIS
AMENDED WOULD PROHIBIT STAFF IN
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES
FROM HAVING CHEMICALS RATE IN
THEIR POSSESSION.
STARTING IN THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE.
HOWEVER IT WOULD PROVIDE
EXCEPTIONS FOR STAFF TO OBTAIN
AND USE CHEMICAL SPRAY IN ORDER
TO SUPPRESS THE RIOT. OR IN
SITUATIONS WHERE DE ESCALATION
TACTICS OF FAILED OR ARE NOT NEW
REASONABLY POSSIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED TO INSURE THAT OFFICERS
HAVE A TWO YEAR PERIOD. IN WHICH
STATE AND COUNTY OFFICERS WILL
BE TRAINED IN DE ESCALATION AND
CRISIS INTERVENTION TECHNIQUES.
FINALLY THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THAT ALL SITUATIONS INVOLVING
THE USE OF CHEMICAL SPRAY BE
DOCUMENTED AND INCLUDE
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE USE.
OF THE REASONABLE USE THE AUTHOR
IS IT AUTHORIZATION
DECONTAMINATION PROCEDURES AS
WELL AS FOLLOW UP. VISITS WITH
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE TWO WITNESSES SO
ABA JUNIOR CARDIGANS OF THE WILL
YOU'VE LAW CENTER AND ALSO AGAR
IBARRA OF THE MILL PA
COLLECTIVE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
COREGONUS STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
THESE LAW CENTER AND I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HIS SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BELL. ON AND THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALSO TOUCHED ON
THE REASONS WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT.
.
CHEMICAL AGENTS WE KNOW ARE
HARMFUL FOR CHILDREN BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY
THERE ESPECIALLY HARMFUL FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA. WHICH IS
VIRTUALLY EVERY IF NOT EVERY
YOUNG PERSON AREN'T IN OUR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
CHEMICAL AGENTS ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IN THEIR ANTI
REHABILITATIVE.
THE GOAL OF CALIFORNIA'S
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
REHABILITATION AND SECURE
JUVENILE FACILITIES ARE TASKED
WITH PROVIDING A SAFE AND
SUPPORTIVE HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENT.
FUN AND PROVIDING EFFECTIVE
REHABILITATION WE KNOW. IT
SUPPORTS PUBLIC SAFETY BECAUSE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO
DEVELOP TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH STAFF ARE ABLE TO DEVELOP
THOSE SKILLS THAT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO. BECOME PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
ON.
BUT THOSE RELATIONSHIPS ARE
DAMAGED AND TRUST IS IMPOSSIBLE
WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY
ARE CONSTANTLY THREATENED WITH
THE USE OF DANGEROUS AND HARMFUL
CHEMICAL AGENTS.
LET ALONE THEIR ACTUAL USE ON
THEM.
I'M MORE WHAT I WANNA SPEAK MOST
ABOUT IS IS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THE FACT THAT CHEMICAL AGENTS
ARE NOT NECESSARY TO RUN
EFFECTIVE AND SAFE JUVENILE
FACILITIES.
AND AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOUCHED ON OUR MOST RECENT DATA
SHOWS THAT ONLY SIX STATE RUN
JUVENILE INSTITUTIONS JUVENILE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEMS USE ON
CHEMICAL AGENTS. CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THEM.
.
OTHER STATES HAVE ELIMINATED THE
USE OF CHEMICAL AGENTS IT SAFELY
AND SUCCESSFULLY TO NAME JUST A
FEW EXAMPLES.
OKLAHOMA HAS BANNED THE USE OF
CHEMICAL SPRAYS AND ALL OF ITS
JUVENILE FACILITIES. SINCE THE
BAN ONE YEAR AGO THEY'VE HAD NO
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
ASSAULTS OR INJURIES EITHER TO
YOUNG PEOPLE OR TO STAFF.
THE BAND INCLUDES THE FACILITY
HOUSING THE YOUTH WHO HAVE
COMMITTED THE MOST SERIOUS
DEFENSES IN OKLAHOMA INCLUDING
MURDER AND RAPE.
ON AND ONCE AGAIN THEY ARE NO
LONGER USING CHEMICAL AGENTS AND
THEY'RE RUNNING THE FACILITY
SAFELY.
STAFF INCLUDING FEMALE STAFF ARE
STILL ABLE TOSECURE THOSE
FACILITIES WITHOUT THE USE OF
SPRAY.
OHIO NEW YORK IN LOUISIANA HAVE
ALSO RECENTLY UNLIMITED
ELIMINATED THE USE OF CHEMICAL
AGENTS AND TEXAS LIMITS THE USE
OF CHEMICAL AGENTS. I'M SIMILAR
TO SIMILAR TO HOW THIS BILL
WOULD LIMIT IT. ON.
BASICALLY ONLY IN RIOT
SITUATIONS IN WITH THE APPROVAL
OF ADMINISTRATORS AND
CALIFORNIA'S PROBATION OFFICERS
AND COUNSELORS INCLUDING OUR
FEMALE PROBATION OFFICERS AND
COUNSELORS ARE JUST AS
COMPETENT.
AND JUST IS ABLE TO MAINTAIN
FACILITY SAFELY AS THOSE
OFFICERS AND COUNSELORS AND
OTHER STATES.
WE KNOW OTHER INTERVENTIONS CAN
BE YOU SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY.
ON IN OKLAHOMA JUVENILE FAT
FACILITIES STAFF ARE EMPOWERED
TO HANDLE THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND
NO ONE HAS ASKED TO BRING SPRAY
BACK INSTEAD STAFFER BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
WORKING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE BEFORE
THEY GET TO THE BLOW UP STAGE.
HELPING THEM THINK BEFORE THEY
ACT AND ENCOURAGING THEM TO ASK
FOR HELP WHEN THEY NEED IT.
THIS BILL IS A SENSIBLE SOLUTION
THAT MOVES CALIFORNIA IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS THE USE
OF BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPERVISION MODELS THAT WILL
OBVIATE THE NEED FOR CHEMICAL
AGENTS.
THE TWO YEAR TRANSITION PLAN
WILL ALLOW OUR PROBATION
OFFICERS YES TICKET. TO BE
TRAINED IN THESE ALTERNATIVE
METHODS FOR SAY FACILITY
MANAGEMENT THANK FUTURE
NEVER GOT STATES TWO MINUTES
INTO AND YOU WILL OVER THOUGHT I
HAVE. A GIVE YEAR TO.
HELLO GOOD MORNING WHIMS EDU
BAHRAM WITH MEAT BY AND OF
SALINAS IN NAM.
I DO WANNA THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND ALL THOSE WHO ON.
PUT INPUT AND MAKING THIS BILL
PUT IT OUT THERE AND JUST WANTED
TO SHARE SOME EXPERIENCES OF
BEING ACTUALLY.
SPRAYED WITH MULTIPLE AND
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OF CHEMICAL
AGENTS SPRAYS.
WHILE I WAS INCARCERATED AS
JUVENILE IN THAT DJJ AND OTHER
FACILITIES AS WELL AS JUST THE.
FIRST EVERYBODY HAVE THIS
MISCONCEPTION THAT. YOU GET
SPRAYED AND YOU GO THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT IN YOUR
FACING YOUR GOOD. YOU DON'T YOU
DON'T BURN NO MORE YOU KNOW YOU
GET A DECONTAMINATION WELL AS
ONE X. SAY THAT NO. THAT'S NOT
TRUE IT TAKES WEEKS.
SOMETIMES DEPENDING ON WHAT KIND
OF SPRAY THE SPREE WITH.
AND THEY SPRAY WITH THIS THE
HEADLESS AND THE INTRODUCED
EXCUSE BY WHILE I WAS THERE IT'S
LIKE A A GOOD LIKE SUBSTANCES
STICKS TO YOU.
IS SITES NOW LIQUID.
IT'S NOT.
JUST A SPRAY KNOWS GOO. AND
THAT MY PERSONAL REACTION MY
BODY PERSONAL REACTION TO IT
WAS.
I HAD BLISTERS AYE BOILED. AYE
GOT BOILS AND MY SKIN PEELED.
AND THIS IS NOT JUST A DAY OR
TWO LATER BECAUSE OF THE
PROLONGED.
PROCESS FOR ALMOST A MONTH AND I
WENT TO THE NURSE THE NURSES
SEEN THIS IS DOCUMENTED IN THEIR
THE NURSES SEEMINGLY TREATED ME
FOR ALL THIS TYPE OF.
OUR SIDE EFFECTS FROM THIS
ANNA.
PEOPLE JUST CLICK CONTINUOUSLY
AND SOMETIMES THEY PUT IN THE
REPORTS ALL IS SET TO IT THREE
SECOND BURST.
OF THIS TYPE OF CHEMICAL AGENT
TO WHICH A CHILD WHICH I WAS AT
THE TIME I WAS ONLY FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AT THE TIME.
NO THE SOMETIMES THEY UNLOADED
THE WHOLE CANISTER ON ME AND
SOMETIMES I WAS ON THE GROUND
ALREADY RESTRAINT. AND THEN
LOADED THE WHOLE CAN.
SPRAINING.
BUT OUT BASICALLY NO CONSENTED
CONTINUE TO SCREAM YOU KNOW.
I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT ALSO
WAS AT THE TIME IS HARD I DIDN'T
KNOW THIS PERSON WHO SPRING AND
HE WORKED THERE. HE WAS A
COUNSELOR AND SUPPOSED TO HELP
ME OUT. BUT THE SAME TIME AFTER
THE FACT I FELT.
A STRONG DISLIKE TOWARDS MAN OR
THE WOMAN.
WHO SPREADING BECAUSE?
I KNOW THEY WENT OVERBOARD.
CLICK CREATED THE DISTRESS THAT
WAS ALREADY THERE AND YOU JUST
AND INTENSIFIED. TO HOLD
DIFFERENT EXTREME WHICH IT WAS.
AT A POINT WHERE WHATEVER THEY
TOLD ME OR TRY TO TALK TO ME
WHEN IT WAS WHENEVER IS NEEDED
TO DE ESCALATE THE SITUATION. HE
WAS NOT GOING TO HELP ALREADY
HAVE THEIR SET IN MY MIND THIS
PERSON DID ME WRONG.
HE TOOK ADVANTAGE OF ME WHEN I
WAS IN A BOIL POSITION IS
ALREADY BAD ENOUGH THAT I'M.
DEALING WITH REJECTION TRAUMA
FROM MY HOME IN HOWARD BROUGHT
UP IN THAT TO COME INTO A
SITUATION WHERE I'M. BEING
ABUSED MORE WITH CHEMICAL
AGENTS.
AND IT'S KIND OF JUST THROW MY
LIFE AND I STILL DO DEAL WITH
THIS TODAY.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
IT'S JUST.
I HOPE THIS KIND OF CAUSE AND
EFFECT BECAUSE I'VE STILL GOT A
FAMILY IN THE SYSTEM. AND I
DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH TO.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. POKER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FEEL
A BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT.
HELLO ANGELINA ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIAN
CHUNKS PART.
GOOD MORNING MARGO TORCH FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JOSE FROM COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ON SCREEN WE
HAVE VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
JOSH AND COMMUNITIES THAT OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
SUPPORT.
MARITZA FROM COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR A STORY OF YOUTH JUSTICE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY FELLOWS FROM COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR A START YOU'VE
JUSTICE IN OAKLAND AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
JIM WYNNE BURGER ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
ANY. WITNESSES AND UP.
POSITION.
ANOTHER SUPPORT. OF A GOOD.
GOOD MORNING SABINE ACROSS CITY
WITH ALL OF US ARE NONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU.
ME WITNESSES YOU HAVE.
REALLY READY MISTER TO RECOUP
MEASUREMENT GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME SOBRE O. TRICKLED ON
APPEARED ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
COALITION PERMISSION
ORGANIZATIONS.
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TEN.
ALTHOUGH WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TODAY.
THE BILL WILL IN ESSENCE RESULT
IN A BAND OF THE USE OF PEPPER
SPRAY CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH
FACILITIES.
THE REALITY IN ANY FIRST
RESPONDER SITUATION WHETHER
WE'RE TOM OF FIREFIGHTERS.
PARAMEDICS POLICE OFFICER OR
PROBATION OFFICERS IS THAT THE
MOST IMPORTANT FACTORS TYPE.
THE PROBATION OFFICER LOVE ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO CARRY PEPPER
SPRAY ON THE PERSON. YOU'RE
PUTTING THE SAFETY OF JUVENILES
AND STAFF IN DANGER MOTHER
RETREAT PEPPER SPRAY. FROM
PRESUMABLY A LOCKED CABINET
AFTER RECEIVING AUTHORITY TO DO
SO.
UNLIKE THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
WOULD RECOGNIZE THE REALITIES
INHERENT IN JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES. PARTICULAR
CALIFORNIA FACILITIES.
CONTRARY TO THE SEARCHES FOR
IMPLICATIONS MADE BY SUPPORTERS
OF THIS BILL PEPPER SPRAY IS
TYPICALLY USED UNDER EXTREME
CIRCUMSTANCES. USING MY TOUR
MORE JUVENILES ARE ENGAGE IN
PHYSICAL ALTERCATION. MOST
COUNTIES HAVE STRICT POLICIES
GOVERNING IN RESTRICTING THE USE
OF PEPPER SPRAY.
SECOND. THE SPONSORS POINT TO A
STUDY OF THE COUNCIL OF JUVENILE
CORRECTION MINISTRIES FROM TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. IN ARGUE THAT
ONLY TWENTY NINE PERCENT
AGENCIES A LOT FOR THE USE OF
CHEMICAL RESTRAINTS.
HERE IS SOMETHING THE SPONSORED
NOT TELL YOU FROM THE SAME
STUDY.
OF THE STATE TO DO PROHIBIT
PURPOSE FOR ONLY TEN ALSO
PROHIBIT ISOLATION OR SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT OF THE JUVENILES.
SIXTEEN FAITH OF BANNED THE USE
OF PEPPER SPRAY CONTINUED UP
ISOLATION AS AN OPTION.
EVERY MONTH I REMIND THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST THREE
YEARS AGO THESE VERY SAME
SPONSORS WERE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTING. SIGNIFICANT LIMITS
ISOLATION CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
REALITY IN JUVENILE FACILITIES
THAT THE PROBATION OFFICERS.
NEEDED DETERRENT TO BE ABLE TO
ASSURE THE SAFETY OF THE GERMAN
OFFICE STUFF LIKE. IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR JUVENILES TO ONE
FACT IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
SEVERAL JUVENILES TO FIND AT THE
SAME TIME. SITUATION LIKE THIS
COMMUTER IT VERY QUICKLY.
TIME IS NOT A LUXURY AFFORDED TO
OFFICERS IN THESE SITUATIONS IT
IS NOT REALISTIC OR PRACTICAL TO
PRESUME. THAT IT OFFICER WILL
HAVE TIME TO SEEK AUTHORIZATION
TO RETREAT PURPOSE BAY FROM A
LOCKED CABINET IN ANOTHER AREA.
THERE ARE OTHER PRACTICAL
REALITIES THAT SEPARATE
CALIFORNIA FROM OTHER STATES.
JUVENILE FACILITIES CURRENTLY
HOUSE MINERS THAT ARE CHARGING
SENSE AS ADULTS CHARGES CENTS
WITH SEVERAL SEVENTY SERIOUS
FELONIES AS A RESULT CALIFORNIA
IN ALL LIKELIHOOD. HAS MORE
DANGEROUS YOU'RE WRONG JUVENILES
ARE SOLUTION OTHER STATES THIS
POPULATION IS SET TO EXPAND AND
LET OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO RAISE THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX. PERCENT AS JUVENILES
TO REMAIN IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES.
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ALSO SITE
OKLAHOMA'S AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT TO
DO AND THE BENEFIT OF USING DE
ESCALATION TACTICS OF COURSE. WE
SUPPORT AND USE SUCH TACTICS
EVERYDAY.
HERE'S A THOUGHT THAT SUPPORTERS
OF NOT SHARED ABOUT OKLAHOMA.
THEIR STAFFING RATIOS ARE ONE
OFFICER PER TWO TO SIX
JUVENILES.
MANY STATES HAVE ADOPTED FEDERAL
STANDARDS OF ONE EIGHT JUVENILES
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
OUR RATES WITH EITHER ONE TO TEN
OFFICERS.
OR ONE TO FIFTEEN.
MY FINAL COMMENT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
PROBATION OFFICERS IN THE FIELD
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IN
REHABILITATION IN FACT MOST
JUVENILES. WINTER THE FACILITY
AND LEAVE NEVER COME BACK
CONTRARY TO THE ADULT SYSTEM.
THE JUVENILE RESTRICT RECIDIVISM
RATE IS EXTREMELY LOW.
THAT IS A TESTAMENT TO THE WORKS
COUPLE MEMBERS TO EVERYDAY. AND
MANY FACILITIES MAJORITY
OFFICERS ARE WOMEN. THESE WOMEN
ARE TASK
SUPERVISING JUVENILES THE ROUGH
AND FULLY GROWN MEN.
EXTRA TO OVER TWENTY POUNDS THEY
DO SO EVERY DAY.
IF AB TWENTY TENANTS ELECTED.
YOU WILL BE PUTTING A RISK THE
SAFETY OF THE JUVENILES AND
STAFF IF YOU'RE NOT THEY BE
TWENTY TEN. THEN SURE BE
PREPARED TO LOWER THE STAFFING
RATIOS RATIOS REPEAL THE
RESTRICTIONS ON ROOM CONFINED
AND SEPARATE MORE SERIOUS
OFFENDERS FROM OTHER JUVENILE
OFFENDERS.
AND YOU SHOULD BE PART EXCEPT
THAT THE ONLY MEANS OR LEAVING
OFFICERS TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
ALL JUVENILES IN THE FACILITIES.
IS PHYSICAL FORCE AN
INTERVENTION. THAT IS THE
REALITY THIS BILL CREATE NOT A
VIOLENCE FREE NEVADA.
SPONSORED PORTRAIT LIKE YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRIAN
RICHARD I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS A
CALIFORNIA'S WELL AS MYSELF
BITCHY PROBATION OFFICER BELL
DORADO COUNTY.
I'M HERE YOU KNOW VOTE TODAY ON
AB TWENTY TEN SO WELL
INTENTIONED PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BUT IT'S PREMATURE AND IT IS
POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS.
BEFORE I GET TO THE REASONS
FORTY MY POSITION AT LIKE TO
OFFER YOU SOME PERSPECTIVE.
NO DOUBT YOU'RE AWARE THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY OVER
THE PAST DECADE. BEGINNING WITH
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT
ACT TEN YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA
PROBATION INDUSTRY HAS RETOOLED
INTO AN EVIDENCE BASED
PROFESSION.
AS A RESULT WE'VE SEEN A SIXTY
PERCENT REDUCTION IN DETENTION
NUMBERS.
A SEVENTY THREE PERCENT
REDUCTION IN JUVENILE ARRESTS
AND A NINETY PERCENT.
AND NINETY PERCENT OF ALL
JUVENILES WHO ARE MEMBERS OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE COMMUNITY ARE
BEING TREATED IN THAT COMMUNITY.
AS A REFERENCE THIS COLOSSAL
SHIFT IN IT IN OUTCOMES STEMS
FROM THE ADOPTION OF AN EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACH TO CORRECTIONS.
WE SHIFTED FROM DOING WHAT FEELS
RIGHT TO WHAT IS RIGHT.
RESEARCH HAS PROVEN THAT
CONTINUED DETENTION CAN BE AND
OFTEN IS HARMFUL TO YOU.
WHEN ALTERNATIVES TO DETENTION
ARE PERMISSIBLE WE USE THEM.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DELINQUENCY
OFTEN RESULTS FROM A HISTORY OF
TRAUMA. WE STRIVE TO REDUCE
TRAUMA IN THE LIVES OF YOUTH
INCLUDING SYSTEMS INDUCED DRAMAS
LIKE DETENTION.
WE HAVE LEARNED TO TREAT THE
ENTIRETY OF THE USE CONDITION
RATHER THAN SIMPLY RESPONDING TO
THEIR BEHAVIOR AND DELINQUENCY.
WHEN YOU HAVE TO REMAINING
CUSTOM TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC OR
TO PROTECT YOU. WE USE COGNITIVE
RESTRUCTURING PROGRAMS.
SUCH AS MORE RECOGNITION THERAPY
AND AGGRESSION REPLACEMENT
THERAPY. WE USE PRESS SOCIAL
ENGAGEMENT TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT AND
EDUCATION.
WE DO THESE THINGS OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND WE DO THEM IN
THE COMMUNITY. THAT IS TO SAY WE
IDENTIFIED IN ADOPTED THOSE
PRACTICES THAT SCIENTIFICALLY
LEAD TO BETTER OUTCOMES WE
ABANDON THOSE THAT DON'T. AND WE
HAVE SEEN IMPROVED OUTCOMES AS A
RESULT.
WITH RESPECT AB TWENTY TEN AND
THE AUTHORS WELL INTENTIONED
GOALS THERE'S SIMPLY NO EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THE CLAIMS MADE ABOUT
THE USE OF CHEMICAL RESTRAINTS
IN DETENTION FACILITIES.
BUT THE FCC JUST COMPLETED ITS
REVISION OF THE REGULATIONS
GOVERNING FACILITY OPERATIONS
AND THE USE OF O. C. WAS HEAVILY
MODERATED THIRTY SECONDS THANK
YOU BY MANY PRACTITIONERS AND
ADVOCATES.
THE REGULATIONS CONTINUE TO
PERMIT USE AND PROVIDE FOR
REASONABLE MEASURED REQUIREMENTS
ON TRAINING REPORTING.
THE BOARD'S DISCUSSIONS RELATED
TO SEE USE USE FOCUSED ON THE
FACT BEFORE CHANGE THE POLICY IS
MADE THERE'S A NEED TO STUDY THE
USE OF OC. TO DETERMINE WHETHER
IT IS A DETRIMENT OR IN FACT A
HARM REDUCTION TOOL IN
FACILITIES.
IN MY FACILITY ITSELF WE'VE HAD
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOR EVENTS
DOCUMENTED THAT WERE THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN JUSTIFIABLE USES OF
FORCE.
WE HAD SIXTY EIGHT ASSAULTS IN
THE FACILITY THAT WERE EITHER
YOU THOUGHT ON YOUTH OR YOU
FOUND STAFF.
WE HAD FIFTY SIX USES OF FORCE
AS A RESULT OF THOSE ASSAULTS.
ZERO INSTANCES OF PEPPER SPRAY
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF MY STAFF CARRIES
PEPPER SPRAY ON THEM. BUT WE ARE
HEAVILY RESTRAINED IN ITS USE IN
OUR FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
KNOW IT AND THAT'S THE POWER WE
EXERCISE.
THANK YOU COULD HOLD UP FOR
SECOND RATE STEPS UP WARM.
MUCH LIKE TO RECALL ROLE.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY.
CARILLO.
CARILLO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
WORK HERE SANTIAGO.
WHAT PRESIDENT I'M
DO THE PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
A. B. NUMBER ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE?
HE A. TOP ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR NINE SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY NINE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY. ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
SEVENTY THREE. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
SIX ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY TWO. I DON'T OVER
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX A.
B. THIRTY NINETY ONE. I DON'T
OVER TWENTY SEVEN AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE AND ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE A. B. THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE IS OUR MOTION TO.
TO APPROVE THE CONSENT SO MOVED.
I GET TO SO MOVED DRIVE SECOND
FROM MISS CARILLO.
JONES SAWYER I TO ANSWER AYE
LACKEY. CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.-KILEY AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE
SANTIAGO.
SET COUNTERS ADOPTED. AND THOSE
WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE YOU YOU MAY
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
IT'S GOOD MORNING MISS CHAIR
MEMBERS RYAN CHILL AT THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
RISKS ARE REPRESENT THE
PROBATION OFFICERS. IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND WE'RE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES PROBATION OFFICERS YOU'D
ASK ME LOCAL SIX EIGHTY FIVE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS RAINY PERRY
ON BEHALF THE SHERIFF'S
EMPLOYEES HAMBURGER YOU KNOW
COUNTY AND POOR.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS GREG STEVER SECOND
ACCOUNT INFORMATION ASSOCIATION
AND THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
PERMISSION LARGE NINETEEN IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING SHARE MEMBERS JIM
ON BAKER WHO HAVE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION
FROM MANY OF THE REASONS OUR
STATE. THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT SHERMAN IS A A
CORRECTIONS OFFICER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS.
GAVE SILVA LAW ABIDING CITIZEN I
THAT MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSUS SHOT MUCH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA ELEVEN TEN
THE UP YOU HAVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU.
JEAN SOLD AT ALL.
I HAVE WORKED IN THE JUVENILE
DEFENSE I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
ANNE.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
A QUIRK.
SO I'M HAVING A HARD TIME WITH
THIS BILL.
LONG I ED MISTER TRIGO FEW COULD
COME UP.
.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE OF
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER THIS.
SO OTHER STATES.
DO ALLOW SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
BUT FRANKLY I DOUBT THAT THAT.
YELLING AT SOMEONE IF YOU DON'T
STOP YOU'RE GOING TO GO INTO
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT WOULD HELP
STOP THE FIGHT.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
WAY KIDS WHO GET INTO A FIGHT.
.
THINK. SO THE QUESTION IS.
IF OTHER STATES DON'T NEED
PEPPER SPRAY.
STOP A FIGHT.
WHAT DID THEY DO IT APPARENTLY
THERE'S ONLY? A HANDFUL OF
STATES THAT DO ALLOW IT.
.
IF YOU.
I MEAN.
YOU HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT I
CAN ALSO ASK THE SUPPLY I DO I
DO HAVE A RESPONSE WAS PART OF
MY COMMENTS.
FIRST.
SEVERAL STATES THAT TO HAVE
BANNED THE USE PEPPER SPRAY
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE RUMORS
PICTURE SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
THAT'S ONE.
POSSIBLE TOOL. OR DETERRENT
EFFECT.
THE OTHER FACTOR IS THAT MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE ADOPTED THE.
LOWER HOME STAFF RATIOS
SHE HAVE MORE STAFF AVAILABLE SO
THERE'S OUTCOME THERE'S A
COMBINATION OF FACTORS.
THAT ALLOW THE STAFF TO HAVE.
ALRIGHT A GREATER ABILITY TO
CONTROL SITUATION.
EGGMAN EASILY OUT OF HAND SO IN
CALIFORNIA NEW RATIOS ARE ONE TO
TEN. THE PODS ARE TYPICALLY
TWENTY OR THIRTY JUVENILE SO
RIGHT YOU HAVE TO STAFF TO
TWENTY KIDS PER THREE STEP
THIRTY KIDS.
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY GET
DETERRENT IN A REAL HURRY.
SPECIAL IF YOU DON'T HAVE
SOLITUDE YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO.
BUT THE KIDS IN A ROOM STRUCTURE
SITUATION ORDERED TO SAY
ANNOUNCE.
WE ARE ABOUT THE PEPPER SPRAY.
THEN IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
THE CITRUS AND CONTROL.
ALRIGHT OF WHAT TO THE
SUPPORTERS HAVE TO STAY WHAT IS
DONE IN OTHER STATES.
IT'S IT'S NOT REALLY A MYSTERY
WHAT WHAT TO DO IN IS AND. AYE I
BELIEVE YEAH OF THE PROBATION
OFFICERS IN THE STATE ARE ALSO
TRAINED TO DO SOME OF THESE
THINGS ALREADY YEAH. IT'S
CREATING A FACILITY CULTURE
WHERE. INTERVENTIONS ARE DONE IN
ADVANCE.
IT IS
CREATING A CULTURE WHERE YOUNG
PEOPLE FEEL SAFE ALREADY IN
THERE NOT AS INCLINED TO.
START ON STATE SITUATIONS I
THINK EDGAR CAN SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TO THAT.
.
IT'S KNOWING THE TRIGGERS FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE BEFORE THEY ARE
OUT.
.
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
NOT A MAGIC BULLET IT'S IT'S
HARD WORK AND BUT OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE IT I I DISAGREE WITH
THE IDEA THAT CALIFORNIA'S YOU
THERE SO MUCH WORSE.
THEN THE YOUTH AND OTHER STATES
WE HAVE YOUTH AND OTHER STATES
WHO ARE ALSO. DETAINED FOR VERY
SERIOUS OFFENSES FOR MURDER FOR
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
AND YOU KNOW WE KNOW WHAT TO DO
THOSE FACILITIES ARE DOING IT
SAFELY THERE'S NOT REALLY A
REASON WHY CALIFORNIA CAN'T.
MOM ON THE OTHER HAND THERE IS A
REASON MR TARIQ I JUST GAVE
WHICH IS THAT THEY HAVE BETTER
STAFFING RATIOS.
SORRY I YEAH I WAS CONFUSED GUY
HEADS DAMN BETTER STAFFING
RATIOS WHAT ABOUT THAT ARGUMENT.
WELL I MEAN I. DO THINK IT'S
INTERESTING TO HEAR.
TEAR THAT ARGUMENT I YOU KNOW.
I.
DO YOU NOT KNOW THAT WE HAVE.
ANY CONCRETE NUMBERS ON STAFFING
RATIOS FOR EVERY STATE THAT
DOESN'T USE PEPPER SPRAY HAVE
HEARD SORT OF THE ASSERTION THAT
MANY PLACES DO HAVE BETTER
STAFFING RATIOS BUT I. HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY.
ANY INFORMATION TO REALLY BACK
THAT UP BY I DON'T KNOW THAT TO
BE THE CASE ON EVEN SO IF YOU
KNOW THAT THAT POINTS TO. A
DIFFERENT OPTION OUR STAFFING
RATIOS ARE NOT MANDATORY.
.
SYSTEMS IN THIS IN THE STATE ARE
FREE TO HIGH HER MORE MORE
PROBATION OFFICERS MORE
PROBATION COUNSELORS IF THEY
FEEL THAT THEY CAN'T RUN THEIR
FACILITY SAFELY FOR YOUTH. WITH
THE CURRENT STAFFING RATIOS THEY
HAVE. ON THE THAT'S A FLOOR NOT
A CEILING AND SAID SO IT'S MAY
REQUIRE REALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES BUT. I BELIEVE THAT
THAT THE SAFETY OF YOUNG PEOPLE
IN OUR FACILITIES IS WORTH THAT.
.
WELL CLEARLY WHAT THE OTHER
WITNESSES SAID IT I MEAN YOU
WERE PIANIST THERE'S NO DOUBT IN
MY MIND. IF FEWER RESTRAINED.
SOMEONE WAS USING PEPPER SPRAY
THAT'S JUST PLAIN ABUSE.
.
YOU KNOW IN TALKING WITH OUR
ALAMEDA COUNTY PROBATION.
.
I KNOW THAT.
THEY FELT IT WAS ESSENTIAL AND
I KNOW THOSE PEOPLE AND THEY'RE
GOOD PEOPLE.
AND.
THEY JUST FEEL IT'S ESSENTIAL.
ARM AND I KNOW HOW MUCH THEY
LOVE THE PEOPLE IN THEIR CARE.
SO I'M TRYING TO RECONCILE THAT
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING HERE.
ABSOLUTELY AND AYE EAT AYE I'M
NOT SEEING ANY OF MY TESTIMONY
TODAY TO CAST ASPERSIONS ON THE
FOLKS WHO ARE STAFFING THESE
FACILITIES AT MANY OF WHOM
GENUINELY CARE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
IN GOING TO THIS LINE OF WORK.
FOR ALL THE RIGHT REASONS.
I THINK IT IS THE CASE WHEN ONE
HAS A TOOL ONE BECOMES
ACCUSTOMED TO USING THAT TOOL.
ON AND WHILE IT MAY BE DIFFICULT
TO ENVISION DOING THE JOB
WITHOUT IT WE KNOW THAT THAT
STAFFER ADAPTABLE AND ARE ABLE
TO DO IT I'M YOU KNOW WE'VE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH DOCTOR
GRISSOM WHEN HE WAS HERE
VISITING BUT.
STAFF IN OKLAHOMA WERE ALSO
VERY ACCUSTOMED TO USING PEPPER
SPRAY THEY HAD A TWO YEAR
SCHEDULE FOR ELIMINATING ITS
USE.
ON THAT SCHEDULE WAS ACCELERATED
BECAUSE STAFF FOUND THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO ADAPT ON AND AND SO
I I BELIEVE THAT THE THE STAFF
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE JUST AS
DEDICATED TO YOUNG PEOPLE WHERE
WAS THAT. OKLAHOMA.
.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. MR DRACO
SAID MR. CHOW.
WAS THAT PRESUMABLY THE PEPPER
SPRAY HAS HAD LOCKED AREA. A.
AND YOU'RE ALLOWING IT FOR
CERTAIN EMERGENCIES.
ARE HOW WOULD YOU ENVISION THAT.
MORE ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF THE
DETAILS. OF YOU KNOW WOULD STILL
HAVE TO BE WORKED OUT AS TO WHAT
THE STORY IS GOING TO BE BUT I
THINK IF I COULD RESPOND TO YOUR
PREVIOUS QUESTION AND THAT IS
SO.
UP YOU KNOW.
I THINK IT ALL COMES OUT OF
BALANCING ACT I MEAN I THINK A
YOU KNOW WHAT. WE KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE THAT'S BEEN
RACES THAT WISE AT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE OF THE
FEW ONE OF THE ONLY SIX STATES
THAT STILL WOULD. ARE ALLOW THE
USE OF PEPPER SPRAY SO WE LOOK
TO OTHER STATES AS TO WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING ALL TO ALLEVIATE
THE SITUATION AT. AND ARE YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT TAKING THE THE
THE TEMPLE AWAY FROM THE OFFICE
IT WAS TO SENSIBLY SAYING THAT.
ARE YOU CAN STILL USE IT YOU
KNOW INSERT CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
THEY NEED TO USE IT TO DE
ESCALATE THE SITUATION FOR
EXAMPLE IS A RIOT OR SOMETHING.
UP.
BUT WE WANT TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW
IT'S A BALANCING ACT SO WHAT
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT WE ARE
LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELL BEING
OF THAT BUT.
ONCE YOU PUT YA THE THAT ON ON
ONE SIDE OF THE EQUATION AND
THEN THE HARMFUL AFFECTED WHAT
THE PURPOSE PAY WOULD PUT ON. A
THAT THE YOUNG PEOPLE AND ALSO.
SO SO YOU KNOW AS TO WHAT WHAT
IS IT THAT WHAT IS THE FINE LINE
THAT WE DRAWING SO SO THAT IS
THAT THAT IS THAT YOU KNOW THE.
THE.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT IS THE
CHALLENGE AND WE ALSO HEARD.
THAT ARE YOU KNOW YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE A FEAR.
FOR THEIR SAFETY MORE THAN
AVERAGE OF THIS REALLY IS AN
ANSWER TO MY QUESTION ABOUT I'D
I'VE HEARD THOSE ARGUMENTS FROM
YOU BREAK FOR SO I DON'T THINK
WE NEED TO GO FURTHER INTO THAT
THERE'S ARE ON. LONG DAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY.
EDU FINISH RICH WITH.
AND MISTER SANTIAGO.
YEAH NOT THINK YOU ARE THE
SPONSORS AND AND THE AUTHOR.
AND HERE'S WHY STRUGGLE WITH
RIGHT.
DO I FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT
YOU SHOULD HAVE A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT TO I FUNDAMENTALLY
BELIEVE.
THAT WE NEED TO ELIMINATE THAT
SORT OF CULTURAL SOMEBODY.
.
IS DETAINED THEM EMPTIVELY WE
WANT THEM THEIR CAREER
REHABILITATE.
I DO.
AND I'M ALWAYS A FAN OF THE
CARROT THE STICK I'M.
BUT I WHAT I ENVISION THIS RIGHT
I THINK ABOUT IF THIS WOULD BE
TO BE IMPLEMENTED WHAT I WHAT MY
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE.
WITHIN THOSE FACILITIES I
NOTICED THAT SOUNDS.
A BIT WILD SAY BUT I STRUGGLED.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO AND I FIRST
GOT HERE AND WE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
AND I AND A VOTING FOR IT.
BUT THEY WERE MARRIED
CONVERSATION COMMITTED THERE WAS
MERITED POLICY POINTS AS TO WHY.
IT'S STILL NEED TO BE ENACTED
AND I FIND MYSELF.
HERE AGAIN STRUGGLING BECAUSE.
AS I UNDERSTOOD THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN.
IF ADMINISTRATOR HAS TO PROVE IT
IF IT'S IN A LOCKER.
LET ME EXPLAIN SUFFER SECOND
SCENARIO A.
A FIGHT OCCURS.
PULL UP THE PEPPER SPRAY FOLKS
GET DOWN.
WHAT'S THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THAT PEOPLE CAN GET HURT. TEN
FIFTEEN SECONDS.
THE PLACE OUT A SECOND COUSIN
AREA.
BUT BREAKS OUT.
GO GET ADMINISTRATOR LET'S GET
APPROVAL LET'S GO TO THE LOCKER.
A MINUTE OF OF OF OF FOLKS BEAT
EACH OTHER UP.
AND THAT'S BRUTAL.
I TWO EXTREMELY BRUTAL SCENARIO
TO ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
AND THAT THAT'S WHY STRUGGLE
WITH IT BECAUSE.
I.
I WANT TO AIR ON WHAT'S THE MORE
HUMANE THING TO DO.
WITHOUT THE WITHOUT ALL THE
NEGATIVE THINGS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE AN INDIVIDUAL.
INSIDE AIR IT THE I DON'T WANT
HIM TO GET HURT AND.
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT THAT
SORT OF.
.
BEATEN DOWN ON KIDS ARE MISUSING
IT OR THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF IT.
BUT IF I WANT TO TAKE.
STRUGGLE WITHIN THE HIM MOST
MOST MORE HUMANE APPROACH TO DO
IT. IS WHEN THIS BREAKS OUT.
I WANT THAT TO BE CLEAR AND TEN
SECONDS
FIFTEEN SECONDS EVEN OF A MEAN
SPRING.
DO THAT REQUIRE BETTER TRAINING
DOES THAT. WHEN INCLUDING COULD
NOT BE USED A AND WE'RE
STRUGGLING WITH THAT
CONVERSATION WHEN IT COMES A USE
OF FORCE IN THIS BUILDING.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A.
MAYBE YOU SAW FOR THE THE USE OF
SPRAY IS PROBABLY A BETTER PLACE
TO BEGIN THAT SORT OF
CONVERSATIONS I WON'T REITERATE
STAFFING WHICH I WILL REITERATE
ALL THESE. ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS BUT THAT'S REALLY RIGHTS
TROUBLE MISTER CHAIRS IN TERMS
OF.
WHAT'S THE MORE HUMANE THING TO
DO.
PLAYED OUT.
AND I WONDER IF YOU MAY BE THE
IF THE SPONSORS CAN SPEAK TO
THAT OR THE AUTHOR COULD DIRECT
RESPONSES TO TO SPEAK TO THAT
IF.
IF APPROPRIATE.
HA WHICH IS THE REASON WHY WE
ARE DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION
OFFER TWO YEARS I THINK.
FOR.
.
FORCED TO CUT YOU KNOW COME UP
WITH A TRAINING ARE PLANNED TO
YOU KNOW TO BASICALLY.
TRAIN THE OFFICERS ON ON DE
ESCALATION METHODS I THINK YOU
KNOW IT IT YOU KNOW THE SAME
ANSWER THAT I GAVE EARLY IT'S A
BALANCING ACT I MEAN ON ONE
HAND.
WILL YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE HARM
IN ON THE OTHER HAND WHAT IS THE
GOOD SO. ARM WE BELIEVE THAT TO
US LIKE I SAID WE'RE NOT TAKING.
THE CHEMICAL SPRAY AWAY FROM THE
OFFICE OR WAS IT SIMPLY SAYING
THEY CANNOT CARRY THE SPRAY ON
THEIR BODY ON THEIR PUT IN A
DEPOSITION.
AND SO ARM.
SO SO WHERE WHERE IS THE LINE I
MEAN I THINK THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE SO.
WHERE ALLOWING TWO YEAR PERIOD
TO TRAIN THE OFFICERS
OF SO THAT WE CAN ALL KIND OF
FACE SEDAN AND IN THE MEANTIME
WE LOOK AT ALL THE SEATS WERE
PUT TO BEEN DOING?
SO WHAT IS THE MOST HUMANE WAY
OF DOING IT SO SO THAT IS THE.
AND.
MATT MATT I ASKED.
SO MUCH OF THE QUESTION I HAVE
REMAINING WOULD BE THE LET LET'S
SAY SEVERE DOES BREAK OUT.
AND IT ESCALATES.
WHAT WOULD?
HOW YOU THE VISION THAT
HAPPENING TEHAMA HOW MUCH TIME
HOW MANY KIDS GET HURT?
WELL THAT'S A.
VERY.
.
SUBJECTIVE LA QUESTION I I THINK
I YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK WE WANT
DON'T LIMIT THE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND WE DON'T WANT TO
SPECIFY. IS YOU KNOW AS TO HOW
LONG WE SHOULD.
I THINK IT'S A JUDGMENT CALL ON
ON THE PART OF THE OFFICER I
THINK IF THE OFFICER DEEMS IT
NECESSARY TO RESORT TO USING
THIS RATE I THINK THAT'S WHEN.
YOU KNOW WHEN HE OR SHE SHOULD
DO THAT. ARM SO.
YOU KNOW IT IT DEPENDS ON THE
SITUATION I MEAN THERE'S NO
FOUNTAIN YOU KNOW.
RULE AND IN IN DETERMINING DOT I
I BELIEVE SO IT ONE TIME AND
THAT'S ALL. I JUST LIKE TO SAY
AT YOU KNOW.
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST
MENTIONED RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
HAVE
HARD AND FAST RULES ABOUT ABOUT
HOW SPACE SHOULD BE USED THEIR A
COUNTIES THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
PROTOCOLS AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED RESTRICTIONS AND?
ENDS.
THAT'S THAT'S FANTASTIC I THINK
THAT CONVERSATION DOES NEED TO
HAPPEN BY THE WAY I DO YEAH
LUNCH SHOULDN'T SHOULDN'T WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION.
BUT.
WHAT I THINK
WE?
SHOULD RECOGNIZE IS THAT THERE'S
A WIDE VARIATION ACROSS THE
STATE BOTH IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
FACILITIES LOOK LIKE AND WHAT
THEIR POLICIES ARE.
AND SO IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SORT
OF.
AT THIS POINT SAY.
WITH OUR BILL WHAT'S THAT WHAT'S
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
IT A YOUTH MIGHT BE ABLE TO
FIGHT. IS.
I WANTED TO POINT OUT I THINK I
THINK WE KEEP HEARING FACILITY
ADMINISTRATOR ITS FACILITY
ADMINISTRATOR OR DESIGNEES.
SO IT IS POSSIBLE TO PUT
PROTOCOLS INTO PLACE THAT. WOULD
MAKE THAT DOESN'T NEED VERY
EASILY ACCESSIBLE THAT WOULD
HAVE THE PEPPERS RESTORED IN AN
EASILY ACCESSIBLE LOCATION THAT
IS NOT PHYSICALLY ON THE
OFFICERS I THINK WHEN WE'RE
ENVISIONING A SYSTEM WHERE WE'RE
HAVING TO CALL. THE CHIEF YOU
KNOW THE HEAD OF THE FACILITY
AND RUN TO A DIFFERENT ROOM GRAB
THIS BREAK COME BACK.
THAT DOESN'T THAT'S NOT REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL AYE AYE FULLY
CONFIDENT IN THE ABILITY OF
FOLKS TO COME UP WITH PROTOCOLS
THAT FIT WITHIN THIS BILL THAT
WILL. REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
EXCUSE ME.
BEFORE BEFORE IT CAN BE USED
APPROPRIATELY MISTER JIM ASKING
A QUESTION.
OKAY.
THEN I.
I WILL MAKE IT MY LAST THAT'S
OKAY WITH MISTER.
AND SO HERE'S THE OTHER POINT
THAT STRUGGLE WITH RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW SCENARIO BREAKS OUT.
.
I WOULD MUCH RATHER HAVE THAT
THAT.
OFFICER SPRAY
SPRING HERE THAN TO ENGAGE.
IF YOU ENGAGE.
IT DID THAT LEADS TO AIM A MUCH
WORSE PASS
IN TERMS OF RELATIONSHIPS AT THE
MENTION PEOPLE GET HURT NOT TO
MENTION.
BUT IT ESCALATES THE SITUATION.
SOMEONE ME LIES IN THAT BETTER
TO HAVE A CARE IN THE STICK.
THEN TO HAVE BUT NOT THAT HAVE
AN OFFICER ENGAGE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT CONCERNED.
BUT I THINK THAT IT POINTS TO
SORT OF A FALSE DICHOTOMY I I
DON'T THINK.
IN SITUATIONS THAT I'VE REVIEWED
THAT I'VE HEARD.
FROM FOLKS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
IT IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF ARE WE
GOING TO SPRING IN THE AIR OR
ARE WE GOING TO PHYSICALLY
INTERVENE PHYSICAL INTERVENTION
OCCURS WHEN SPRAYS USE.
IN IN MANY IF IN MANY CASES.%
AND SO IT'S NOT AS THOUGH SPRAY
IS STOPPING PHYSICAL
INTERVENTIONS FROM HAPPENING ON
IT'S IT'S USED IN TANDEM.
AND SO I THINK THE IDEA THAT
THERE'S JUST A SIMPLE SPRING THE
ARIES IS IS NOT EXACTLY HOW IT
ACTUALLY WORKS IN FACILITIES I
THINK.
OKAY. ANYMORE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MACHINE.
MIKLOS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS LET
LET ME CLOSE BY SAYING THAT I I
HAVE THEM UTMOST RESPECT FOR OUR
OFFICERS WHO STAFF FOR JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND. AND A FULLY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO OF THE JOB CAN
BE. ARE YOU KNOW AS I STATED
BEFORE THE INTENT OF THE BILL
EYES NOT TO PUT THE OFFICER OR
TO THE YOUNG PERSON IN HARM'S
WAY BUT RATHER TO FOCUS ON THE.
OTHER FOSTERING A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT.
AND RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
OFFICER AND THE YOUNG PERSON.
AND.
YOU KNOW AS I SEATED AGAIN I
MEAN WE'RE NOT COMPLETELY
BANNING THE CHEMICAL.
IN THESE FACILITIES.
WOULD MERELY SAYING THAT
OFFICER SHOULD NOT HAVE. TO
THOSE COMPOSED RIGHT ON THEIR
BODY NOW AS TO THE QUESTION
EARLIER.
LOCAL JURISDICTION CAN MAKE
THEIR OWN DETERMINATION AS TO
WHEN AND WHAT THEY WE HOW LONG
BEFORE THE USE THAT THE
CHEMICAL.
SO ARM SO I THOUGHT I THINK
AGAIN IS A BALANCING ACT AND AND
I THINK OUR YOU KNOW IT IT.
LET ME JUST REITERATE THE FACT
THAT ALL THE THE.
THE OBJECTIVE OF SENDING OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO THESE FACILITIES
IS NOT TO PUNISH THEM BUT ARE
JUST RATHER TO HELP THEM TO OUR
HELP THEM REHABILITATE. AND AND
SO THAT THEY BECOME PART OF THE
CITY THE SOCIETY AGAIN. ANTS SO
WE WANT TO PROVIDE E. A. L.
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S CONDUCIVE FOR
THEM TO TO FOSTER THAT
RELATIONSHIP SO I THINK ON
BALANCE I THINK OUT. YOU KNOW
THIS IS A GOOD TO A GOOD
BALANCE.
THE U. BETWEEN THE TWO SO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT.
AND THANK YOU ARE NOT YET YOU
KNOW THIS IS BEEN A DIFFICULT
ONE AS I'VE GONE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN THE PROPONENT.
AND THE SUPPORTER.
AND.
IN SOME WAY DON'T APOLOGIZE TO
THE. TO THE AUTHOR TO THE
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS THAT.
MY FIRST SUGGESTION.
WHICH WAS TO DO A STUDY.
BECAUSE AS
DE SUPPORTERS CAME IN AND TOLD
ME ABOUT ALL THE DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES THAT USING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THAT WE NEEDED TO TO STUDY IT
SORT IT WE HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN MOVING FORWARD. OF BUT AS.
AS SOMEONE IS ALWAYS TRYING TO
GET TO THE IDEAL UTOPIA DID YOU
HAVE REALITY.
AND HERE WE HAVE REALITY BUMPING
UP AGAINST.
EACH OTHER AND I KNOW BOTH SIDES
HAVE NOT ALWAYS. COMMUNICATED
AND NOT WHEN I FIRST GOT HERE
WHICH MIGHT FULL INTENT WHICH.
WAS TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO FORCE
BOTH SIDES.
COME TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH
THE PLAN.
AND STATE OF.
BATTLING BACK AND FORTH ABOUT
WHAT IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE
MEANS EVEN.
SOME OF THEM THEY'D THE
OPERATIONS AND LA COUNTY WHERE
THEY WAY THE PAPER PEPPER SPRAY
AFTER.
THERE'S AN INTERACTION WITH WHAT
DID YOU LEARN HOW
SEEM LIKE A A A GOOD SOLUTION.
.
BUT AGAIN I STUDY HERE MORE
SOLUTIONS
AND SO.
.
YOU KNOW LIKE I I ASKED AYE PIT
AYE WITH WITH AMENDMENT BECAUSE
I WAS PUSHING.
TO MAKE SURE THAT ON DOES TIME
FOR IMPLEMENTATION
IT'S TIME FOR BY IN.
FROM THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT IF.
I AM EXTREMELY CONCERNED WHEN
TO DON'T HAVE COMPLETE BY AND
FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT IT. BECAUSE OF.
MANY TIMES WE DON'T GET. WHAT
YOU ULTIMATELY WANT?
?
AND SO OP. ED.
EIGHT IT IN ANY CAN SEE THE.
HOW EVEN MEMBERS HERE ARE
CONFLICTED BETWEEN THE SAFETY OF
OFFICERS?
THE SAFETY OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND AND JUST MAKING SURE WE
DIDN'T TAKE THIS TO THIS NEXT
LEVEL. AREN'T WE ALL WANT TO
TAKE TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
AND AND I PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE.
TOLD STUCK. EARLY ON WITH THE
AUTHOR THAT WE NEEDED TO REALLY
DO SOME KIND OF COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY ON THIS AND SO ON. IF HE
GETS OUT.
I WILL.
STILL PUSH
FOR SOME KIND A COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY IF IT DOESN'T GET OUT. DO
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO HAVE.
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY ON IS GOOD
IS IMPORTANT.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE
TO THAT NEXT LEVEL.
OF
OF INCARCERATION FOR OUR YOUTH.
AND HAS TO BE A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT.
IT REALLY HAS TO BE A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
AND SO.
.
MEN SECRETARY CALLED.
DO HAVE MOTION.
THERE'S NO MOTION.
SORRY MISS JUNE.
THIS.
CHAU SORRY.
NOT USED TO THIS FROM WOULD
HAVE.
MISTER CHAIR I EVER YOUR
REQUEST.
I I WOULD LIKE TO VOICE.
AND OBJECTION. TO THE FACT THAT.
TO THESE BILLS HAVE BEEN. ARE
DETERMINED TO BE VOTE ONLY.
AND THERE WAS NO AGREEMENT.
WITH THE AUTHORS ARE NO FILE
NOTICE.
BUT THE.
YOU GOT NO CHARGE TESTIMONIAL.
WELL MISTER.
.
ESTEFAN JUST AGREE TO IT.
I WOULD CERTAINLY NOT WANT TO
SPEAK TO MR FUNG. AND FOR HIM
BUT I I WOULD SAY THAT THERE
CERTAINLY WAS NO AGREEMENT. WITH
ME AND WE JUST GOT NOTICE.
LIKE AN HOUR AGO.
I THINK THAT'S A VIOLATION OF
THE RULES IS WHAT I'M SAYING SIR
WE TAKE. THIS
.
OKAY.
EVEN NINETEEN ELEVEN FOR AB
NINETEEN ELEVEN AND.
MISTER LACKEY REJECTION TO
TESTIMONY ONLY.
THIS INTERNAL COMMITTEE. MOTION.
JOINT THAT'S PRESIDENT
MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT AND
VOTING.
A MOTION TOLD THE COMMITTEE.
JUDGE RECOMMEND AND I.
SO TO SPEAK BILLS.
WE DON'T GET TO HEAR MY.
WE WILL.
YES.
WELL LET'S NOT.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S NOT THE
RADIATOR SEEKING OSHITA.
MAYBE THE LOWER PART OF THE
TURNER TO COME IN HERE THAT WE
GOT THIS FROM. VOLUNTARY YES
BECAUSE I DO THINK I DESERVE.
TODAY. AND YOU WILL BE HURDLE OF
THE OTHER. THING IS A WHOLE
DIFFERENT AND COMPLIMENTARY.
WILL HOLD A BRIEF RECESS AND
CALLED PARLIAMENTARIAN
WE'RE BACK IN SESSION.
YES.
NUMBER TWO ISSUE IS.
FIVE.
WHETHER.
SEE.
THAT MONO.
SELECT.
HOWEVER THE COMMITTEE DOES HAVE
THIS.
BY A MAJORITY OF RESIDENTS VOTE.
TO HOLD ANY BILL.
THAT'S A DECISION OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MAJORITY DOES PRESIDENT VOTING.
OTHER MEASURES.
SECTION LACKS AND LOCAL SAID
WELL REQUIREMENTS.
THE MAJORITY OF US PRESIDENT
VOTING.
RIGHT IN FRONT.
OKAY THAT'S.
THE MAIN PROBLEM THE SIDELINES
OR MISTER SANTIAGO WE NEED TO.
VOTE.
OKAY NEW MOTION TO HOLD A
COMMITTEE CAN WE STILL HEAR
TESTIMONY
OKAY WILL VOTE TO HOLD IN
COMMITTEE. OF THE AND MOTION.
FOR SOME OF SECOND.
CHEERS RECOMMENDING I.
CALL THE ROLL.
EXCUSE ME JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE AYE.
NIKE I CARILLO BECAUSE YOUR AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK ICE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT BILL IS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. BUILDING UP
WELL THANK THANK WAS CHAIR.
MISS MELENDEZ.
AB THIRTY TWENTY SIX
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE THE LAST TIME THAT
DOTSON HAD TO COMMITTEE HEARING
CLEAR SOMETHING UP I WAS THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WITHOUT. I DON'T YOU
KNOW IT'S TRADITION.
IT'S TRADITION.
YEAH WHAT'S UP THE MIKES A VERY
LOW. BUT LOW VOLUME IS.
PRETTY LOW.
.
OKAY SO GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB THREE ZERO
TWO SIX THIS MORNING. WHILE THE
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU TODAY A
POLL TO SECOND AMENDMENT AND
AWESOME FORCES WHAT WAS WRITTEN
IN THE UNITED STATES DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE WHICH IS THAT WE
HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE SELF
EVIDENT. THAT ALL MEN ARE
CREATED EQUAL THAT THEY ARE
ENDOWED BY THEIR CREATOR WITH
CERTAIN INALIENABLE RIGHTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A PERSON MAY
PASSED A RIGOROUS BACKGROUND
CHECK INCOMPLETE NUMEROUS HOURS
OF SAFETY TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
BUT THEY CAN STILL BE DENIED A
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT.
SHERIFF'S DETERMINE WHETHER
SOMEONE HAS GOOD CAUSE TO
RECEIVE A CCW PERMIT AND THIS
HAS BEEN INTERPRETED
INCONSISTENTLY ACROSS ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ISSUED SIX
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR CCW PERMITS LOS ANGELES
COUNTY YOUR COUNTY ISSUED ONLY
FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR
WHILE SAN FRANCISCO ISSUED ONLY
FOR.
KEEP IN MIND LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS ALMOST TEN TIMES LARGER IN
POPULATION IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND SAN FRANCISCO HAS A
POPULATION OF NEARLY ONE MILLION
PEOPLE.
AB THREE ZERO TWO SIX IS THE
SIMPLE BELL. IT GUARANTEES THAT
EVERY LAW ABIDING CITIZEN NO
MATTER THEIR RACE RELIGION
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION HAS THE RIGHT TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES WITH THE
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT. AFTER
PASSING ALL OTHER BACKGROUND IN
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL WOULD DEFINE SHARES
DISCRETION OF GOOD BECAUSE AS
THE NEED FOR SELF DEFENSE
DEFENDING THE LIFE OF ANOTHER OR
PREVENTING CRIME IN WHICH HUMAN
LIFE IS THREATENED. IF A CITIZEN
PASSES THE STRINGENT BACKGROUND
CHECK COMPLETES UNNECESSARY
FIRING TRAINING SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS AND IS DEEMED TO BE
A. TO HAVE GOOD CAUSE AND OF
GOOD MORAL CHARACTER UNDER THIS
STATUTE THEY SHALL BE ISSUED A
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO GREAT INDIVIDUALS LIVING
OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA THE ABILITY
TO APPLY FOR CCW PERMIT UNDER
SHERIFF'S DISCRETION.
THERE IS NO ACCEPTABLE REASON TO
DENY THEM A CCW BECAUSE SELF
DEFENSE IS A RIGHT.
AND IS NOT A PRIVILEGE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
VARIOUS GROUPS INCLUDING THE
PINK PISTOLS THE LIBERAL GUN
CLUB THE NRA GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA JUST TO NAME A FEW.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY
IS NIKKI STOLID FROM THE PINK
PISTOLS AND RAIN SHERMAN WITH
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WITH THAT I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO MY WITNESSES AND ASK
YOU TO CAREFULLY CONTEMPLATE
THIS MAGNIFICENT BILL THANK YOU.
YOU.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YEAH HI
I'M THE KEYS TO OUR.
I'M CALIFORNIA THINK PISTOLS
OUR MODEL OUR GAZE ON GET BASH
WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT ARMED SELF
DEFENSE. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY TWENTY SIX.
OKAY NOW. BARREMIAN MAKE
COUNTIES I LIKE GOOD CAUSE FOR
CCW PERMIT DOESN'T MATTER THEM
HIGH RISK A HATE CRIME ATTACKS.
MOST OF WHICH HAPPEN OUTSIDE THE
HOME AND WITH NO PRIOR WARNING.
WHEN OUR LIVES ARE STEAK AND
EFFECTIVE SELF DEFENSE CHOICES
ARE DENIED BY LAW.
THE LAWS NEED TO CHANGE.
NATIONWIDE SIXTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE CCW PERMITS.
THEY ARE THE ONE THE MOST LAW
ABIDING DEMOGRAPHICS IN THE
COUNTRY.
SHE SHE W. HOLDERS WERE PUBLIC
SAFETY MANAGE WHO ARE HARD OF
LONG BY NOW.
SHALL ISSUE CCW LAWS ARE
REASONABLE BALANCE BETWEEN SELF
DEFENSE IN PUBLIC SAFETY.
DON'T CALIFORNIANS DESERVE THE
SAME SELF DEFENSE CHOICES THAT
AMERICANS IN FORTY OTHER STATES
HAVE HAD. NOW FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS
EQUAL RIGHTS HAS BEEN THE CORE
RIGHT OF ALL CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENTS.
REGARDLESS OF WHO WE ARE WE ALL
DESERVE EQUAL TREATMENT UNDER
THE LAW.
THIS BILLS REFORM WILL BRING
EQUAL RIGHTS TO ARE UNEQUAL CCW
PERMIT SYSTEM.
FOR FREE QUALITY VOTE FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS TRYING SOME OF
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION.
WE REPRESENT THE THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS OF THE RIVERSIDE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUP. AND WE
STRONG SUPPORT AB THIRTY TWENTY
SIX THAT WOULD ALLOW QUALIFIED
SCREENED AND TRAINED RESIDENTS
TO OBTAIN A DOJ APPROVED PERMIT.
TO LAWFULLY CARRY CONCEALED
WEAPON AS YOU KNOW AB THIRTY
TWENTY SIX IS DESPERATELY NEEDED
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY BECAUSE OUR
SHERPAS FAILED.
TO FULFILL HIS SWORN DUTY TO
PROTECT THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS OUR
RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
UNACCEPTABLE IT UNACCEPTABLY.
HIGH LEVELS OF CRIME INCLUDING
VIOLENT CRIME.
THE INABILITY OF OUR SHERIFF TO
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS COMPELS
THEM TO TAKE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
AB THIRTY TWENTY SIX WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL QUALIFIED RESIDENTS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS.
AFTER COMPLETING THE REQUIRED
PAPERWORK MANDATORY BACKGROUND
CHECK AND PAYING THE REQUIRED
FEES THE TOLL PROCESS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TAKES ABOUT TWO
YEARS.
.
TO GET OF THE APPROVAL.
TO LIVE TO THE SHERIFF AND IF HE
DOESN'T LIKE THE UPHILL OR FOR
SOME OTHER REASON THE SHERIFF
MAY DENY IT FOR ANY OTHER REASON
THE SHERIFF MAY DENY THE
ISSUANCE OF THE PERMITS. MRS
RESULTED IN THE DENIAL OF CCW
PERMITS FOR MANY QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS
WELL THOSE WITH PERSONAL
POLITICAL OR FINANCIAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR SHERIFF.
HAVE THE CCW PERMITS APPROVED AN
EXPEDITED.
SHERIFF'S WASN'T HERE TO A CLEAR
CONSISTENT AND OBJECTIVE POLICY.
FOR THE ISSUANCE OF THE CCW
PERMITS
PERSONAL PREFERENCE MUST NOT
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEONE GOES
TO THE FRONT OR BACK OF THE
PERMIT LINE. OR MORE IMPORTANTLY
WHERE THE CCW AB CAN RESULT
MEDLEY APPROVED.
PERSONAL PROTECTION CANNOT BE
LEFT TO THE WHIM OF ONE ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
APPRECIATES THE EFFORTS HERE. TO
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE STANDARD
FOR ISSUANCE OF CCW PERMITS
THEREBY ALLOWING CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TO BETTER PREPARE TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND OTHERS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. AB THIRTY
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING WAS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK IN THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
ONE SHERMAN OR GROUP OF
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISSED
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
THANK YOU SIR.
SO CHAIR FOR THE RECORD AND WE
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SOME
THANK YOU.
WHICH ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRIED TO LOSE ABOUT
THE FIREARMS POLICY COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
GEN MCMAHON A STRONG SUPPORT AND
MISTER CHAIR THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE PREVENTION HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT FIVE ARE NOT
ALLOCATED THREE NAMING
ORGANIZATION ATTEMPTS ARE
THEMSELVES EVERY YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR COMING LAW.
MY NAME STAND KATANA ON BEHALF
OF MY SISTER ALL SINGLE WOMEN
AND CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT A. B.
THIRTY TWENTY SUCKS THANK YOU
SIR.
DUSTIN SHERMAN THREE PERCENT
UNITED PAGERS CALIFORNIA WHERE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
YOU SIR.
GAVE SILVA LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS JEFFREY PERRINE I'M A
CITIZEN AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR COMING ANSWER.
JONATHAN LODWICK I'M A CITIZEN
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JEAN CELL NOT ALL AM THE
LANDLORD AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM.
THIS GARBAGE IN PRIVATE CITIZEN
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
AND LEAD PRODUCT BECAUSE OF THE
SENATE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR FOR COMING IN. AT
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MINUTES APIECE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE UP MY NAME IS ARIF
I LICK COMPETE ON APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF GIFFORD'S LAW CENTER
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
NOW ABOUT FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN
GABBY GIFFORDS AND HAVE TO MARK
KELLY ORGANIZATION HAS WORKED
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO ENACT
EVIDENCE BASED POLICY REFORMS TO
SAVE LIVES FROM GUN VIOLENCE.
AND WHERE REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY WEAKEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO
DETERMINE WHO IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES SHOULD BE PERMITTED
TO CARRY CONCEALED LOADED
WEAPONS.
IN PUBLIC OUR STATE.
HISTORICALLY ALMOST EVERY STATE
PROHIBITED ARE STRICTLY LIMITED
THE CARRYING OF CONCEALED LOADED
WEAPONS IN PUBLIC PLACES.
THESE RESTRICTIONS ARE AMONG THE
EARLIEST GUN LAWS ADOPTED THE
UNITED STATES.
IN THE TWENTIETH CENTURY SOME
STATES INCLUDING OURS BEGIN TO
GRANT LAW ENFORCEMENT SOME
DISCRETION TO ISSUE CCW LICENSES
TO RESIDENTS WHO PASSED THE
BACKGROUND CHECK RECEIVED FARM
SAFETY TRAINING AND OR
DEMONSTRATED. A PARTICULAR NEED
TO CARRY HAD UNLOADED GUNS IN
PUBLIC.
AT THE BEHEST OF THE GUN LOBBY
AND ACTIVISTS HOWEVER MANY SEATS
IF WE CAN THESE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS IN RECENT YEARS.
THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
BEEN AMONG THEM. UNDER EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW MUNICIPAL POLICE
CHIEFS AND COUNTY SHERIFF'S MAY
ISSUE CCW LICENSES TO RESIDENTS
OF THEIR JURISDICTION IF THE
LICENSING AUTHORITY DETERMINES
THAT THE APPLICANT IS A GOOD
MORAL CHARACTER. AND THAT GOOD
CAUSE EXISTS FOR ISSUING
LICENSE.
THIS LEGISLATION WE CAN THESE
REQUIREMENTS BY INSTEAD
MANDATING THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT APPROVED THESE
APPLICATIONS IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT ALSO FUNCTIONALLY REPEAL
STATE LAWS GOOD CAUSE
REQUIREMENT BY REQUIRING
LICENSING AUTHORITIES TO ACCEPT.
AN APPLICANT'S QUOTE STATED
COULD CAUSE WITH ADDITIONAL
INQUIRY. IF HE OR SHE STATES
THAT THEY DESIRE CCW LICENSE FOR
SELF DEFENSE OR CRIME PREVENTION
PURPOSES.
THIS BILL WOULD AFFIRMATIVELY
PREVENT LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE
FROM SUCH APPLICANTS REGARDING
ANY SPECIFIC A UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES PERTAINING TO THE
COURT STATED COULD CAUSE.
BECAUSE THIS BILL WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY WEAKEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO PROTECT
THE COMMUNITIES.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING AMANDA WILCOX
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE. I WILL
BE BRIEF.
THIS CONCEPT HAS BEEN BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE. MANY MANY TIMES
AND IT HAS FAILED EACH TIME AND.
I SHOULD DO SO AGAIN THE KEY
QUESTION THAT THIS LEGISLATION
PRESENTS AS SHE CALIFORNIA. MOVE
FROM BEING AND MAY ISSUE. OUR
CCW STATE TO A SHALL ISSUE IN
UNDER THE SHALL ISSUE SCHEME LAW
ENFORCEMENT ESSENTIALLY WOULD
LOSE THEIR DISCRETION ON
DETERMINING WHO CAN CARRY A
LOADED HIDDEN. GUN IN PUBLIC UP
WE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN.
S. QUESTION AREN'T REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT TO HAVE A SPECIFIC
IDENTIFIED THREAT. INSTEAD TO
JUST ARE ALLOWED TO BE GENERAL.
SELF DEFENSE
WHICH SOMETIMES MEANS I'M ON TO
CARRY GUNS IN PUBLIC THAT IS NOT
AND GOOD ENOUGH REASON. UP
CONSIDERING THE RISKS INVOLVED
WITH HAVING MORE LOADED HITTING
GUNS HONORS IN OUR STREETS AND
IN OUR CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
NO CREDIBLE STATISTICAL
EVIDENCE EXISTS TO SHOW THAT
PERMISSIVE CARRY LAWS REDUCE
CRIME IN FACT EVIDENCE SUGGESTS
THAT PERMISSIVE CCW LAWS MAY
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE FREQUENCY
OF SOME TYPES OF CRIME. AND I
WOULD JUST THAT BAD IF MORE GUNS
REALLY RESULTED IN LESS CRIME
THAN THE UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
THE SAFEST COUNTRY IN THE
DEVELOPED WORLD. IT IS NOT.
I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY.
HELLO I'M SABRINA CHRIS SAID HE
WITH ALL OF US ARE NINE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
PARTY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENIOR NON.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
WHAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS BILL TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE WITNESSES YOU
CAME TO TESTIFY TODAY?
VERY OFTEN WE ARE ON OPPOSITE
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE BUT I
CERTAINLY RESPECT YOUR POINT OF
VIEW.
I WILL SAY THOUGH I WANT TO
POINT OUT A FEW FLIES IN THE
TESTIMONY OF THE OPPOSITION AND
THAT IS THAT IT WOULD WEAKEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO SCREEN.
PEOPLE.
IN AND DECIDE WHO IS.
WHO SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET THESE
PERMITS AM THAT IS FALSE?
BECAUSE THEY STILL HAD TO GO
THROUGH A BACKGROUND CHECK THEY
STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH ALL OF
THE OTHER STANDARDS THAT ARE
REQUIRED RIGHT NOW FOR C. CW'S.
SO THAT IS JUST FLATLY FALSE.
I THIS IS I WILL REMIND EVERYONE
AGAIN A RIGHT.
TO OWN A WEAPON NINETY
PRIVILEGE.
.
I NOTICED ALSO THAT THERE WAS
TWICE.
THE PHRASE. LOADED HIDDEN GUN
IN PUBLIC.
WHICH SOUNDS VERY SINISTER
TIMMY AM PERHAPS THAT'S BY
DESIGN BUT LET'S REMEMBER THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF AMERICANS
WHO HAVE CARRIED A LOADED HIDDEN
GUIDE IN PUBLIC AND ACTUALLY
SAVED LIVES AND I'D. I WOULD
CHALLENGE YOU TO GIVE ME. I
DON'T A HANDFUL ANVIL OF CASES
IN WHICH A CCW HOLDER.
COMMITTED HARM AGAINST ANOTHER
FELLOW HUMAN BEING WITH THAT
LOADED HIDDEN GUN. THAT'S NOT
THE CASE AND WE KNOW THAT CCW
HOLDERS ARE ARE AMONG THE MOST
LAW ABIDING WHEN IT COMES TO GUN
OWNERSHIP. WE KNOW THAT THOSE
ARE FACTS.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WE ARE MORE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE GUNS.
MY REQUEST IS VERY SIMPLE IF
THEY CAN PASS THE BACKGROUND
CHECK IF THEY ARE OF GOOD MORAL
CHARACTER AND BECAUSE AND
STANDING BY THEIR LOCAL
SHERIFF'S.
THEY SHOULD BE ISSUED A CCW
PERMIT ITS ACTIVE UP THERE
SOMETHING IN THE RECORD.
THAT SHOULD KEEP THEM FROM BEING
ABLE TO POSSESS THAT WEAPON WITH
THE CCW.
THEN SO BE IT BUT I THINK THIS
IS RIDICULOUS TO ALLOW FIFTY
DIFFERENT COUNTIES TO ASSIGN
DIFFERENT STANDARDS.
AND IT NO CONTINUITY ACROSS THE
BOARD FOR WHO CAN HOLD A CCW
PERMIT AND WHO CANNOT.
I JUST THINK THAT'S WRONG THIS
IS AGAIN THIS IS A RIGHT IT IS
NOT A PRIVILEGE.
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND DANK UNITE AND NO YOU.
YOUR PASSION ABOUT DESIGN YOU
BROUGHT JUST BEFORE AND ALL OF
TOLD YOU.
THAT ARE EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. UMPIRES ARE
CALIFORNIA CC W. PERMIT HOLDERS.
I'LL DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER GROUP
THAT HAS A ONE HUNDRED PERCENT.
.
POLICY. WOULD IS NO PROPS WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA CCW HOLDERS AND I
THINK BECAUSE ASSIST EXISTING.
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE AND WINDED
WAY LAW ENFORCEMENT HANDLE SINK
YES.
I EVEN MIGHT EVEN MY COUNTY
WE'VE HAD.
SOME CCW HOLDERS BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL REASONS THAT WERE
ISSUED DUMP.
IT'S STILL CARRY WEAPONS PERMITS
BUT EVEN THEN.
WE HAVE HAD ANY INCIDENTS
THAT I KNOW OF HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO UP MY NOSE MORE OF LET'S
NOT.
NEXT I CHANGE SOMETHING A
FORMULA THAT IS WORKING
EXTREMELY WELL THERE'S PROBABLY
GOOD REASONS WHY IT SACRAMENTO
THERE'S MORE CCW HOLDERS ARE
PERMITS LET OUT. THEN CAP AND IN
LOS ANGELES THEY MAY BE VERY
GOOD REASONS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NO.
AGAIN I PROVING AIR ON THE SIDE
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY
KNOW BETTER THAN I DO ABOUT WHO
SHOULD HAVE CCW.
PERMIT AND WHO SHOULD NOT AND
SO UP AGAIN GRETA BILLY AND I
KNOW YOU YOU FEEL PASSION ABOUT
IT AND I. AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
PASSION.
.
BUT I I DON'T WANT TO CHANGE
SOMETHING THAT IS.
WORK WHERE PERFECTION
CCW LAWS WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF
THAT JUST AUTOMATICALLY ASK FOR
IT BUT NO OF WELL I HAVEN'T
GOTTEN IT MOTION CHAIRMAN QUIRK
CUT THOUGH IT WE'RE DONE. WORK
WELL AS A COURTESY TO A
COLLEAGUE I WOULD ASK THAT I DID
JUST MAKE IT UNDONE NO COMMENT
WHAT YOU THAT. EVERY MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN THEY GO TO
A PUBLIC EVENT PLEASE DON'T TURN
OFF MY MICROPHONE WOULD DONE
THAT. EVERY MEMBER IN THIS
LEGISLATURE WHO GOES TO A PUBLIC
EVENT AS SOMEONE THERE WITH A
GUN TO PROTECT BATTLE AND OTHER
CALIFORNIAN SHOULD HAVE THAT
RIGHT AS WELL.
THE SECOND IN.
ON A. B. THIRTY TWENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY AYE AYE
LACKEY AYE GAVIOTA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
THE BILL IS ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBERS ITEMS. FLORAL
NUMBERS.
FIVE AND THIRTY AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY. AND A. B. THIRTY TWO OH
EIGHT. MISTER COOPER.
IF I TOLD.
SO MISTER WE CAN TAKE UP TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FIRST PLEASE.
YES OKAY THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA TASK FORCE.
IN JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL BEGIN ISSUING CANNABIS
LICENSES.
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED CANNABIS
OPERATORS CURRENTLY HOSTED
LICENSES IN THE LARGEST CAMPUS
MARKET IN THE COUNTRY.
IT'S CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET BEGINS ESTABLISHES
FOOTING IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
STEPS BE TAKEN TO WEED OUT THE
LEGITIMATE OPERATORS.
THE COUNTRY'S LARGEST LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET CALIFORNIA'S
ALSO HOME TO LARGEST ILLEGAL
MARKET.
ACCORDING THE HUMBLE STATE
UNIVERSITY FIVE POINT FIVE
BILLION OF CALIFORNIA SEVEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION. IN CANADA
CELLS ARE GENERATED FROM
UNLICENSED NONE RIGHTLY GROWERS
DISTRIBUTORS DISPENSARIES.
THE REMAINING TWO POINT THREE
BILLION CELLS ARE GENERATED FROM
THE MEDICAL MARKET.
TO PROMOTE LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET
PREVENT ILLEGAL MARIJANA
RUSSIAN AND AVOID ILLEGAL
DIVERSION OF MARIJUANA TO OTHER
STATES. CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE
AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO ATTACK THE
MARIJUANA BLACK MARKET.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
ESTABLISHES A TASK FORCE
TO BRING TOGETHER STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
AND INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS TO
DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO COMBAT
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERGROUND
CANNABIS ECONOMY.
OUR STATE WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
YES YOU HAVE WITNESSED IN.
OKAY. NOW ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANKS SO MUCH BILLION UP NO.
A WITNESS ISN'T OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE GLENN BACCHUS ON
BEHALF OF DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
WHEN WE FIRST SAT DOWN TO
ANALYZE THIS BILL WE GET
RECOGNIZE IT WITH A NEW TASK
FORCE THAT WAS STACKED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
PERSONNEL LONG FORCED AND
REPRESENTATIVES WHO OPPOSED PROP
SIXTY FOUR OPPOSED ALMA BUT WE
THOUGHT PERHAPS.
IF YOU'RE.
FAVOR.
POST.
.
WE THOUGHT PERHAPS THE COMMITTEE
COULD BE. THAT NEW TASK FORCE WE
BALANCED TO ADD SOME.
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
OTHER STUDENTS IN THE CONTROL.
PRESS.
BUT THEN AS WE REVIEWED ALMA THE
PROP SIXTY FOUR WE REALIZE THAT
WE'RE SPENDING. TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR TO DO WHAT
THIS ACT.
DESCRIBES.
THIS ACT WANTS TO INCREASE.
THEY WERE IN THE BILL AS ATTACKS
ON ILLEGAL MARIJUANA.
BUT.
PROP SIXTY FOUR ARE HE SPENDS
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
YEAR.
ON STATE PERSONNEL AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
TO ATTACK ILLEGAL MARIJUANA IT
HASN'T EVEN BEEN GIVEN A CHANCE
TO REALLY RAISE REVENUE AND
MATURE AND OPERATE.
BUT THE ACT ITSELF.
CREATES.
A TASK FORCE FOR BCC AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ON THE TASK FORCE
THAT BUREAU CANNABIS CONTROL. IT
ALSO.
PROVIDES FUNDS FOR ENFORCEMENT
AND REGULATION.
AT THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMITTEE CORRECTIONS CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DEPARTMENT FOOD NAG.
STATE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT PARKS IN RAGS.
PARK AND RECREATION STATE WATER
BOARD PESTICIDE REGULATION LABOR
STANDARDS OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
CONTROLLER STATE AUDITOR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
ALL OF THOSE ARE FUNDED BY THE
ACT.
THAT MAKES THIS MEASURE TO
CREATE A NEW TASK FORCE
REDUNDANT.
AND UNFUNDED.
THE.
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EXPERTISE
AND THE RESOURCES ADDRESS ELECT
DID.
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANOTHER TASK FORCE.
THE.
ADVISORY PANEL TO BE SEEN AS I
SAID HAS LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPRESENTATION AS WELL AS
EXPERTS FROM PUBLIC HEALTH DRUG
TREATMENT PREVENTION.
AND THE PROPOSED TASK FORCE
POSTS ALL OF ITS HEARINGS AND
LONG FOR SAID THE CHANCE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE.
TO MAKE ROOM FOR THE.
.
OTHER WITNESS TO SPEAK.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS.
HERE IS.
ALRIGHT THEN I WILL WRAP UP BY.
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY A PREVIEW OF
OUR OUR TESTIMONY APPROACH AS
WELL. THIS IS UNNECESSARY
UNFUNDED BE DON'T USE OF
MARIJUANA ACT SETS ASIDE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
EVALUATE THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ASPECTS.
OF THE LEGALIZATION MARIJUANA.
SET ASIDE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR LOCAL AND
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
RADICALLY LEGAL.
CULTIVATION SALE TRANSPORTATION.
THIS IS SIMPLY A NEEDED THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OTHER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RT QUESTION FROM.
ME NO. PA.
YOU MAY CLOSE WITH COOPER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK OUR
LAST SPEAKER WAS MISTAKEN SOME
OF THE STATEMENTS OF THE THE
STATE FUNDING FOR THE TASK FORCE
IS A STATE TASK FORCE. IS A FOR
A STATE LOCAL TASK FORCE THAT
ALSO HAVE INDUSTRY INVOLVED
INDUSTRY SUPPORTS THIS.
COLORADO IN TWENTY TWELVE
INSTITUTED A.
LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET IN RIGHT
NOW. THEY'RE FORMING A TASK
FORCE
TO DEAL WITH THE BLACK MARKET.
BECAUSE THE ISSUES THEY HAVE IN
COLORADO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ESTABLISHING A TASK FORCE TO
BRING TOGETHER A SPECIFIC GROUP
OF INDIVIDUALS TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM. THEIR CARS A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY APPROACH.
THE TASK FORCE INTO THE ILLEGAL
MARKET NOT THE LEGAL MARKET
WHICH LOVE FUNDS GO TOWARDS.
THIS YEAR THE STATE OF COLORADO
WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER STEPS IN
THAT MARKET. AND THEY'RE STILL
BATTLING BLACK MARK POOL OF
CULTIVATION DISTRIBUTION
EXPORTATION OTHER STATES
COLORADO IS SO THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA GETTING AHEAD OF THE
CURVE.
WE KNOW A LOT A MARIJUANA. IS
GOLF THE BLACK MARKING THOSE OUT
OF DATE SO THIS WOULD.
I'M HELP COMBAT THAT OUR STATE
WE ARE THREE RIVAL MISTER CHAIR.
YES NON.
WHICH COOPER WILL.
COME BACK TO YOUR BILL.
UNTIL THERE'S ENOUGH MEMBERS
OFFER MOTION AN ASSUMPTION AND A
SECOND AND A SUBSEQUENT VOTE.
I MEAN LIKE YOU KNOW NOW THE
CHAIRS GOING TO RECOMMEND AND I
BECAUSE WE DO NEED A TASK FORCE.
THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF WE DO
HAVE A.
WE HAVE COUPLE MEMBERS TO JUST
YOUR TIMING.
YEAH.
AND NOW SECOND.
UP AND THEN WE'LL TAKE A VOTE
BUT WE DO NEED SOMETHING BECAUSE
THE LEGAL.
BOMB.
CANNABIS INDUSTRY WILL
ULTIMATELY.
HARM ILLEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY
IN WAYS THAT ON.
OF MAY BE IRREPARABLE.
AND AND SO.
THIS IS
ONE AREA THAT BOTH MISTER COOPER
MYSELF IN A VICE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
STRONGLY WORKING TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE CURB THE
ILLEGAL MARKET AND WE NEED TO DO
IT NOW WE SHOULDN'T BE WAITING.
A YEAR FROM NOW TWO YEARS FROM
NOW WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO STEM
IT RIGHT NOW. AND AND DOUG
FOURTH CONFIGURATION.
WE NEED MORE I THINK YOU.
MORE. INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE AN
INFORMATION THAT WILL HELP
STRENGTHEN THIS BILL HELPLESS
DEAL TO BLACK MARKET MORE
EFFECTIVELY. I AM SURE MISTER
COOPER WILL BE. WILLING TO TO
LISTEN TO THAT.
WE HAVE A.
MOTION A SECOND.
AB TWENTY BY TWENTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
MEASURES ON CALL.
AND YOUR SECOND ITEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS
AB THIRTY TWO AWAY AS A DISTRICT
BILL NEARLY CRAFTED ZERO WHEN AN
EPIDEMIC OF LARGE SCALE ILLEGAL
INDOOR MARIJUANA GROW HOUSES.
THE CITIES OF ALL GROW IN
SACRAMENTO ESTIMATE THAT OVER
ONE THOUSAND ILLEGAL MARIJUANA
GROW HOUSES DURING OPERATION.
ACCORDING TO STATISTICS IN THE
U. S. D. A. CALIFORNIA WAS HOT
SPOT FREE LEGAL INDOOR GROWS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
WITH POLICE USING OVER THREE
THOUSAND EXCUSE ME THRILLER
TWELVE THOUSAND PLANTS
REPRESENTING SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF ALL PLANTS GROWN
INDOORS TAKEN BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
CROSS THE U. S. AND I'LL REPEAT
MYSELF. THOSE REPRESENTING FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT OF ALL PLANTS GROWN
INDOORS TAKEN BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE'RE TAKING HERE. IN SACRAMENTO
AND TELL GROWTH.
OF THE OPERATORS THE WILL GROW
HOUSES TARGET OTHERWISE QUIET
SUBURBAN NEIGHBORHOODS IN AN
ATTEMPT TO BLEND IN AND OPERATE
UNNOTICED.
HOMES ARE OFTEN PURCHASED BY
CASH AND CONVERTED INTO A
SOPHISTICATED INDOOR GROW
OPERATIONS.
REQUIRING ELEVATED AMOUNTS OF
ELECTRICITY AND WATER.
EAGLE GROWS Y. OF COMMITTEE
REWIRING OF ELECTRICAL PLANT
OILS TO DRAW LARGE AMOUNTS OF
POWER WHICH CAN LEAD TO LET COOL
FAILURES OR OVERLOAD
TRANSFORMERS. RESULTING IN GRID.
POWER INTERRUPTIONS OR FIRES.
IN FEBRUARY FIREFIGHTERS
RESPONDED TO AN ATTIC FIRE ANY
SACRAMENTO HOME UNCOVERED A
LARGE.
NUMBER OF MARIJUANA PLANTS
INVESTIGATORS SUSPECT THE FIRE
WAS CAUSED BY THE ILLEGAL
MODIFICATION OF ELECTRICAL
PANELS.
TWO CHILDREN PRESENT AT THE HOME
WERE TAKEN THE PRICKS CUSTODY
WHILE BOTH PARENTS WERE ARRESTED
ON SUSPICION OF FELONY CHILD
ENDANGERMENT.
VIOLENT CRIMES ASSOCIATED WITH
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROWING
OPERATIONS HAVE ALSO BEEN ON THE
RISE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLDS WERE GUNNED DOWN
OUTSIDE A SUSPECTED SOUTH
SACRAMENTO ILLEGAL MARIJUANA
GROW HOUSE.
POLICE BELIEVE THE TEAMS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO BREAK INTO THE POT
HOUSE AND WERE MET WITH GUNFIRE
FROM A MALE OCCUPANT.
IS CURRENTLY FACING DOUBLE
HOMICIDE CHARGES.
POLICE FOUND EVERY ROOM.
IN THE RESIDENTS WAS ALFA TO
GROW MARIJUANA HELD WAY OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED PLANTS.
HIS RECENTLY AS LAST WEEK THE US
ATTORNEY FOR THE EASTERN
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA ANNOUNCES
SEIZURE OF ONE HUNDRED HOMES IN
A MULTI AGENCY EFFORT TO
CRACKDOWN ON ILLEGAL MARIJUANA
GROW HOUSES.
SIXTEEN THE HOME SEE ISRAEL
GROVE.
THE BUS DEMAND WOULD LARGEST
RESIDENTIAL FOR FUTURE EFFORTS
IN THE NATION'S HISTORY.
THE UNITED STATES ATTORNEY FOR
THE EASTERN DISTRICT A
CALIFORNIA CALL THE USE OF ACID
FOR FUTURE A GAME CHANGER. THAT
MAY HAVE COST THE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATION HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOST DRUG
PROFITS IN THE MONEY SPENT ON
HOMES.
AB THIRTY TOOL A SIMILAR TARGETS
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROW HOUSES
OPERATING IN RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS AFTER NEXT TO
SCHOOLS. PARKS WHO ARE CHILDREN
GATHER.
AB THREE TO AWAY IT'S A NARAL
BILL AND A NARAL PROBLEM FOR A
LIMITED TIME BASIS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY IS.
A CAPTAIN TIM O'BRIEN VEAL GROW
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND WE'VE ALSO GOT FOLKS FROM
CITY SACRAMENTO FABLES AND
KENNEDY PRESIDENT SACKED
SOUTHEAST VILLAGE NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION. INTERMINGLE
PRESIDENT THE AVONDALE WHEN
ELDER NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION.
YES WHEN THE REWRITING REPORT
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OUT MY
NAME IS TIM ALBRIGHT NAM A
CAPTAIN WITH THE APPROPRIATION
PERMIT.
AS PART OF MY DUTIES I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OVERSEE OUR
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT. WHICH
INCLUDES OUR NARCOTICS UNIT.
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX OUR CITY HAS
BEEN COMBAT IN THE PROLIFERATION
OF ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROW HOMES
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
OUR LAST TWELVE YEARS WE HAVE
DISMANTLED HUNDREDS
OF ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROW HOMES
ONLY TO SEE THEM REAPPEAR.
ON NEW RESIDENTIAL STREETS
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS CYCLICAL PRESENCE OF
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROW HOMES
WITHIN THE CITY VELCRO. AFFECTS
THE QUALITY OF LIFE AND
COMPROMISES PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
OUR CITIZENS.
THESE PROPERTIES POSE
SIGNIFICANT FIRE SAFETY HAZARDS.
I AND ATTRACT A CRIMINAL ELEMENT
TO OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AS YOU'RE AWARE THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR ALLOWS
FOR SMALL AMOUNTS OF MARIJUANA
TO BE GROWN FOR PERSONAL USE.
ALTHOUGH WHAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING OAK GROVE IS FAR
DIFFERENT.
WE ARE EXPERIENCING
SOPHISTICATED INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE ENGAGING. IN
LARGE SCALE ILLEGAL MARIJUANA
GROWS.
AND THEN EXPORTING THAT YIELD
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF ILLEGAL
OPERATION TARGETED UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION.
LAST YEAR TO PUT IT IN CONTEXT
THE ELK GROVE POLICE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE. ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE CALLS FOR SERVICE INVOLVING
THE AFOREMENTIONED ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA GROWS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE
THEY'LL GROW POLICE DEPARTMENT
DISMANTLED FORTY ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA GROW OPERATIONS.
WE ARE ON PACE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO FAR EXCEED THAT
NUMBER.
WHAT THE OVERSIGHT OF DUE
PROCESS A. B. THIRTY TWO OH
EIGHT WILL PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH ANOTHER VERY
USEFUL TOOL TO PROTECT OUR
RESIDENTS?
AND THE QUALITY OF LIFE WITHIN
OUR CITY.
OUR BALANCED APPROACH ALLOWS FOR
LAWFUL MARIJUANA GROW OPERATIONS
TO CONTINUE TO TAKE PLACE.
WHILE TARGETING THE HIGHLY
SOPHISTICATED UNSAFE AND ILLEGAL
GROW OPERATIONS WHICH COMPROMISE
THE SAFETY AND QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU TO A SETTLEMENT COOPER
FOR THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS
BILL. AND THE CITY OF OAK GROVE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. THIRTY TO AWAIT
THANK YOU.
GREETINGS AND THANK YOU MY NAME
IS FAYE WILSON KENNEDY. AND I'M
A CO FOUNDER OF THE SALT THESE
VILLAGE NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
AND RETIRED HEALTH EDUCATOR. I
CURRENTLY LIVE IN SACRAMENTO. IN
THE CITY COUNCIL DISTRICT NUMBER
SIX.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE WITH YOU MY DIRECT
FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE OF DEALING
WITH ILLEGAL GROWS. MY STREET
MADE HISTORY ON APRIL FOURTH
MIGHT ONE OF MY CROSS THE STREET
NEIGHBORS WAS ONE OF THE
ILLEGAL.
OF GROW HOUSES THAT WAS TARGETED
BY THE FBI I CAME HOME BETWEEN
MEETINGS ONLY TO BE STOPPED BY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE F.
B. I. I COULD NOT ENTER MY
STREET. BECAUSE THE HOUSE
DIRECTLY ACROSS THE STREET FROM
ME WAS THE ILLEGAL GROW HOUSE I
WAS SHOCKED. BUT NOT SURPRISED
IT IS ONLY.
THAT HOUSE ON APRIL FOURTH AND
IN TWO YEARS AGO HOUSE DIRECTLY
ACOSTA ST FOR ME WHICH WE
SUSPECT IT WAS ALSO LEAGUE A
LIVE. IT ILLEGAL GROW HOUSE
BOTH HOMES WERE LOCATED ONE
BLOCK FROM A LOCAL NEIGHBORHOOD
AND THE PARK. IN OUR COMMUNITY
GARDEN WHICH WE ENJOY.
BOTH HOMES SIT SAT.
THINK WE SORT. CRIME BLIGHTED
UP.
THE GARAGE DOORS WERE REMOVED
NOW WE'RE WORKING WITH TRYING TO
FIND OWNERS OF THE HOME. TO.
.
TO REMOVE THAT.
ALSO WOULD WE FACE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD I LIVE IN. IS NOT
ONLY ILLEGAL GROW HOMES BUT ALSO
A LARGE NUMBER OF LEGAL
MARIJUANA BUSINESSES.
DISTRICT SIX IN PARTICULARLY HAS
A LARGE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL GROW
HOMES.
GOING ON THAT'S REALLY INFECTING
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD IN WE'RE VERY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IT SO WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND LIKE
THAT THINK ASSEMBLYMAN COOPER
FOR SPONSORING IT. AND WE
WORK WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO ADDRESS BOTH THE ILLEGAL GROW
AS WELL AS.
THE OVER NUMBER AN ABUNDANCE OF
MARIJUANA BUSINESSES IN DISTRICT
SIX BANK YOU THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN DAVID JONES ABOUT THE
CITY SACRAMENTO THANK THE AUTHOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
UNFORTUNATELY SHARE THIS.
SAME SCOURGE AT WE HAVE OVER A
THOUSAND GROW HOUSES THAT WE
KNOW FROM* IN AND.
DISTRICT SECRETARY SO WE NEED
THIS TOOL WE GAS FOR MY VOTE.
RT WITNESSES IN.
SUPPORT ANY OTHER WOULD ANY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
BUT THEY NEED TO COME TO MIND.
HERE YOU ARE HERE.
ARE YOU TESTIFYING.
OKAY.
ALL FLOOR YOU HAVE ALL THREE OF
YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES OR.
OKAY.
HOW I AM ELLEN COMP WITH
CALIFORNIA NORMAL NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR THE REFORM OF
MARIJUANA LAWS WERE MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION? WE GOT FOR FUTURE
REFORM AT THE STATE LEVEL
BECAUSE OF THE ABUSES OF
FORFEITURE IT HAPPENS WITHOUT
DUE PROCESS BEFORE A PERSON IS
CONVICTED. EVERYTHING IS SEIZE
THAT THEY OWN IF WE START
OPENING UP FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO WILL TO DO
FORFEITURE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WE'RE GONNA SEE TERRIBLE ABUSES
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES. ARE PASSING VERY
PUNITIVE LAWS AGAINST GROWING
EVEN SMALL AMOUNTS OF MARIJUANA
WITH HUGE FINES INVOLVED PUTTING
LIENS ON PEOPLE'S HOUSES.
FOR FUTURE IF IF THE CARTOONS
OPERATIONS THEY'RE DESCRIBING
COULD BE FORFEITED ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AS A HUNDRED
HOUSES JUST HAVE BEEN IN
SACRAMENTO WE DON'T NEED THE
LOCALS TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
POWER THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST MIKE THAT DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
HERE AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO A. B. THIRTY TWO OO EIGHT.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CIRCUMVENT
THE CRITICAL DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS THE LEGISLATURE PUT
IN PLACE LESS THAN TWO YEARS AGO
WHEN IT PASSED S. B. FOUR FOUR
THREE. SENATOR MITCHELL'S ASSET
FORFEITURE REFORM BILL INSTEAD
THE SPELL BREATHES NEW LIFE INTO
CIVIL ASSET FORFEITURE OF
REMNANT OF THE FAILED WAR ON
DRUGS AND AT A TIME WHEN THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
SEEKING TO REINVIGORATE THE
PROGRAM. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AS
MANY OF YOU REMEMBER THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AS BEFORE FOR
THREE. IT WAS A BILL DESIGNED TO
CURB ABUSES OF THE ASSET
FORFEITURE PROCESS AND IT WAS
DESIGNED TO CURB ABUSES THAT
FELL DISPROPORTIONATELY ON. LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR AT THE HEART OF AS BEFORE
FOR THREE IT WAS THE REQUIREMENT
THAT BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTCAN
PERMANENTLY TAKE AWAY SOMEBODY'S
PROPERTY. THERE MUST BE A
CONVICTION AND AN UNDERLYING
CRIMINAL CASE.
S. BEFORE FOR THREE RECEIVED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND THE
FINAL BILL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED WAS THE RESULT OF
SUCCESSFUL NEGOTIATIONS THAT
RESULTED IN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION THE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND THE
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION ALL
REMOVING THEIR OPPOSITION.
AB THIRTY TWO EIGHT SEEKS TO
UNDO ALL OF THAT WORK BY
PERMITTING THE CITY OF ELK GROVE
TO BYPASS STATE LAW.
AND CONFISCATE AND SEEK AN
ORDER OF FORFEITURE FOR ANY
PERSONAL OR REAL PROPERTY
WITHOUT FIRST OBTAINING A
CONVICTION. INVESTIGATIONS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY FOUND THAT PEOPLE
OF COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AT RISK OF HAVING THEIR PROPERTY
TAKEN BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PUT
INTO THE ASSET FORFEITURE
PROCESS. AND THAT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ARE ALSO PARTICULARLY HARD
HIT.
BY A CIVIL ASSET FORFEITURE
BECAUSE THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO
CARRY CASH FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THE SPELLING ASK YOU TO VOTE
NOW.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CRAIG PAGE WITH A
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION.
WE REPRESENT THE TITLE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO
IN OPPOSITION.
WE WERE VERY SYMPATHETIC TO
CONCERNS THE WORD THAT WERE
RAISED EARLIER BY THE PROPONENTS
OF THE BILL NAY AUTHOR. AND WHY
WE THINK IT'S WELL INTENDED WE
THINK THE SWEEPING IMPACT OF
THIS IS PRETTY PROFOUND. OF THE
SINCE LEAGUE SEEDINGS STATE
CONTROL CONSTITUTIONAL.
OVERSIGHT TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WERE BASED ON
LANGUAGE IS PRETTY VAGUE UNITS
AND TEN.
AND I KNOW THAT THEIR OR OR THE
WAY IT'S WRITTEN AND I KNOW THAT
THEIR IT'S INTENDED TO TO TARGET
SPECIFICALLY GROW HOUSES. THE
WAY IT'S CURRENTLY DRAFTED WOULD
BE A VIOLATION OF ANY ORDINANCE
IN THE CITY OF. A VELCRO.
ANECDOTALLY WE HAD A GROUSE
ACROSS MY IN MY HOUSE WHERE I
LIVE IT DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IT WAS
THERE. AND WHEN THEY FINALLY
FOUND IT HELL WHEN THE WHEN THE
ATTENDANCE FLED. OF THEY HAD TO
DO TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
REPAIR WORK AND IT WAS A
NEIGHBOR THAT I KNEW SO HE WAS
HE WAS AN INNOCENT LANDHOLDER.
WHO DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THERE WAS A
GROW HOUSE IN HIS IN HIS ARM? IN
HIS HOME AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY IN MANY CASES THEY'RE
GOING TO BE INNOCENT LAND
LANDLORDS WERE PROVIDING.
HOMES TO PEOPLE IN MANY CASES
FROM A LOW INCOME.
WORD OR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
WILL NOT KNOWING AND NOT HAVING
THE ABILITY TO MONITOR THEIR OWN
HOMES THEY CAN'T TELL WHETHER
THIS CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. AND TO
BE ABLE TO COME AND SWEEP AND
SEIZE THEIR HOMES I THINK IS IS
A IS A IS A STRETCH AND AND AND
AND UNFORTUNATE.
EXPANSION OF THE LOCAL POWER. A
WE WOULD.
WE WE THINK THAT THE EARLIER
BILL.
WITH THE TASK FORCE TARGETING
THIS MORE SPECIFICALLY AND
FOCUSING ON HOW CAN WE.
DO THIS IS IS A BETTER WAY TO
TO HANDLE THIS AND SEAL TAY'S IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IT'S OUR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE WE WORKED
WITH THE INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE
ACO YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HADLEY IN
SENATOR MITCHELL'S WE AUTHORS OF
THE BILLS THAT RECEIVED
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
TO BETTER CONTROL. CIVIL ASSET
FORFEITURE INCOME LAST SUPPORT
DURING THE STATE. WE DO NOT WANT
TO GO BACKWARDS ONE. TOWN AT A
TIME ALLOWING HOMES CARS CASH
JEWELRY. TO BE TAKEN WITHOUT DUE
PROCESS WITHOUT A CONVICTION.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES OPPOSITION NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.
TIFFANY RIGHT WITH THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION IN
OPPOSITION FOR ALL THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THINKING.
THANK YOU.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
CAROL STRICT MEN.
ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. OUR ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MOST COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
IT'S VERY INTERESTING SO THE
STATEMENTS THAT WERE MADE.
THIS IS ORGANIZED CRIME IS NOT
STREET LEVEL DRUG DEALERS AS YOU
KNOW THESE HOMES.
ELOISE HOMES ARE BOUGHT BY
ORGANIZED CRIME ON THE EAST
COAST IN NEW YORK.
BEING OUT CHINESE IMMIGRANTS.
THE FARM IS HOUSES ARE PUTTING
TYPICALLY UNDER THOUSAND DOLLARS
DOWN ON THE HOUSES.
NICK INVERTING AND INDOOR GROW
SO IT IS ORGANIZED CRIME AND IT
WAS ALSO INTERESTING IN THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO. FOR THAT ONE
DISTRICT DISTRICT SIX THEIR
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND RESIDENTS
PRIMARILY PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
OVER ONE THOUSAND ROLES IN THAT
AREA. IN THE CANNELLA GRILL THE
NUMBER OF GIRLS KNOW GROVER BEEN
QUITE A BIT QUITE A BIT.
EVERYONE THESE ONCE THE
TESTIFIED HAS NOT COME TO MY
OFFICE TO OFFER. LANGUAGE TO AND
TAKE AMENDMENT SIR OFFER
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO DO THIS
BUT IT IS AFFECTING THE
RESIDENTS OF SACRAMENTO IT HAS
BEEN FIFTEEN RISEN SECOND FOR
SOMETIME NOW.
AND.
THERE'S DUE PROCESS IS BUILT
INTO THE BILL.
AND THAT'S WITH A BIG ISSUE AND
ALSO WITH THIS PRODUCT.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WHERE THERE'S TRACK AND
TRACE IT IS TESTED TO MEASURES
NOT PESTICIDES SO WE DON'T WANT
MARIJUANA GOT GOING OUT. TO HAVE
RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS DANGEROUS AND SELL ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HEALTH AND
THAT'S OUR CONCERN WITH THAT SO
WE SAY THAT AND ONE GERMAN
TALKED ABOUT HOUSES BEING FEES
FIRST OF ALL. NOT GONNA SEE THE
HOUSE FROM SOMEONE WHO'S
ILLEGITIMATE HOMEOWNER USER
BEING BOUGHT BY STRAW OWNERS FOR
THAT SO WHEN THAT INDIVIDUAL GET
PER SE THAT'S JULIE
DISINGENUOUS.
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO IS THE
DISTRICT BILL THE FOR THE CITY
SACRAMENTO?
TESTIFIED OF THIS IS AN ISSUE
WITH THEM.
SIMILAR GERA IS OFFICES HERE
THAT CONCERNS THEM YOU'VE HAD A
REPRESENT OF LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT COME FORT AND
TESTIFY.
AND TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES NO
GROWTH IS RAMPANT NOT TO MENTION
THE FIRE ISSUE BECAUSE THEY RE
WIRE THE HOUSES. BECAUSE THE
HIGH POWER DEMAND NOT TO
MENTION.
THE DRUG REPULSIVE HAD WE'VE
SEEN HERE YOUR REPORT FROM THE
FED CITY HERE SAYS SACRAMENTO'S
GROUND ZERO SACRAMENTO GROVE
AREA. SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
ALL INDOOR GROWS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
CAME OUT THESE AREAS THESE FOLKS
NEED AN OPTION.
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THIS IN FIX
SIX.
SO TO ME WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
ASSET FORFEITURE THIS IS APPLES
TO ORANGES COMPARISON IS THERE
ORGANIZED CRIME FOLKS WHO ARE
DOING THIS IS NOT A MOM AND POP
INTO OPERATION. ON THE THE
DOCUMENTATION THERE TO PROVE
THAT SO. I GUESS WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO IS WE DO SOMETHING FEES
RESIDENTS ARE BEING AFFECTED BY
THESE AREAS THE DOROTHY DAY IN
AND DAY OUT AND IS DANGEROUS.
SO WE NEED OPTION THIS IS AN
OPTION TO DEAL WITH IT AND
REALLY HIT THESE FOLKS WORDS
HURTING. NOT TALK ABOUT TIME
HERE.
IT'S TO HIM WHERE HURTS IN THE
POCKETBOOK.
AND I IT COMES BACK TO ORGANIZED
CRIME MEANS YOU'RE NOT STREET
DEALERS WITH THIS.
SO IS FULFILL APPEARANCE THEY
WOULD EVERYONE. AND THEIR
AGAINST EVERYTHING BUT YOU DON'T
LIVE IN THESE NEIGHBORHOODS IN
OUR PERSONS OF COLOR IT DOES NOT
AFFECT YOU HAVE THE HOMEOWNER
HER TALK ABOUT IT AFTER AMERICAN
LEVI'S HER NEIGHBORHOOD.
PREDOMINATELY AFRICAN AMERICAN
THEY DEAL WITH IT DAY IN AND DAY
OUT THEY DON'T DRIVE HOME TO
SOME RICH NEIGHBORHOOD AND SIT
THERE. SO THAT'S MY BIG ISSUE
WITH THIS. LET'S HELP PEOPLE TO
HELP THEM AND RULE INTO TO TRY
AND. FIX THE BILL DO WHATEVER IT
TAKES BUT IT IT'S WORTH IT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OKAY AND.
.
I DO NOT SEE SEE YOUR YOUR
PASSION.
ON NOV SEE YOU. YOU WILL DO ONE
PROTECT YOUR COMMUNITY AND I
ADMIRE YOU FOR THAT.
.
THIS IS A STATEWIDE PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHY I'M SUPPORTING YOUR
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA TASK FORCE
BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
A COMPREHENSIVE.
POLICY ON THIS.
I MAY BE ONE OF THE FEW. THAT
ALSO BELIEVED IT ASSET
FORFEITURE.
WHEN IT COMES TO ILLEGAL
CANNABIS MIGHT BE AN EFFECTIVE
WEAPON. AND GETTING RID OF THE
ILLEGAL.
.
MARIJUANA BUSINESSES AND
CALIFORNIA.
RECYCLING MARIJUANA BECAUSE I
DON'T UPGRADE INTO CANNABIS
THAT'S HOW MUCH I DISLIKED
ILLEGAL.
I'M AFTER AMERICAN. I HAD THE
SAME PROBLEM MY DISTRICT IN LOS
ANGELES A HUNDRED THREE LEGAL
ONES OVER EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
ILLEGAL.
SELECT CROSSES ALL COMMUNITIES
ALL COLORS.
EVERYONE'S AFFECTED BY THE
ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET RIGHT
NOW.
AND SO ON.
I THINK THIS THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE I DO WE MAY HAVE A
POTENTIALLY WE WILL EVENTUALLY
GET. TO AN EFFECTIVE ARM PROGRAM
OF GETTING RID OF ILLEGAL YOU
LIVE YOU TALK ABOUT THE TASK
FORCE ALONG WITH MISTER LACKEY.
WITHIN THE BOTTOM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TO ALSO DEAL WITH IT BECAUSE IT
IS AN EMERGENCY AND NEED TO BE
DEALT WITH.
NOW NOT NEXT WEEK.
NOW.
AND.
.
UNTIL WE.
CREATE JUST TASK FORCE INTO WE
COME UP WITH SOME.
SOME A PLAN THAT WILL NOT HARM
PEOPLE WHO ARE INNOCENT.
THAT THE MONIES THAT YOUR
OFFICERS. ULTIMATELY WILL GET
FROM THIS WILL GO BACK TO
COMBATING CANNABIS AND MAYBE
SOME GO BACK TO COMBATING. ON
DRUG ABUSE
OF TO WE FIGURE OUT HOW WE DO
THAT WITH ASSET MANAGEMENT
UNFORTUNATE TO RECOMMEND A NO
VOTE.
I BELIEVE WE ARE WE DON'T WANT
THE RIGHT TRACK.
WITH THIS BUT WE'VE WE'VE GOT TO
DO WE'VE GOT LOOSE MORE PLANNING
AND I THINK.
.
YOUR AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY IS OF
LITTLE WAITED TO GET US THERE.
IS THERE A MOTION.
IT'S HELD IN COMMITTEE FOR LACK
DILEMMA.
AFTER RECONSIDERATION.
EXCERPTED ACCEPTABLE WOULD
WITHOUT A VOTE
.
SO I HAVE.
FONG.
IF YOU GO.
THE LAST YEAR.
I KNOW I BELIEVE A LITTLE BIT.
IT THANK YOU MISTER FUNG FOR FOR
FOR GREEN TO TESTIMONY ONLY I.
ABSOLUTE TO GIVE ME CHAIR REALLY
APPRECIATE CYPRESS OUTLOOK FOR
WORKING WITH THE U. S. US ON
THIS BILL.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
WHICH HOLDS DUI OFFENDERS
ACCOUNTABLE ENSURING THAT A
PRIOR FELONY DUI CONVICTION.
EVEN IF IT IS A WAY TO REDUCE A
MISDEMEANOR REMAINS A FELONY FOR
PURPOSES OF THE TERMINATION OF A
SUBSEQUENT DUI OFFENSE.
BY THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
A MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING
THE KERN COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS.
EVERY YEAR THOUSANDS OF LIVES
ARE NEEDLESSLY LOSS IN DO YOU
AYE RELATED ACCIDENTS.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE ONE
THOUSAND FIFTY NINE CALIFORNIANS
LOST THEIR LIVES TO DRUNK
DRIVING ACCIDENTS.
AN ASTOUNDING AND TRAGIC
REALITY.
SINCE POINTS AND NINETY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN KILLED INCURRING
COUNTY DO YOU DO TO TEA Y.
RELATED ACCIDENTS.
A MOTHER AND DAUGHTER DIED AT
THE HANDS OF REPEAT DO YOU AYE
OFFENDER JUST LAST YEAR
BAKERSFIELD. AND THERE ARE
TRAGEDIES LIKE THIS HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
CURRENT LAW HAS ALLOWED REPEAT
OFFENDERS TO EVADE PENALTIES
DESIGNED TO CLAMP DOWN ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE REPEAT YOU
AYE OFFENDERS.
WITH A NUMBER OF REPEAT YOU WIFE
UNDERSTANDING AT OVER TWENTY SIX
PERCENT OF ALL CASES. IS
CRITICAL THAT THIS LOOPHOLE IS
CLOSE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW ORIGINAL
FELONY CONVICTIONS TO STAND AS
FELONIES IN LIGHT OFNEW DO YOU
Y. VIOLATIONS. EVEN IF THEY HAVE
BEEN SUBSEQUENTLY REDUCED TO
MISDEMEANORS
THIS WILL HOLD REPEAT TO YOU Y.
OFFENDERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS AND HELP SAVE LIVES.
NOW AFTER SPEAKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE IN MY STAFF I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE NARROWING
IN CLARIFYING THIS BILL TO ONLY
CAPTURE DO YOU WISER ORIGINALLY
CHARGED AS A FELONY. AND ARE
LATER REDUCED TO A MISDEMEANOR.
NOT IDEA WHY THAT IS ORIGINALLY
CHARGED A MISDEMEANOR.
IT NOW WITH ME TO TESTIFY AND
AND AND THE PRESENT IN SUPPORT
ISSUES IN PRICE FROM THE ORANGE
COUNTY JUST RETURNEES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU I AM A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR OFFERING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN THIS BILL
A LITTLE BIT FURTHER. I'M I WANT
TO START BY SAYING THAT THE
APPLICATION OF THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY A VERY NARROW
APPLICATION IT ONLY APPLIES TO
SITUATIONS WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL
HAS PLAYED TO AND BEEN CONVICTED
OF AND SENTENCED TO A FELONY.
THEY GO THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
REHABILITATION COMPLETING THE
OBJECTIVES OF THEIR SENTENCE
ONCE THEY'VE COMPLETED THAT THEY
WILL GO BACK TO THE COURT AND
ASK FOR A REDUCTION TO A
MISDEMEANOR SO THAT THEIR RECORD
NO LONGER REFLECTS A FELONY.
THAT'S A GOOD THING WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THAT AND WE WANT
COURTS TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REDUCE THOSE FELONIES TO A
MISDEMEANOR FOR ALL PURPOSES TO
ALLOW AN INCENTIVIZE
REHABILITATION.
HOWEVER IN THE ONE AREA WHERE
THE FELONY WON'T BE REDUCED TO A
MISDEMEANOR IT WILL BE REDUCED
TO MISDEMEANOR AND ALL OTHER
AREAS BUT IF THE PERSON.
IF THE PERSON SHOULD PICK UP A
NEW D. Y. OFFENSE
THEN THE PRIOR FELONY EVEN
THOUGH IT'S BEEN REDUCED TO A
MISDEMEANOR WILL STILL BE
CONSIDERED A FELONY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CHARGING THE NEW DO
YOU WHY.
AND THAT IS COME CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS.
CONSISTENTLY FOR DECADES FELT IS
IMPORTANT WHICH IS.
OF LOOKING AT RECIDIVISM AND THE
HIGH RATE OF RECIDIVISM INDIE Y.
FATALITIES AND ADDRESSING THOSE
AND CURBING THOSE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WHAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
SAID IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
TREAT REPEAT OFFENDERS.
DIFFERENTLY AND ENHANCED
PENALTIES FOR REPEAT OFFENDERS
INDIE Y. CASES
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW US TO
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE THAT AGAIN
WOULD ONLY APPLY TO A NEGLIGIBLE
AMOUNT OF INDIVIDUALS. IF THE
CASE IS TRIED AS A FELONY TO
BEGIN WITH AND CHARGES OF FELONY
DUI TO BEGIN WITH IT'S USUALLY
SUCH AN ELEVATED CRIME THAT IT'S
UNLIKELY TO BE REDUCED TO A
MISDEMEANOR ANYWAY. BUT IN THE
RARE SITUATION WHERE THE COURT
WILL USEITS DISCRETION AND
REWARD REHABILITATION AND
PROGRAMMING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL RECEIVES
IN THEIR LIFE THAT THEY CAN GO
ON AND HAVE AND A RAP SHEET
THAT'S FREE OF THE FELONY THAT
THEY CAN HAVE A PLAYMATE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
THIS ONLY KICKS AND IF THEY PICK
UP A NEW DIY IF THEY PICK UP A
NEW DEAL AYE THEN THE DA WILL BE
ABLE TO CHARGE THE NEAT NEW DIY
AS A FELONY. BECAUSE THE
INDIVIDUAL IS A REPEAT OFFENDER
WHO WAS ONCE CONVICTED OF A
FELONY DE WHY IT'S A VERY NARROW
LOOPHOLE IT WILL HAVE A
NEGLIGIBLE FISCAL AND PRACTICAL
IMPACT BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH A
LOW NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHO
QUALIFY FOR THIS MOST PEOPLE WHO
GET THEIR SEVENTEEN BE AND GET
THEIR REAP TO THEIR CRIME
REDUCED FROM MISDEMEANOR ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LEARNED AN
IMPORTANT LIFE LESSON WHO ARE
NOT REPEAT OFFENDERS THAT'S WHY
THE COURT IS WILLING TO REDUCE
THEM? SO WE ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT THIS IS
THIS IS NOT A A BILL THAT'S
ENHANCING SENTENCES OR PUNISHING
PEOPLE HARSHLY THIS IS A BILL
THAT IS SQUARE IN LINE WITH THE
IT INTENT OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
IN TREATING REPEAT DI Y.
OFFENDERS DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF
THE NUMBER OF DUI FATALITIES
THAT WE SEE BECAUSE BY REPEAT TO
YOU AYE OFFENDERS AGAIN THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE IN THE
PAST.
THE POTENTIAL EXPOSURE FOR THAT
NEGLIGIBLE NUMBER OF AFFECTED
INDIVIDUALS IS AT MOST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS BUT IT'S
UNLIKELY THAT THEY WOULD GET
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IT WOULD LIKELY
IF THEY DIDN'T GET PROBATION AND
WERE SENTENCED TO PRISON. GET
THAT MID TERM OF ADDITIONAL YEAR
AGAIN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
NEGLIGIBLE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY VERY
SMALL LOOPHOLE DE WIFE FELONIES
ARE RARELY DO REDUCED TO A
MISDEMEANOR. THAT RARE SITUATION
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL HAS
DEMONSTRATED PROGRAMMING AND
REHABILITATION THE COURT SHOULD
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO REWARD
THAT PERSON WITH A MISDEMEANOR
BUT SOCIETY SHOULD NOT BE HARMED
BY HAVING THAT REPEAT DI Y.
OFFENDER BE CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR THE SECOND TIME
AROUND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURTESY. AND INDULGING ME IN MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE INDIA WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MAP IS ONLY HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU.
I ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION I
APOLOGIZE FOR MY VOICE THURMOND
WILL HORSE THIS MORNING.
THIS BILL IS ALMOST AN EXACT
REWRITE OF SB SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
DIED IN COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
AND.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE AT
ONE TIES JUDGE'S HANDS JUDGES
HAVE DISCRETION. TO AS ON. THAT
PROPONENTS SAID SEVENTEEN BE
UNDER PENAL CODE SECTION
SEVENTEEN BE. REDUCED SO.
A WHAT IS KNOWN AS A WAFFLER TO
A MISDEMEANOR.
AND FELONIES THAT ARE CHARGED AS
FELONIES.
ON THEM GO TO A PRELIMINARY
HEARING AND ASK THAT HEARING THE
JUDGE HEARS THE EVIDENCE.
AND HAS THE DISCRETION AT THAT
POINT TO REDUCE THE OFFENSE TO A
MISDEMEANOR. BASED ON THE FACTS
OF THE CASE.
SO BAD THIS IS NOT JUST
REDUCING IT AFTER SOMEONE HAS
BEEN CONVICTED THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO ACTUALLY HERE'S THE EVIDENCE
AND FEELS THAT. THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE OUTCOME.
.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE IF THE
BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED IF IT HAS
THE MONEY APPLAUD BAT BUT THE
WAY IT WAS ORIGINALLY WRITTEN IT
WAS ACTUALLY. PRECLUDED.
THE JUDGE.
REDUCING IT AT THAT POINT.
IT TIES THE JUDGE'S HANDS AND
IT SAYS.
AHLAM IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN
CHARGED WITH A FELONY DUI.
AND TEN YEARS LATER YOU GET
CHARGED WITH THE NEW FELONY DE.
VIGNETTE YOU WILL BE PUNISHED
WITH A FELONY. AND THAT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE.
IT GIVES INSTEAD OF GIVING POWER
TO BOTH.
THE.
JUDICIAL SYSTEM THE JUDGE AND TO
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IT
VIOLATES THE SEPARATION SHIFTED
TO THE PROSECUTOR TO
DECIDE.
IT ALSO REDUCES THE.
.
THE INCENTIVE FOR.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED.
OF FELONY DE YOU WISE TO
REHABILITATE THEMSELVES.
BECAUSE EVEN IF THEY'RE AWARDED
LATER FOR THEIR EFFORTS.
AND IT'S REDUCED AFTER THAT
CONVICTION.
ALL IT WILL STILL REMAIN PRIOR
BULL AND FOR TEN YEARS LATER. SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOU TO VOTE NO
THIS BILL DIED LAST YEAR.
A SIMILAR BILL MORE ASKING YOU
TO VOTE NO THIS YEAR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YES.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
WOULD MAKE AN UNPRECEDENTED
EXCEPTION TO THE PROVISION OF
PENAL CODE SECTION SEVENTEEN BE
THAT PROVIDES THAT A REDUCTION
TO A MISDEMEANOR UNDER THAT
SECTION. MAKES THE CRIME A
MISDEMEANOR FOR ALL PURPOSES.
AND EVEN AS I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE BILL IS TO BE AMENDED THAT
THAT IS STILL AN UNPRECEDENTED
EXCEPTION. ON I WOULD ALSO JUST
TURN AROUND WHAT THE WITNESS I
IN SUPPORT OF THE THE BILL SAID
AND SAY. IN THE VERY RARE
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE SOMEONE WAS
CHARGED AND SENTENCED TO A ON A
FELONY DUI AND IT'S LATER ABLE
THROUGH EVIDENCE OF THEIR
REHABILITATION TO. GET THE JUDGE
TO REDUCE IT TO A MISDEMEANOR
WHICH IS HOW I UNDERSTAND IT
WOULD APPLY NOW. THAT THAT SAYS
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT PERSON THAT
THAT THE JUDGE IS RECOGNIZING
AND THAT SHOULD CARRY FORWARD
EVEN IN THE SITUATION WHERE
WITHIN THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
THEY ARE CHARGED WITH ANOTHER
DUI OFFENSE WE WE ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE.
QUESTION.
ABOUT IT OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THE SPELL.
I THINK YOU KNOW AND I AM AN
ADVOCATE FOR.
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO FIX THEIR
MISTAKES.
BUT DO YOU AYE IS COMPLETELY
AVOIDABLE AND I THINK IN THOSE
RARE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE YOU DO
HAVE A SITUATION.
AND A FELONY DO YOU I AM
PARTICULAR MEANS.
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD SOMEBODY.
AND THOSE RARE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE SOMEBODY MADE THAT MISTAKE
THE FIRST TIME AND AND DID GET
THAT REDUCED.
THEY'RE ON NOTICE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THERE'S A LOT YOU
CAN DO TO AVOID. EVER AGAIN
RISKING THE LIVES OF COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE HAVING
CARRIED YOU I LEGISLATION
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN THE EFFECTS
OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SOMEBODY
DRIVES DRUNK THE WRONG WAY OR
SOMEBODY DRIVES DANCING KILLS.
YOUNG LIVES THIS UNLIKE SO MANY
CRIMES AND CRIMES OF OPPORTUNITY
CRIMES OF NECESSITY CRIMES OF
PASSION THIS ONE IS COMPLETELY
COMPLETELY AVOIDABLE EVEN IF YOU
SUFFER FROM ALCOHOLISM YOU CAN
AVOID GETTING BEHIND A CAR AND
DRIVING A CAR SO I THINK IF IT'S
LEGISLATION I THINK AT SOME
POINT. LEGISLATION I HOPE WE
FIGURE OUT A WAY WE CAN BUT FOR.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH ELLE. CLEARLY I ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS JUST EXPRESSED A VERY
VERY THANKFUL FOR THIS.
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION BECAUSE
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THERE'S A REASON WHY.
FIRST TIME OFFENDERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WHAT RECKLESS
PLEA.
AND
HOW IN THAT INSTANCE.
IF YOU DON'T RE OFFEND YOU
DON'T EVER HAVE.
HE HAD TO DO YOU AYE CONVICTION
BUT IF YOU DO.
DID A DOES COUNT AS A OF A
PROBABLE OFFENSE IN THE SAME IS
TRUE IN THIS INSTANCE.
YOU GOTTA REMEMBER WH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SOMEBODY
THAT HAS BEEN CAUGHT
KAT NOT OFFENDED BUT CAUGHT.
A FOURTH.
THANKS.
THAT ASSEMBLY THAT IS SUCH A
HIGH RISK.
TO OUR PUBLIC.
THAT THE ONLY REASON. THEY GET
HELP.
BECAUSE OF THIS DRASTIC
FELONY CIRCUMSTANCE.
REBUILD TASTE IS ALWAYS OUR
GOAL.
BUT SO IS THE PROTECTION OF OUR
PUBLIC AND SO. VERY THANKFUL FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE I THINK IT
DOES BOTH AND I APPRECIATE YOU
BRING FORWARD THANK YOU.
OKAY AND YOU MAKE.
CLOSE WAS TWICE WHEN I SAY THAT.
WHO WERE ST THIS SUPPLY BILL
WOULD APPLY ONLY AFTER THE
PERSON IS CONVICTED AND WE HAVE
CERTAINLY WE ARE HAPPY TO AMEND
THE BILL TO REFLECT THAT BUT I
JUST WONDER TO JUST CONCLUDE BY
SAYING? WE'RE DEALING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A SECOND FELONY
DUI.
CONVICTION AND A TF FELONY DUI
IS ENOUGH THAT OF OFFENDER. IS
HAS A FOURTH OR SUBSEQUENT DO
YOU AYE OFFENSE IF ID Y. CAUSES
SERIOUS INJURY THAT YOU AYE WAY
PERSON IS KILLED WITH THE
OFFENDER HAS PROVES HE COMMITTED
A FELONY Y. AND SO. THIS BILL IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO SAVE
LIVES AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF TO TO REFLECT TO REFLECT
ANY CHANGE IN THE BE MADE TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL WAS
FORD THANKS VERY MUCH. AND KNOWS
TESTIMONY ONLY AND WHAT I WILL
SUGGEST.
TO THE OPPONENT
TO LISTEN CAREFULLY TO WHAT
MISTER.
THE VICE CHAIR SAID AND.
JEEZ ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM SAN
DIEGO SAID THAT.
THEIR POSITION ON THIS THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT YOU WORK WITH
FONG BECAUSE HE'S WILLING TO
TAKE.
A MEMBERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T. TAKE AWAY JUDGES'
DISCRETION OVER WE LIMIT THEM
SO.
.
THIS GIVES YOU A WEEK.
TO WORK IT OUT. AND DUBBED AS.
AND THEN AS YOU CAN SEE NOW DID
THERE'S A WILLINGNESS.
BONTA COMMITTEES PART TWO OF.
AND HIS WILLINGNESS FROM THE
AUTHOR.
TO WORK OUT SOME SOME RESOLUTION
SO OF I I WOULD. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE OPPONENTS TO BILLS
TO ACTIVELY WORKED WITH MR FONG
WHO'S GRACIOUSLY NAM.
THE CITY WANT TO WORK THROUGH
THIS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY.
MISTER HOLDEN
ESTIMATES VARY AND SAID.
YOU'RE A LOT TALLER THAN HE IS
HE LET YOU GO FIRST.
I'M HOPEFUL.
WE CAN BE VERY EFFICIENT IN
PRESENTING THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE.
THE STUDENTS ARE IN AND WHOSE.
GENEROSITY.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT OUR GREAT AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE.
TO DO THE OFFICIAL.
BUT YOU MISTER CHAIR. I'M HERE
REPRESENT.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE A
BILL THAT WILL INCREASE THE
AMOUNT. OF INFORMATION AVAILABLE
BY CLEARING.
YOUR RECORD.
LAST YEAR I JOINT AUTHORED A
BILL WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
STOP EMPLOYERS FROM ASKING
APPLICANTS ABOUT THEIR CRIMINAL
HISTORY AND GIVE THEM A BETTER
CHANCE AT EMPLOYMENT.
I SUPPORTED THAT BILL BECAUSE A
PERSON SHOULD BE ABLE TO RESTART
THEIR LIFE AFTER THEY SERVE
THEIR SENTENCE.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO DO THAT IF
PEOPLE IDENTIFY YOU ONLY BUY
YOUR CRIMINAL HISTORY.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN AND NEW LAWS CREATED
BY THIS BODY. THERE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A PERSON TO
HAVE THEIR RECORD CLEARED.
IF THEY ARE CONVICTED MORE
PEOPLE THAN EVER HAD THE CHANCE
TO SEEK EXPUNGEMENT. EXPUNGEMENT
OF THEIR RECORDS.
IF THEY ARE ARRESTED AND NOT
CONVICTED MANY DO NOT KNOW THE
IMPACT OF THAT THEIR ARREST THE
REST ON THE RECORD OR THAT IT
CAN BE SEALED. AND THERE'S A
THAT DONE
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE
AWARENESS OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
BY ADDING INFORMATIONAL SIGNAGE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
DURING PROBATION PROCESS.
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT IN MY OWN
DISTRICT WHEN YOUNG MAN WAS
ARRESTED AND LATER.
A LOT GO FOR A CRIME HE COULD
PROVE HE DID NOT COMMIT.
HOWEVER IT WAS NOT UNTIL LATER.
HE REALIZE THAT THE ARRESTS WAS
STILL ON AS BACKGROUND CHECKING
AFFECTING HIS JOB PROSPECTS.
THANKFULLY FOUND OUT IN TIME AND
COMPLETED THE PROCESS THE
DIFFICULT PROCESS.
OF SEALING HIS RECORD.
BUT NOT EVERYONE FINDS OUT THAT
THEY CAN STILL THE RECORD OR
THEY DON'T FIND OUT IN TIME.
THIS BILL SIMPLY MAKE THE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE AT THE
POINT OF ARREST AND TELLS THEM
WHERE TO GO FOR NEXT STEPS.
NO ONE SHOULD BE DEFINED SOLELY
BY THEIR PAST BUT THEY SHOULD BE
GIVEN THE CHANCE TO CREATE A
FUTURE THEY AND THEIR FAMILIES
COULD BE PROUD OF. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
AND.
SECOND.
MARGOT GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
WHERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA.
HERE IN OPPOSITION STAGE YOU
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OFFICE FOR HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH US.
OUR SPECIFIC CONCERN IS
RELATIVE TO THE PROVISION IN
THERE THAT TALKS ABOUT.
PROBATION HAVING TO INCLUDE
THIS IN A PRE SENTENCE REPORT.
UNDER PENAL CODE TWELVE A THREE
POINT FOUR OTHERS ARE THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT SAYS THE
DEFENDANT IS ALREADY REQUIRED TO
RECEIVE INFORMATION ON THIS TYPE
OF RELIEF. AYE SPECIFICALLY IT
SAYS IN HIS ARE HORROR.
PROBATION PAPERS AND SO THE.
INFORMATION ON THIS TYPE OF
RELIEF BEING SOUGHT IS ACTUALLY
RD BEING PROVIDED OUGHT TO THE
DEFENDANT.
THAT I THINK THE CONCERN FOR US
IS THAT THE PRE SENTENCE REPORT
REALLY IS NOT THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS.
THAT'LL LET AND.
CHIEF DAHLE IS SPEAK TO.
SO WHERE WERE REQUESTING THAT
DOT DOT SPECIFIC PROVISION BE
STRICKEN ON BECAUSE IT'S.
ESSENTIALLY RD BEING ACHIEVED
UNDER EXISTING LAW I DO WANT TO
INTRODUCE AYE CHIEF JIM SALLY
WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OF C.
POCKET ALSO THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICER OF SAN LUIS OBISPO.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FEET TALL THREE POINT FOUR
ALLOWS FOR AND IT REQUIRES THE
ADVISEMENT
IN THE PROBATION PAPERS WHICH IS
A MUCH MORE GENERIC TERM THAN
PROBATION REPORT. AS A MATTER OF
PRACTICE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
PROVIDE THAT A AYE BITES ME IN
THE PROBATION ORDERS THAT EVERY
DEFENDANT IS GIVEN.
THAT CLEARLY TAKES.
CARE OF.
HAVE BEEN THAT ADVISEMENT BEING
DONE. YOU CAN CERTAINLY HAVE
ABOUT HAVING IT ALSO INCLUDED IN
THE PROBATION REPORT IS NOT
EVERY.
PROBATION CASE GETS A PROBATION
REPORT IN FACT MANY COUNTIES THE
COMMON PRACTICE IS TO WAIVE THE
PROBATION REPORT  SIMPLY
PROVIDE PROVIDE THE ORDERS OF
PROBATION TO THE COURT FOR THE
COURT TO SIGN. SO THE LAW
CLEARLY AS AS AS IT STANDS NOW
PROVIDES FOR THAT ADVISEMENT IN
PROBATION ORDERS.
THAT IS THE PRACTICE ACROSS THE
STATE BY PROBATION DEPARTMENT SO
THE DEFENSE ARE GETTING THAT
ADVISEMENT NOW IN THE ORDERS
THAT ARE GIVEN TO THEM.
AS A TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF
THEIR PROBATION.
THANK YOU.
A.
DO ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW I JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
I THINK THAT.
THE POSITION THAT OF THE THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS HAVE
TAKEN IS ONE THAT I FIND TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT.
OF SUCH AS IT IS THEIR DUTY TO
TO CARRY OUT THIS PROVISION. AND
I WOULD BE HOPE THAT YOU'D BE
SENSITIVE TO OF WHAT THEY'VE
JUST SAID.
IT'S THE ORDERS LAW AS LONG AS
THIS IS ACCOMPLISHED I THINK
THAT SHOULD BE THE GOAL ANATA TO
CREATE THIS CONFUSION.
YES MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER I'VE
A QUESTION THAT I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T IMAGINE THE AUTHOR COULD
TELL ME BECAUSE THAT WOULD
EXPECT YOU KNOW EVERYBODY ELSE'S
BILL. BUT AND THIS.
WE HAD A TEAM BILL THAT WENT
MUCH FURTHER BUT THESE BILLS
CAMP BOTH PASS AND BE SIGNED
RIGHT THESE DON'T. GO TOGETHER.
ON EXPUNGED AUTOMATIC IS FUN TO
IS THAT RIGHT. I DON'T KNOW TIME
TRYING TO GET MY FUTURE WORK
RIGHT HERE IN COMMITTEE BUT DOES
ANY AYE. THE PROBATION JOKES IT
THIS IS STAFF KNOW.
BUT THIS IS JUST NOTICE THIS IS
JUST NOTICE BUT IF THERE'S
AUTOMATIC EXPUNGEMENT YOU
WOULDN'T NEED NOTICE.
DID TO THE PROBATION FOLKS
REMEMBER THAT BILL.
YEAH FIGHT AGAINST IT CERTAINLY
COULD THE CHAIR UP I CAN'T
SPEAK.
SPECIFICALLY AS TO WHETHER
WITHOUT LOOKING AT THE TWO BUT I
DO THINK AND AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK A CONCERN FOR US AS WELL
AS A FOR HAVING THAT MORE GLOBAL
DISCUSSION ON HOW BEST TO REMOVE
BARRIERS BECAUSE. OPERATION IT'S
A POX CERTAINLY SUPPORTS
REMOVING BARRIERS AND AND
WORKING WITH OUR FOLKS TO TO
SEEK THE RELIEF THAT THERE UP
ELIGIBLE FOR I DO THINK THERE
COULD CERTAINLY BE CONFLICTS AND
ARE ONE OF THESE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO WORK IN LIGHT OF THE OTHER.
DO YOU HAVE A PREFERENCE ARE THE
TWO BILLS.
I THINK I THINK THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AND WE BELIEVE IT'S RD
ACTUALLY BEING DONE UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
PROVISIONS ON WHAT THE COUNTY
JAILS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
NOTICE UNDER THIS THAT SEPARATE
FROM OUR P. SO.
WE BELIEVE THAT EVEN IF THAT
PROBATION REFERENCE IN THIS BILL
STRICKEN DOT IT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING AND THEREFORE THAT
WOULD NOT CONFLICT WITH ANY
OTHER MEASURES HAPPENING. IN
LIKE A COMET THROUGH THE CHAIR I
THINK THE DISTINCTION AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS THE OTHER.
HAD TO DO WITH CONVICTIONS AS
OPPOSED TO A REST I THINK THAT'S
A VERY DISTINCT DIFFERENCE.
IT IS ALSO A SURPLUS IS MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S POSTING SO
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL KNOWS THEY
CAN SEE AND READ AND BE CLEAR
ASSIST MORE INFORMATION BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBERS.
THAT THERE ARE STILL FOLKS OUT
THERE THAT DON'T KNOW YOU SO IT
MIGHT BE DONE IN MAY BE COVERED
IN CURRENT LAW BUT THIS GOES THE
EXTRA STEP TO SAY. WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN TAKE AN
ADDITIONAL EFFORT TO POST THE
INFORMATION.
JUST LIKE YOU WOULD POST AND
LET THEM KNOW THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A CALL.
TO ALERT IF THEY WERE ARRESTED
AND LET SOMEONE KNOW CAN PICK MY
CHILD UP TODAY THAT YOU HAVE
THAT RIGHT. OF THE SAME WOULD
APPLY HERE THAT YOU HAVE THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY. OF THAT.
EXPUNGEMENT IS IT MAY NOT BE
AUTOMATIC BUT THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY GO THROUGH A PROCESS
AND A LOT OF TIMES. YOU FIND
THAT.
INDIVIDUALS ONCE THEY DO FIND
OUT THEN THEY'LL GET A LAWYER.
AND A LOT OF PAY FOR THE LAWYER
AND STYLES OF DOLLARS TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS SO WE CAN
CHECK THE BOX AND SAY. YEAH THEY
THEY SHOULD KNOW.
OR THERE IS A PROCESS BUT YOU
GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND WHEN
MADE IF THEY FIND OUT IN TIME.
IT COULD COST THEM MORE MONEY IT
COULD BE OP PUT THEM IN A.
SITUATION WHERE ARE THEY JUST.
DON'T GO FORWARD AND DO IT ALL
AND SO WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO.
ARE CREATE.
AN EXTRA STUFF.
WILL BE AN EXTRA STEP.
BUT WE THINK TO THE BENEFIT. OF
THOSE WHO NOW. WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BACK OUT AND
REHABILITATE THEIR LIFE AND THAT
MEANS TO BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
COMPETE FOR A JOB. OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO AFFECTED WE COMPETE. OFF
FOR AND HAVE A FAIR LEVEL
PLAYING CHANCE TO TO. OUGHT TO
BE ABLE TO RENT A HOME.
AND SO THESE ARE THE TYPES OF
THINGS HAVE BECOME THE BUILDING
BLOCKS FOR THEM TOO. OUGHT TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET AND BECOME PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS IN THE MORE WE CAN DO
TO HELP EDUCATE I THINK IS A
GOOD THING.
I I LIKE THE BILL THAT WAS NOT
MEANT TO.
TO SAY ANYTHING EXCEPT LIKE THIS
BILL AND I THINK THEY'RE BOTH
GOING TO APPROPRIATIONS AND THIS
SOUNDS LIKE A MUCH LESS
EXPENSIVE BILL SO PERHAPS.
YOU MISTER TEAM CAN TALK ABOUT
HIGHER BILLS TALK TO EACH OTHER
I LIKE TALKING TO MISTER TO I.
THINK YOU
THEN THAT NIGHT DENIED. WITHOUT
THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES I WOULD
THAT IS MY CLOTHES. AND AND I
AGREE IT IF YOU IF YOU TALK.
WITH TO CHOI PROBATION OFFICERS
OH WITHOUT A JOB.
I THINK YOUR POINT IS MAKING
SURE.
IT'S DONE.
AS OPPOSED TO WE ALREADY DO IT
AGAIN ANNALISA.
SUBTLE DISTINCTION BUDDAH AS WE
KNOW A GOVERNMENT.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING IS TO ENSURE THAT IT
GETS OUT.
.
BUT WE HAVE NOTICES ALL OVER
THIS CAPITAL MOUNT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
PEOPLE KNOW.
BEAR RIGHTS AND AND AND. AND
WHAT OUR OBLIGATIONS ARE
A AND IT'S POSTED.
EVERYWHERE NOW SO.
THAT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT IT GETS
DONE I THINK THAT'S WHERE MR
HOLDEN.
AND AND THE SPONSOR THIS BILL
ARE ARE WORKING TOWARDS LIKE TO
KEEP TO BECOME TOGETHER AND
WORKED OUT SUCH AS RECOMMENDED
AYE VOTE.
FOR SIX.
THE EMOTION DEPRESSED BUT
PROBABLY.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JOXER AYE LACKEY.
GOD LEO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
AND MR QUIRK LOST HIS VOICE.
AND YOU NEVER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND THE GENTLEMAN.
WHO ALLOWED MR HOLDEN TO GO
FIRST?
WITH IN HIS AREA.
I HAVE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
AND A. B. THIRTY FORTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES.
A TRAMP PRESENTING A FIRST THE
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKER AND RAPISTS SERVE
THEIR FULL SENTENCES BY ADDING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND RATE TO
THE LIST OF VIOLENT CRIMES.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A FORM OF
MODERN SLAVERY AND SUBJECTS
INCREASING NUMBERS OF VICTIMS.
THE SEXUAL EXPLOITATION IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE STARTING
NUMBER STARTLING NUMBERS OF
CHILDREN ARE FORCED INTO LABOR
AND SEX TRAFFICKING EACH YEAR.
MAKING. THEM SOME OF THE WORLD'S
MOST EXPLOITED AND VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS.
VICTIMS ARE OFTEN SUBJECTED TO
RAPE ABUSE ISOLATION CONFINEMENT
AN EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
TRAUMA.
THE SERIOUSNESS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND RAPE. SHOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE PUNISHMENT FIT
THE CRIME.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SINCE THE
PASSING OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN THE
PERPETRATORS OF THESE CRIMES
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY
PAROLE.
FOR INSTANCE BROCK TURNER.
A FORMER COLLEGE ATHLETE
CONVICTED ON THREE COUNTS.
OF FELONY ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT WOULD HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE
FOR EARLY RELEASE.
HAD HE BEEN SENT TO STATE
PRISON.
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE
STRENGTHENS THE PURPOSE OF PROP
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH WAS INTENDED
TO ALLOW. NON VIOLENT
REHABILITATED OFFENDERS
ELIGIBILITY FOR EARLY RELEASE
AND NOT PERPETRATORS OF VIOLENT
CRIMES.
A WITH ME I HAVE DAN FELIZ OTTO
WITH THE LA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING SICKNESS RETIREMENT.
DAN FELIZ AUTO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION THIS MORNING. OF AS
THE MRS AREA AND.
POINTED OUT.
.
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE UNINTENDED.
CONSEQUENCES PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR INITIALLY DID
HIS REGULATIONS FOR PROFITING
SEVEN.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WOULD HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR. EARLY PAROLE IN
A PROFIT TO SEVEN.
RECENTLY THE.
SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR COURT.
RULED THAT.
ONLY OFFENSES ARE ACTUALLY
LISTED AND.
ARE VIOLENT FELONY SECTION OR
COVERED BY.
PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
THEREFORE.
IN ORDER TO EFFECTUATE WHAT.
YOU KNOW WAS. THE UNDERSTANDING
OF.
THE PROPONENTS WHEN THE CAMPAIGN
FOR PROP FIFTY SEVEN THEY SAID
THAT THESE RAPISTS SEX OFFENDERS
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. OFFENDERS
WOULD NOT BE RELEASED EARLY
UNDER PROFITABLE.
THERE WAS SOME DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THAT WAS TRUE.
BUT THAT WAS WHAT THE
PROPONENTS.
.
CAMPAIGNED ON.
LIKE SAID THE SUCCUBUS SUPERIOR
COURT RECENTLY.
RULED THAT THAT WAS AND IN FACT
THE CASE.
THIS BILL WILL FIX THAT.
PROBLEM THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN THIS
BILL.
OF LAST YEAR WHEN OUR OFFICE
SPONSORED. OF THE TEARS SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE ALL MOVED INTO
THE LIFETIME.
REGISTRATION SECTION BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THE OFFENSE THE
DANGER CSUS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
YEAH. IS BAD IN OF ITSELF BUT
THERE'S ALL THE ASSOCIATED
CRIMES THAT GO ALONG WITH IT YOU
KNOW. ALMOST ALWAYS YOU HAVE.
INDIVIDUALS BEING PROVIDED WITH
SOME TYPE OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEATEN RAPED
ROBBED.
THAT IS A REGULAR OCCURRENCE.
THE IDEA OF A YOU KNOW RAPING AN
UNCONSCIOUS PERSON OR SOMEBODY
WHO SO INTOXICATED THAT THEY
CANNOT. I EITHER CONSENT OR
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
TO ME THAT IS A VIOLENT RAPE.
AND I THINK THAT THE PUBLIC
WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT AS A FORM
OF VIOLENT CRIME. THIS BILL
SIMPLY CODIFIES WHAT. IS THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROPONENTS
OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN WHAT I THINK
THE GENERAL PUBLIC WOULD VIEW AS
VIOLENT CRIMES. AND OF COURSE
YOU KNOW FOR THE.
PILL CHO TO ADDRESS THAT.
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AN IMAC
IS ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES OF
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
FISHER FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
BY ADDING CRIMES TO THE LIST OF
VIOLENT FELONIES AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WOULD PERPETUATE
CALIFORNIA'S EXPENSIVE AND
INEFFECTIVE OVER RELIANCE ON
INCARCERATION. INTERJECT DIRECT
CONTRADICTION TO WHAT THE VOTERS
INTENDED WHEN THEY ENACTED PROP
FIFTY SEVEN. AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE ALSO SINGLES OUT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING FOR TREATING
UP FOR TREATMENT AS A VIOLENT
FELONY A CRIME FOR WHICH
INCREASED PENALTIES HAVE JUST
RECENTLY GONE INTO EFFECT.
THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT PICKED
FIXES A MISTAKE OR PUT TEND TO
AFFECT THE TRUE INTENT OF THE
VOTERS.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN IN THE ARGUMENTS
FOR AND AGAINST PROP FIFTY SEVEN
THE VOTERS KNEW WHAT THEY WERE
VOTING FOR. THE VOTERS
UNDERSTOOD THAT LAYS LENGTHY
PRISON SENTENCES DO LITTLE TO
PREVENT THE TYPES OF CRIME FOR
WHICH THEY ARE IMPOSED. THEY
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE CHOICE THAT
THEY WERE MAKING WAS WHAT WAS
NEEDED TO MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
PRISON COSTS.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT
SECOND GUESS THAT CHOICE.
SERIOUS PENALTIES ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF THE CRIMES
ADDRESSED IN AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WE URGE YOUR NOVEL.
YES ANY OTHER WITNESS YES.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. ARM.
I'M I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT UMAN TRAFFICKING WHICH IS A
MODERN DAY FORM OF SLAVERY AND
THAT'S WRONG. BUT THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY. THE UNDERLYING
CRIMES FOR THE MOST PART ARE
READY ARE FELONIES.
OF THE SENTENCING RANGE INCLUDES
LIFE IN PRISON FOR SOME OF THE
OFFENSES.
OUR LENGTHENING PRISON SENTENCES
DOES NOT MAKE THE PUBLIC SAFER.
IT RESULTS AS WE'VE SEEN AND
MASS INCARCERATION.
ARE ARE COMMUNITIES BECOME
DEVASTATED.
BECAUSE SCARCE PUBLIC RESOURCES
AND UP BEING DEVOTED TO BUILDING
MORE PRISONS. AND INCARCERATING
MORE PEOPLE.
INSTEAD OF SCHOOLS HOUSING AND
HEALTHCARE.
AND YOU KNOW AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER I HAVE REPRESENTED ON
OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN CHARGED.
WITH.
THESE OFFENSES I'VE ALSO
REPRESENTED. VALLEY MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WERE THE VICTIMS.
AND VAGUE BUT DON'T NEED A FALSE
PROMISE OF LOCKING UP THE THE
PERPETRATORS FOR LONGER AND
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME.
INSTEAD THEY NEED HOUSING
EDUCATION COUNSELING.
AND A WAY TO GO HOME AGAIN.
AND THIS BILL DOESN'T OFFER
THAT.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU
KNOW FOR.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCREASE SPENDING ON MENTAL
HEALTH AND TRAUMA CARE AND WE
OPPOSE INCREASE SPENDING ON MASS
INCARCERATION. AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE ANY EXPANSION OF THREE
STRIKES AS A REMEDY FOR THE
STATE'S PROBLEMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISSIONS AREA.
THANK YOU I AM.
I I WOULDN'T AT AT AT TIME WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO DECREASE.
THE OVER POPULATION OF PRISONS
AND TRY TO REHABILITATE AND PUT
PEOPLE BACK INTO NORMAL SETTINGS
IN SOCIETY. A AND I'VE BEEN A.
VOCAL IS WELL AS VOTING ADVOCATE
OF THESE MEASURES.
I WOULDN'T BRING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS FORWARD IF I DIDN'T SEE
THAT THERE WAS A NEED TO ADDRESS
SOMETHING. THAT THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN SOME OVERSIGHT ON AT THE
END OF THE DAY. IT'S HUMAN
BEINGS THAT RIGHT THESE LAWS.
AND SOMETIMES THEY NEED TO BE
TWEAKED OR CHANGED.
A EVEN IF IT'S AS SHORT AS
WITHIN THE TWO YEAR PERIOD
BECAUSE THEY MAY HAVE BEEN SOME
THINGS THAT WERE OVERLOOKED OR.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS IT IN A
COURT IT WENT THE OTHER WAY.
WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT. WAS
UNEXPECTED EARLIER THIS YEAR
THAT HAPPENED.
SO.
THIS IS A VERY SMALL STEP IN
TRYING TO CAPTURE A VERY
SPECIFIC AREA.
A THAT THE.
WAS MEET ME OF SHOULD HAVE
SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN TAKEN
OUT.
AND THAT JUST TO CORRECT SOME OF
THE PREVIOUS STATEMENTS. THIS
WAS THIS DOES NOT LINK. ANYONE'S
PRISON.
TERM VISSER SIMPLY PLACES BACK
A SEVERAL DIFFERENT AREAS OF
VIOLENT SEXUAL CRIMES THAT WERE
TAKEN OUT BY PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEM CHAIR CALLED ROLE.
VICTOR. OKAY.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING LACKEY.
CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING.
SANTIAGO.
SOME DEVIL I.
THE MEASURE DAHLE CALL.
AND NOW YOUR SECOND BILL.
AB THIRTY FORTY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS
I AB THIRTY FORTY WOULD EXPAND
AND CLARIFY CURRENT LAW. THAT
PROHIBITS SEXUAL ASSAULT OF
ANIMALS.
THIS BILL ALSO WOULD EXPAND THE
INTENT ELEMENT OF THE LAW TO
COVER AND ACTS COMMITTED FOR
FINANCIAL GAIN. PROHIBITING THE
SALE OF ANIMALS FOR SEX.
THANK YOU.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE COURT TO ORDER THAT
CONVENE A CONVICTED PERSON TO
REFRAIN FROM.
FROM CONTACT WITH ANIMALS AND
WOULD REQUIRE PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSESSMENT TO BE ISSUED. I DON'T
WANT TO GET INTO THE DETAILS OF
WHY THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT I
WILL JUST LEAVE IT TOO. CHIEF
HENRY BRZEZINSKI WITH THE EL
DORADO COUNTY ANIMAL SERVICES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR JONES SAWYER
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE ON MAKE MY COMMENTS
QUITE BRIEF. MY NAME IS CENTER
PRESENTS CAME ABOARD LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION. ARE STATEWIDE GROUP
REPRESENTS BOTH GOVERNMENTAL AND
NON PROFIT AND LOSS SERVICES
AGENCIES IN OF COURSE WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO MY AGENCY WAS
INVOLVED IN INVESTIGATION
RELATED TO A BELOVED ANIMAL THAT
IT SUFFERED AND WAS OWNED BY A
COMMUNITY MEMBER.
AND AS I LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS
CRIME WAS UPON THE FINEST TYPE
OF ANIMAL ABUSE.
IS THE SINGLE STRONGEST
PREDICTOR OF INCREASED RISK FOR
OFFENDERS TO COMMIT CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
ADA HILLARY BAGLEY WHO HEADS UP
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY ANIMAL
CRUELTY TASK FORCE WAS NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY.
DO A FAMILY. EMERGENCY JUST A
COUPLE MINUTES AGO ON BUT SHE
DID TELL ME THAT IT'S.
YOU HAVE TO PROVE ON
JUSTIFIABLE PAIN AND SUFFERING
WITH THE ADDITION OF THE
DEFINITIONS IN THIS BILL
PROPOSED BY SOME WOMEN IN THIS
AREA.
THIS WILL SOLVE THAT LOOPHOLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OR IN ANY OTHER
WITNESSES A SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATHIS SOME HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION INSPIRED. THANK YOU.
GOING TO TURN MEMBERS CAROLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL WELFARE ASSOCIATION WITH
DEEP GRATITUDE TO MISTER
NAZARIAN FOR TAKING ON A VERY
DIFFICULT TOPIC MOVING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU.
AND EARLIER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR ARM AS AMENDED WE'RE
WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
YOU MAY CLOSE MRS LARRY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
IT'S A VERY COMPELLING FACT WHEN
YOU HEAR ABOUT HOW ANIMALS
SEXUAL ABUSE IS THE SINGLE
STRONGEST PREDICTOR. OF
INCREASED RISK FOR COMMITTING
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE.
SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THE CHEST RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE
WOULD DEAL WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT.
THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED.
CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTY FORTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. JOBS ARE AYE
LACKEY.
WTO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
YOU'VE GOT.
SO AUTHORS WAITING ON AUTHORS
BONTA.
LOW.
AND MISTER SANTIAGO CAN PRESENT
RIGHT NOW OVERLY FREE OTHER.
AUTHORS
.
WHOEVER IT WAS BEEN MOVED BY
MISS GONZALEZ FRESH LECTURE AT
SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK.
MISTER CHAIR OF BECAUSE IS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED I WILL SIMPLY
ASK FOR SUPPORT.
I NINE AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN.
YES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OTHERS BE VERY BRIEF AND SAY.
ON BEHALF OF DIFFERENT LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
WASHINGTON STATE ENACTED A LAW
LAST YEAR TO ENSURE PEOPLE
CONTINUED TEMPERATE POSSESSION
OF ANOTHER PERSON'S GUNS IN
ORDER TO PREVENT SUICIDE OR SELF
HARM. THIS LEGISLATION TO CREATE
A SIMILAR THE CLEAR AND NARROWLY
TARGETED EXEMPTION PROMOTE BEST
PRACTICES AND SUICIDE PREVENTION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU YES.
ALL AMANDA WILCOX WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
I'M FROM NEVADA COUNTY WHERE.
SUICIDE BY FIREARM IS OUR GUN
VIOLENCE ISSUE I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN OUR COUNTY TASK
FORCE.
TO PREVENT SUICIDE IN ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS PROFESSIONALS
FAMILY MEMBERS EVERYONE AGREES
THE NATIONAL GROUPS ADVISE WHEN
THERE'S A RISK OF SUICIDE REMOVE
THE GUN GET OUT DOWN OUT OF THE
HOME. GIVE THE GUN TO FAMILY
MEMBERS OR TRUSTED FRIENDS
OF COURSE RIGHT NOW UP GIVING A
GUN TO OUR LENDING IT DOWN TO A
TRUSTED FRIEND IS BREAKING THE
LAW SO WE NEED THIS EXEMPTION. A
TO DO SUICIDE AND I THINK
THERE'S ENOUGH PROTECTIONS IN
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S NOT
ABUSED.
TIRED YOUR SUPPORT.
YOU.
OPERATING WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE PERSONAL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BUT
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JOSH EGGMAN AYE VOTE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
QUIRK HIGH QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND WE'RE WAITING ON MR BONTA MR
LOW FOR A FINAL. AND.
AND MISTER ALLEN.
FOR OUR FINAL BILLS
.
HA.
WHAT WILL
MISTER BONTA YOU READY TO
PRESENT AND SHARE CARILLO?
IF YOU HAVE TO BUILD UP.
WOULD YOU AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE YOU MADAM CHAIR CAN I START
WITH AB SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE
THE CANNABIS EXPUNGEMENT BILL.
BOTH. THE BALLOT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COLLEAGUES AND STAFF AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE CREATES A
SIMPLER AN EXPEDITED PATHWAY FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
TO TURN THE PAGE BY HAVING
CERTAIN CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
FOR CANNABIS RELATED OFFENSES
AUTOMATICALLY REMOVED FROM OR
REDUCED.
ON THEIR RECORDS
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WHICH
VOTERS PASSED WITH FIFTY SEVEN
PERCENT APPROVAL IN IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN CONTAIN
PROVISIONS THAT. NOT ONLY
PROSPECTIVELY REDUCED OR
ELIMINATED MANY CANNABIS LAW
VIOLATIONS BUT MADE THOSE
CHANGES RETROACTIVE
THIS MEANS PEOPLE WITH FELONIES
MISDEMEANORS FOR CANNABIS
RELATED OFFENSES THAT WERE
CHANGED BY PROP SIXTY FOUR ARE
NOW. LEGALLY ENTITLED TO
PETITION THE COURTS TO EXPUNGE
REDUCE THOSE CONVICTIONS THAT IS
THEIR RIGHT TO SUBSTANTIVE RIGHT
THAT WAS GIVEN BY PROP SIXTY
FOUR. MY BILL DOES NOT CREATE
ANY NEW SUBSTANTIVE RIGHT AT ME
AND REALLY CHANGES THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW THE PROCESS REQUIRES.
INDIVIDUALS WANT TO KNOW THAT
THEIR ELIGIBLE TO TO.
PETITION AND PAY A FEE FOR
FINGERPRINTS AND.
FOR FILING IN THE TAKE TIME OUT
OF THE DAY POTENTIALLY TO TO GO
TO COURT AND HAVE HEARINGS.
ALL OF WHICH MAKES THE
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHT THAT'S BEEN
GRANTED.
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE ENTITLED TO
ITSELF MY BILL PROPOSES?
AND. AT MORE EFFICIENTPROCESS
I THINK IT'S A GOOD GOVERNMENT
APPROACH WHEREBY.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WILL SEARCH THEIR CRIMINAL
RECORD DATABASE TO IDENTIFY ALL.
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS AND THEN
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION TO THE
COURTS.
THE COURTS WILL THEN BE REQUIRED
TO NOTIFY THAT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES THE
PROSECUTORS.
TO ALLOW THEM TIME TO REVIEW
EACH OF THE CASES AND AS IS
THEIR RIGHT UNDER PROP SIXTY
FOUR AND IS NOT CHANGING WITH
THIS BILL
I CHALLENGE ANYONE OF THE CASES
THAT THEY WISH.
IF IN THEIR VIEW THAT INDIVIDUAL
PRESENTS UNREASONABLE RISK OF
DANGER TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND THEN AFTER THE REVIEW
PROCESS THE COURT AND THEN
MODIFY THE RECORD IF THERE'S NO
CHALLENGE BY THE PROSECUTION SO
WE WE THINK THIS IS. A BETTER
WAY TO YOU KNOW WE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE ONLY.
A FEW THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
WHO'VE APPLIED SO FAR UNDER THE
EXISTING SYSTEM THAT LEAVES
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
WHO CAN HAVE THEIR RECORDS
EXPUNGED?
OR REDUCED WHO ARE NOT GETTING
ACCESS TO THIS RIGHT AND WE
BELIEVE THEY SHOULD.
.
AGAIN IT DOES NOT CREATE A AND A
NEW SUBSTANCE A RIGHT IT JUST
BRINGS THAT RIGHT CLOSER TO
INDIVIDUALS AND IS THAT.
EXAMPLE OF OF GOVERNMENT DO
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
PROVIDING THE RIGHTS THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY ENTITLED TO
TO THIS CALIFORNIANS.
.
WITH ME HERE IS.
YOU AND ME SEIZE
HERNANDEZ
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE.
GREAT THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS OWN
USES ARE NOT THIS.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE A LOCAL NATIONAL
NONPROFIT WORKING ON A POLICIES
AROUND HARM REDUCTION CRIMINAL
JUST REFORM AND CANNABIS
REGULATION. I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB
SEVENTY.
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE A BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE AUTOMATIC A
PROP SIXTY FOUR RELIEF FOR
PEOPLE QUALIFY.
WHICH IS HUNDRED OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR.
I'VE ORGANIZED SEVERAL DOZEN
EXPUNGEMENT FAIRS MANY.
IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT
ONLY A SMALL AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
HAVE COME IN FOR PROP SIXTY FOR
RELIEF DUE TO A LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE OF THESE PROVISIONS.
OF AVAILABLE LEGAL SERVICES IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
BARRIERS.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME
CONTEXT AROUND MARIJUANA
PROHIBITION CALIFORNIA IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND MARIJUANA
ARRESTS ARE MOST OF THESE WERE
BLACK AND BROWN. YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE SEE THAT BLACK LATINO Y.
PEOPLE SELLING USE CANNABIS AT
SIMILAR RATES BUT BLACK AND
LATINOS A BLACK PEOPLE MIGHT BE
KNOWS.
ARE TWO TOP TWO TO FIVE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE ARRESTED FOR
CANNABIS OFFENSE
I THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE A NOT
ONLY FOR ADULTS GUY THIS IMPACTS
YOUTH A LOT. IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS WE'VE SEEN THAT.
YOUTH UNDER EIGHTEEN HAVE
COMPROMISED HAVE COMPRISE TWO
THIRDS OF ALL CANNABIS ARE
ARRESTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THIS IS NOT
ONLY AN ADULT ISSUE IT IMPACTS
YOU THEN A LOTTA YOU'D HAVE A
KIND OF HIS CONVICTIONS I NEED A
DRESS THAT I NEED TO GET
ADDRESSED. I'M I'M SURE THAT YOU
ALL THE WHERE I AM PREACHING TO
THE CHOIR BUT HAVING A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION BECAUSE A LOT OF
BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE. OF CLOSING
THE DOOR TAKEN.
EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES HOUSING AND OTHER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ARE THE
RECORD CHANGE PROVISIONS OF THE
PROP SIXTY FOUR HELP RE OPEN THE
DOORS TO SOME OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. ESPECIALLY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE. OTHER RECORD
CHANGE PROCESS IS NOT EASY AYE
AND IT AND IT'S PRETTY EXPENSIVE
IF YOU HAVE AN ATTORNEY WELL
FIRST OFF YOU NEED AN ATTORNEY
TO TELL YOU IF YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
AND I YOU CAN DECIDE WHETHER YOU
ARE THAT'S A LEGAL PRACTICE. ARE
YOU NEED TO GET A COPY OF ALL
YOUR RECORDS YOU NEED TO SUBMIT
ALL THESE DOCUMENTS THIS IS JUST
SACRAMENTO PACKET. THIS IS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PACKET THESE
ARE ALL CRIMINAL FORMS OF PEOPLE
NEED TO FILL OUT THAT REGULAR
FOLKS DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO. AND
SO THESE ARE SOME OTHER
BARRIERS.
YOU NEED A VOTING EACH
COURTHOUSE WERE YOU CONVICTED.
TO SUBMIT THESE DOCUMENTS YOU
NEED TO HAVE A THIRD PARTY
SUBMIT THE PROOF OF SERVICE SO
THAT'S ALSO DIFFICULT TO HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE YOU KNOW GET OUT OF
THE JOBURG SCHOOL TO GOING TO
SUBMIT THESE DOCUMENTS.
.
YOU NEED TO KNOW WHAT COURTHOUSE
WHO WERE CONVICTED YOU NEED TO
KNOW HOW MUCH CANNABIS WAS
INVOLVED IN THE OFFENSE NORMAL
FOLKS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS
YOU NEED TO GO TO. SO DOES LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPERATION OTHERS TO
GET THAT INFORMATION I'LL BE OF
THEM ALL BE FAST.
.
SO THIS DIFFICULT PROCESS IS
KEPT THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
FROM OBTAINING PROP SIXTY FOUR
RELIEF AS OF LAST YEAR'S
SEPTEMBER ONLY THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE YOUTH CASES HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED FOR PROP SIXTY FOUR
REALLY ONLY THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE. AND FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED FOUR ADULTS WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S ABOUT A MILLION CASES IN
CALIFORNIA COULD POTENTIALLY
QUALIFY FOR PROP SIXTY FOR
RELIEF. US EMBASSIES AND SO THIS
IS NOT NEW DOING AUTOMATIC PROP
SIXTY FOUR RECORD CHANGE SOME
FRANCISCO IS DOING IT THE DA'S
PUSHING FOR ACTS OF THE EAGLE
OTHER DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ALSO
MOVING FORWARD. THAT'S GONNA
HELP ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS A VERY. VERY SMALL
DROP IN THE BUCKET COMPARED TO
THE MILLION THAT QUALIFY.
NOW THE CALIFORNIA. AND ITS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE PROFITING
AND ITS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
PROFITING OFF THE SALES OF
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS A WE MUST
INVEST IN HELPING THOSE IMPACTED
BY MARIJUANA PROHIBITION. THIS
IS RACIAL JUSTICE AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES ON SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA.
THANK YOU.
.
YOUR THING BY RUN FOR OFFICE.
YEAH YEAH EVERY COUPLE YEARS.
WHERE THEY WERE BEFORE I START
IT WOULD DISTRIBUTE LIVE? YEAH
Y. YOU OUT THERE THAT.
YEAH YOU GOT A LONG WAY TO GO.
PEOPLE. JUST LOOK AT THAT.
BUT BUT I THINK PEOPLE ARE
PRETTY CHEAP PROVISIONS. MICHAEL
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT ONLY THOSE
WHO CAN AFFORD LEGAL SERVICES
CURRENTLY THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE ARE NO
PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICES WHERE
THEY CAN'T JUST GOING GET
SERVICES. AND A LOT OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE THAT WILL NEVER
GET ACCESS TO HAVING AN ATTORNEY
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS TRIED TO
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO DO THIS AND
THEY'RE ONLY IN IT TO MAKE A
QUICK BUCK WEAVER FROM PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ACROSS THE STATE. THAT
THERE'S BEEN MANY FILINGS WITH
ERRORS SUBMITTED BY PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS INSTEAD OF GETTING A
FULL JUST MITCHELL FOR PROPHECY
PORKY'S WHICH ENTITLED TO THE.
ENTITLED TO UNDER THE LAW
THERE'LL BE SUBMITTING FOR LIKE
REDUCTIONS
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S A ONE
ADVOCATE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALERT ANY OTHER WITNESSES THE
SUPPORT.
HI ELLEN COME WITH CALIFORNIA
NORMAL WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL A BIG REASON PEOPLE
VOTED IN FAVOR OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR WAS THAT IT WAS GOING TO
BRING JUSTICE TO ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN
CONVICTED. BUT THEY'RE ALL
CAUGHT UP IN LITTLE PAPERWORK
PROBLEMS.
I LOVE THAT THIS WAS BROUGHT BY
A NAME A NOTE.
LARRY DOYLE A BATTLE CONFERENCE
A CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M A SNUGGLE ME HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARGOT GEORGIA MY HALF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND CONSTITUENT OF
MR MANTAS HAPPEN AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF CANA CRAFT
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
ACHY.
SABINE ACROSS CITY ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF US ARE NINE BAY AREA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGELIQUE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. YOU.
ROXANNE UP ECONOMICALLY ON
BEHALF OF WE DROP CANADA SLAVERY
AND THE LONG BEACH COLLECTIVE
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
REILLY ON BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THE BILL. AT THIS TIME
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT OPERATIONAL AND PRACTICAL
IMPACTS ON COURTS AND HOW. THEY
CAN M. EXPENDS THESE RECORDS.
HOWEVER WE'VE HAD AN ON GOING
DOLLAR DIALOGUE WITH THE MEMBERS
OFFICE WE LOOK CAN LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO. LOOK FOR WAYS
TO MAKE THE BILL MORE EFFICIENT
AND.
NOT BE SO BURDENSOME ON THE
COURTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT.
OUR NIC.
QUESTIONS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MOST BONTA.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IN
COLLEGE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL WILL FOR THE
CREATE REAL DIFFERENCES IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES BRING THEM CLOSER
TO JOBS CLOSER TO HOUSING AND
OTHER SERVICES AND. WE ALL KNOW
THAT.
.
THAT VULNERABLE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE WAR ON DRUGS THIS WILL
PROVIDE SOME SEMBLANCE OF
JUSTICE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
DEAR MOTION.
MISTER QUIRK MOVEMENTS CARILLO
SECOND.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE DANCER AYE
LACKEY.
CARILLO. CAVIAR AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
KILEY QUIRK
HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE HAVE MR ALLEN OLD
MISS ABOUT YOU HAVE.
I THINK A BILL I'M SORRY UP IN A
HURRY I SAW.
WE HAD OUR SECOND TO BEGIN MAYBE
RATE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FIVE. WHICH.
WOULD DEPOLITICIZE INCREASE THE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PARDON AND
COMMUTATION PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONVICTED OF A CRIME MAY APPLY
FOR UP A GUBERNATORIAL PART IN
OR COMMUTATION. IF THEY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED EXEMPLARY BEHAVIOR
THE PARDON RESOURCES SPECIFIED
RIGHTS THAT PEOPLE LOSE BEEN
CONVICTED OF A FELONY SUCH AS
THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN A
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE.
A PARDON ALSO ALLOWS FOR
IMMIGRANTS THREE OPENED THEIR
DEPORTATION CASES.
ALTHOUGH THOSE CONVICTED OF
CRIMES MAY SPEND YEARS
REHABILITATING THEMSELVES INTO
PRODUCTIVE AND LAW ABIDING
RESIDENTS IMMIGRANTS ARE FACED
WITH THE RISK OF BEING. SENT TO
COUNTRIES WHERE THEY HAVE LITTLE
OR NO TIES TO THE SHARP INCREASE
IN IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
ARRESTS ONE OF THE PRIMARY
REASONS PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SEEKING
PART IN THIS. IS TO OBTAIN
POTENTIAL RELIEF FROM
DEPORTATION PARDONS ARE ONE OF
THE ONLY AVAILABLE AVENUES OF
RELIEF FOR IMMIGRANTS FACING
DEPORTATION.
SINCE THE SO CALLED TOUGH ON
CRIME POLICIES WERE ENACTED IN
THE NINETEEN NINETIES CALIFORNIA
GOVERNORS HAVE GRANTED VERY FEW
PARDONS FROM NINETEEN NINETY ONE
TO TWENTY TEN THREE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S GRANTED A TOTAL OF
JUST TWENTY EIGHT. PARDONS BY
CONTRAST GOVERNOR BROWN HAS
GRANTED ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN PARDONS THUS FAR IN HIS
THIRD AND FOURTH TERMS. GOVERNOR
BROWN RECENTLY ISSUED SEVERAL
PARDONS TO IMMIGRANTS FACING
IMMINENT DEPORTATION WE APPLAUD.
THESE ACTIONS OF THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN FOR THIS FUTURE GOVERNORS
MAY NOT BE WILLING TO GRANT
PARDONS ESPECIALLY IN THEIR
FIRST TERM THERE'S ALSO LITTLE
TRANSPARENCY. AROUND THE PART IN
PROCESS INDIVIDUALS WHO APPLY
FOR PARDONS DO NOT KNOW IF THE
REQUEST IS RECEIVED THEY DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S BEEN REVIEWED OR IF
OR WHEN A DECISION WILL BE MADE.
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE WOULD
CREATE A PART IN AND COMMUTATION
PANEL.
TO PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE GOVERNOR ON PARDONING
COMMUTATION REQUESTS.
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE WOULD
ESTABLISH A TIMELINE FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON PARDON
REQUEST INCLUDING AN EXPEDITED
PROCESS FOR URGENT PARTING
REQUEST SUCH AS THOSE OF THE
PENDING DEPORTATION ORDER.
THE PANEL WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
NOTIFICATIONS TO APPLICANTS WHEN
THEY RECEIVE APPLICATION BEGIN
THE INVESTIGATION. AND ISSUE A
RECOMMENDATION.
SO WE THINK WE THINK THAT.
THIS NEW PROCESS THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED PRICE MORE TRANSPARENCY
MORE EXPERTISE MORE TIMELINESS
MORE RESPONSIVENESS TO PARDON
REQUESTS.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE
VOTE AT THIS. TIME WE'RE NOT
AWARE OF ANY OPPOSITION.
BOB WITH ME HERE TODAY IS HAFSA
ALAMEDA COORDINATOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF WOMEN
PRISONERS A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. AND ALSO SUPPORT IS DANIEL
MAY HER WHO WAS RECENTLY
PARDONED BY GOVERNOR BROWN AND
WAS REPRESENTED BY ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
ANOTHER CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
QUIRK SECOND. MR SATO MOVED.
YES WITNESSES YOU HAVE.
FOUR MINUTES BUT WHERE WERE YOU
IN A.
BREAK IT UP.
I THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN KENNEDY
MY NAME IS DANIEL MEYER I'M HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE. OF THE
BILL IS NEEDED TO MAKE THE
PARDON PROCESS MORE ACCESSIBLE
AND TRANSPARENT SO THAT MORE
PEOPLE CAN BENEFIT FROM THIS
IMPORTANT AVENUE FOR IMMIGRATION
RELIEF.
MY STORY I WAS THREE YEARS OLD
WHEN MY FAMILY LEGALLY
IMMIGRATED FROM ACCOUNT TO THE
UNITED STATES. AS I GOT OLDER I
FELL IN WITH THE WRONG CROWD A
DECISION TO CHANGE MY LIFE.
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY I
PARTICIPATED IN ARMED ROBBERY I
WAS ARRESTED CONVICTED AND
SERVED MY SENSE IN THE STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY. UPON
COMPLETION OF MY SENTENCE I WAS
TRANSFERRED TO AN ICE DETENTION
FACILITY IN EL CENTRO CALIFORNIA
WORLDS PLACED ON TRIAL AGAIN.
THIS TIME IN IMMIGRATION COURT
AND ORDERED REMOVED FROM THE
UNITED STATES
O WHAT DOES THIS MEAN IT'S
ESSENTIALLY IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UNITED STATES IS YOUNG
CHILDREN. ARE FACED WITH A RISK
OF BEING DEPORTED TO COUNTRIES
WHERE THEY HAVE LITTLE OR NO
TIES OF THIS IS IT SENATE
SINCERELY MIKE MY SITUATION
WHERE.
I LOOKED AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE I
BASICALLY HAVE NO INFORMATION NO
WAY OF UNDERSTANDING WHAT WOULD
LIFE BE OVER THERE. OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT REFUSED TO
RECOGNIZE ME THE CITIZEN TO DO
THE HAND OVER NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. AND REFUSE TO ISSUE TRAVEL
DOCUMENTS SO I'M BASICALLY HERE
WITHOUT A COUNTRY. I WAS PLACED
ON SOMETHING CALLED INDEFINITE
DETENTION.
AND FOR THE NEXT ONE HALF YEARS
I WAS EVENTUALLY RELEASED ON AN
ORDER OF SUPERVISION PENDING
REMOVAL.
THAT REMOVAL ORDER HAS BEEN
STANDING FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
WITHOUT RELIEF.
AND DURING THAT TIME KNOWING
THAT THE DEPORTATION ORDER CAN
BE ACTIVATED ANYTIME PROVIDED
THE COUNTRY WAS. WILLING TO
ACCEPT ME.
IT STILL DIDN'T MATTER I'D
ALREADY TURNED MY LIFE AROUND
WHILE I WAS ALREADY IN PRISON.
GOT A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND
CONTINUE TO WORK ON SELF HELP
PROGRAMS AND AS I WAS RELEASED I
CONTINUE TO GIVE BACK TO
COMMUNITY AND PROVIDE ANY KIND
OF SUPPORT THAT I COULD TO.
ENCOURAGE GROWTH IN MY OWN LIFE
AND OTHERS.
.
TWO WEEKS AGO AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER WAS FORCED TO BE GRANTED
A FULL PARDON BY OUR GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN. I CANNOT THANK YOU
ENOUGH FOR THIS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY GOOD SECOND
CHANCE IN LIFE FOR ME BECAUSE
NOW THIS GIVES ME THE
OPPORTUNITY CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING SO
FOR.
THE PART ALSO JEWEL LOT OF
CRITICISM.
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
HIS SUPPORTERS.
OUT MULTI RECOGNIZE THE
IMMIGRANTS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
MANY HARD WORKING COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE SUBJECTED TO HARSH
CHARACTER ATTACKS SIMPLY FOR
SEEKING A BETTER LIFE FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
SOME SUCH AS MYSELF HAVE MADE
MISTAKES BUT I FOUND NEW PURPOSE
IN THE SERVICE OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE WOULD ALLOW
OTHERS SUCH AS MYSELF WHO HAVE
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
POSITIVE CHANGE AND SERVICE TO
THEIR COMMUNITY FIND A PATHWAY
TO A NORMAL LIFE THROUGH A
GUBERNATORIAL PARDON.
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD INCREASE
ACCESSIBILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN THE PARDON PROCESS WHICH CAN
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE. WHO DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO OR CANNOT AFFORD
COUNSEL?
AND IT WILL BUILD ON GOVERNOR
BROWN'S LEGACY OF ISSUING A
RECORD NUMBER OF PARDONS BY
ESTABLISHING A PANEL. DEDICATED
TO REVIEWING IN MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON PARDON AND
COMMUTATION APPLICATION.
SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY STORY
PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE.
OF MY NAME IS HASA ALUMINIUM.
I'M A STAFF MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS WE ARE ALSO CO
SPONSORING THE BILL.
I AM ACTUALLY A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIP.
AND I'M THE SPOUSE OF A FORMER
DEATH ROW PRISONER WHOSE
SENTENCE WAS COMMUTED I MENTION
THAT BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN HAPPILY
MARRIED FOR FORTY YEARS. HAVE A
BUNCH GRAND KIDS KIDS AND WE'VE
ALL BEEN.
EXEMPLARY. CITIZENS AND. IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME
THAT.
PEOPLE ARE LANGUISHING IN PRISON
TO DYE WHEN THEY COULD BE OUT
HERE HELPING WITH SO.
BUT SEE CWP IS A GRASSROOTS
SOCIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION
WORKING WITH CURRENTLY AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND
CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN'S PRISONS AYE
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE APPLYING FOR
COMMUTATION WITH A FOCUS OUR
FOCUSES. ON SUPPORTING
COMMUTATION FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND KEEP AND
PEOPLE SERVING LIFE WITHOUT.
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE ONE OF
THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF MASS
INCARCERATION IS A SEVERE AND
DISPROPORTIONATE SENTENCING OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR. POOR PEOPLE
SURVIVORS OF ABUSE AT CETERA A
GOVERNOR BROWN AS YOU'D
MENTIONED.
.
HAS GRANTED FORMER COMMUTATIONS
AND ANY CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
SINCE NINETEEN SIX.
OF BROWN'S COMMUTATIONS HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED EXTREME AND
DISPROPORTIONATE SENTENCING IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT FAR EXCEED
BASED TERMS. THE DISTURBING
INCREASE IN LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE
SENTENCING IN THE SEVERE SENSING
OF. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS%
YOUTH AND ACCOMPLICES UNDER THE
FELONY MURDER RULE ETCETERA.
.
THE RECENT INCREASING COGNITIVE
AND COMMUTATIONS HAS INCLUDED
MANY WOMEN WHO WERE SENTENCED TO
LIFE WITHOUT POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE A FOR THE ACTIONS.
STREETS OF THEIR ABUSERS OR FOR
SELF DEFENSE MANPOWER. WILL RUN
THE ONLY FOUR MINUTES LAUGHING
LIFE BEFORE. WE NEED A SPECIAL
AYE WE AGREE THAT A SPECIALIZED
PROCESS IS NEEDED AND A PANEL
WITH COMMUNITY BASED EXPERTS TO
HELP FUTURE GOVERNOR'S CONTINUE
TO REVIEW. AND MAKE DECISIONS IN
A TIMELY MANNER SO WE.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND THE OTHER WITNESSES AND SO
PORT MAIMAN ORGANIZATION
INTERNET OUT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUST CALIFORNIA PAT
BECAUSE SPONSORING STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY MITCHELL
CITY JEHLUM HAVE A CHAIR LEG
POLLUTION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ARE STRONG SUPPORT AND
PRODUCT COSPONSORED THANK YOU.
GINA DISAVOW WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
GLENN BACCHUS ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
YOU NEED A CASINO SO THE COUNCIL
ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
GO AGING WITH THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAROL STRICT MAN ON BEHALF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN WERE CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
CB UNIVERSITY WITH ALL OF US ARE
NINE BAY AREA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BEN ALONG WITH ASIAN PRISONER
SUPPORT COMMITTEE AND CAMPAIGN
TO PARDON BOARD PJ I. IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALSO BELIEVE JUSTICE COALITION
CO SPONSORS STONE SUPPORT.
IN A PRASAD ASIAN LAW CAUCUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CYRUS SCENE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
DANNY COUNTY FROM ASIAN PUT
PRISONERS SUPPORT COMMITTEE A
STRONG SUPPORT.
RENT THE MOVIE FROM CONCORD IN
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MOST BONTA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY I THINK THIS IS A
IMPROVEMENT ON APARTMENT
COMMUTATIONS PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
M. SECRETARY MICHAEL THE ROLE.
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE AYE
GINGER AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO CARILLO AYE CONSULTAS
FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THEY CAN SECURE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
IT'S ALMOST THERE ALAN.
YES I SURE TAKEN WHEN HE WAS
HERE
WHILE WE'RE WAITING WE'LL DO
SOME ADD ONS.
FOR MEN ABSENT MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE NOW.
WHAT WOULD THOSE NUMBERS AGAIN?
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY.
OKAY.
ON TWENTY FIVE TWENTY THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL LACKEY GODLY
YA.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY.
GOTTA YA. GOTTA YOUR AYE QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND WHAT YOU.
THIRTY TWENTY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL AB THIRTY
TWENTY SIX BY MISS MELENDEZ
SCULLY YA.
PETTY YA KNOW.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER QUIRK.
NO QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
THAT MEASURE FAILS.
WE WANT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY NINE CAVIAR.
CARILLO I
.
BUT THERE'S.
ON AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL.
GARCIA.
CARILLO AYE KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY THREE BY MR
HYSTERIA THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE THAT MEASURE PASSES
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND MR LOS HERE SO.
YOUR TURN MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE ZERO FOUR WHICH
REQUIRES LGBT. SPECIFIC TRAINING
FOR PEACE OFFICERS AND
DISPATCHERS.
.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE.
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF RESPECTING DIVERSITY AMONGST
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT AIR IS
GREGORY REALITY PROFESSOR OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN LGBT STUDIES
IN A RETIRED POLICE OFFICER AND
DAMIEN SAN VAULT ERECTOR. OF
POLICE ACADEMY IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TRAINS INNER AT NAPA
VALLEY COLLEGE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THE MORNING EVERYONE AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US MY
NAME IS GREAT MORALE YEAH I'M A
PROFESSOR OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND LGBT STUDIES A NAPA VALLEY
COLLEGE. AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE OH
FOR.
I BEGAN MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAREER AT THE AGE OF FIFTEEN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND I
KNEW FROM THE MOMENT I WALKED
INTO THE DOOR THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT THAT I WAS GAY BUT I
DID NOT HAVE ANY IDEA ABOUT WHAT
I WOULD FACE. INSIDE THOSE DOORS
BUT I LEARNED QUICKLY THAT I
COULD NEVER COME OUT.
AFTER COMING OUT IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR I'VE WRITTEN THREE BOOKS
ABOUT SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY MINORITIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND OVER THE
LAST DECADE I HAVE TALKED WITH
NUMEROUS GAY LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS ABOUT THE
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION.
THEY'VE SUFFERED WHILE WORKING
AT CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
HAVE ALSO SERVED AS AN EXPERT
WITNESS IN SEVERAL UNLAWFUL
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION CASES
INVOLVING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OFFICERS WHO ARE GAY.
WELL YOU WOULD THINK THAT WHAT I
EXPERIENCE BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD NOT BE THE
CASE TODAY. SADLY IT IS.
TODAY WITH US IN THE AUDIENCE AS
A DEPUTY SHERIFF FROM THE EAST
BAY.
WHO RIGHT NOW IS SUFFERING FROM
THE KIND OF HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION THIS BILL WILL
ADDRESS?
HE IS A DECORATED COMBAT VETERAN
AND A CAPTAIN IN THE U. S.
MARINE CORPS.
HE WAS A SUCCESSFUL LAUNCH
FORSMAN OFFICER UNTIL HIS
SUPERVISORS DISCOVERED THAT HE
IS GAY.
AND WALL THINGS HAVE.
GOTTEN BETTER THE WORKPLACE
ENVIRONMENT FOR LGBT POLICE
EMPLOYEES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
EXTERNAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LGBT COMMUNITY IS NOT GOOD.
WHEN COMMUNITY GROUPS SEEK TO
EXCLUDE EVEN LGBT MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM PARTICIPATING
PRIDE EVENTS.
BECAUSE THEY LACK TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS A WHOLE SOMETHING
IS WRONG.
AND WOULD HATE CRIME IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS ARE AFRAID TO
CALL THE POLICE BECAUSE THEY
FEAR RIDICULE SOMETHING IS
WRONG.
MY TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
THIRTY YEARS EXPERIENCE AS A
TEACHER HAS TAUGHT ME THAT
TRAINING IS THE KEY TO CHANGING
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT CULTURE. AND
TO BEGIN BUILDING TRUST
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
LGBT COMMUNITY WE CAN DO THIS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL WILL GIVE
US THE FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
AND DISPATCHER OR GIVEN THE
KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO SUPPORT
LGBT CO WORKERS AND OUR
COMMUNITY AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES SIR.
GOOD MORNING AND I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE MY NAME'S DAMIAN SADDLE I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TRAINING CENTER AND
POLICE ACADEMY.
THAT NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE.
AND I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
DIRECTORS' ASSOCIATION.
I'M A CAREER MEMBER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE AND HAVE BEEN
TEACHING CULTURAL DIVERSITY IN
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT PREVENTION
CLASSES FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
FOR MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE OH FOR.
THIS BILL REQUIRES A UNIQUE
TRAINING SUBJECT NOT CURRENTLY
COVERED. BY ANY EXISTING LAW.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA POST
TRAINING AND TESTING SPECS.
FOR BASIC TRAINING IN THE AREA
OF CULTURAL DIVERSITY AND
COMMUNITY POLICING MAKE NO
MENTION OF LGBT PEOPLE.
THE TRAINING REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL CAN BE EASILY PROVIDED
WITHIN THE EXISTING HOURS A
BASIC TRAINING REQUIRED FOR
PEACE OFFICERS AND DISPATCHERS.
THERE ARE AMPLE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS AROUND THE STATE. WHO
ARE WILLING AND ABLE TO
FACILITATE THE DELIVERY OF THIS
TRAINING?
THIS BILL INSURERS.
NEW LAW ENFORCEMENT EMPLOYEES
ENTERING THE PROFESSON WILL
RECEIVE AT LEAST A FOUNDATIONAL.
TRAINING ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY.
IT ALSO ENSURES THAT THE NINETY
SIX THOUSAND CURRENT EMPLOYEES
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
RECEIVE A COMMON CORE
CURRICULUM.
AND DISPATCHERS AND OFFICERS
WILL RECEIVE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO MORE EFFECTIVELY SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY.
TO RESTORING THE KIND OF TRUST
LAW ENFORCEMENT WANTS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING.
AND THERE DOES EXIST ALREADY A
FUNDING MECHANISM TO HELP PAY
FOR THIS TRAINING.
IN FACT A NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE
WE'VE ALREADY SECURED AWAY OF
AND. OF USING ENHANCED NONCREDIT
APPORTIONMENT.
TO PROVIDE THIS TRAINING IN OUR
REGION.
CURRICULUM HAS BEEN DEVELOPED
AND IS READY TO SHARE WITH
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE.
I BELIEVE IT'S TIME FOR US TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL FOR
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD
TO BE A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GIVE.
DOUG TRIED WELL INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHILE KLEIN BLOCK PLAN FOR STONE
WALL STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN BACH RILEY BOARD MEMBER OF
PLASTER STONEWALL DEMOCRATS
SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO MY
ASSEMBLYMAN. KEVIN KILEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN MY NAME IS MIGUEL
GILERA.
DIPPY SURE FOR PLAYED BY THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN MY CAPACITY AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BUT AS DAVID HAD SERVED THE
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY CENTER
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
YOU.
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND
FILLS OUT ON BEHALF OF THE CRIME
VICTIMS ACTIONAL LINES OF
SUPPORT.
USER.
MARGO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GEORGE DRYER WITH THE SACRAMENTO
STONEWALL DEMOCRATIC CLUB STRONG
SUPPORT.
WILLIAM LUXEMBOURG HAD BEEN
ASKED BY EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
AND TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY FOR.
OF POLICE AND SHERIFFS I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I LET ME BE
VERY CLEAR THAT WE DO NOT ARGUE
WITH THAT.
MORE AT TRAINING AYE REGARDING
SENSITIVE SENSITIVITY TO THESE
ISSUES.
WILL BE USELESS WE THINK YOU'LL
BE VALUABLE THAT ALSO LET ME BE
VERY CLEAR. THAT GIVING AT THE
COST OF DEVELOPING AND PROVIDING
TRAINING AS WELL AS THE COSTS OF
TRAVEL AND OFFICER BACK FAILED.
THAT ARE ALWAYS ASSOCIATED WITH
MOST TRAININGS WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT UNFUNDED
MANDATE THAT THIS BILL
REPRESENTS.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH POSTS
CURRENT FISCAL CHALLENGES AS YOU
KNOW.
THIS BILL WILL PUT EVEN MORE
PRESSURE ON A SYSTEM THAT IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF APPROPRIATE
RESOURCE SAYS. I'M ALSO WE WANNA
BE CLEAR THAT.
.
WE ARE I AM NOT SURE THAT THE
TOPICS THAT ARE CONTEMPLATED BY
DISPEL ARE NOT CURRENTLY THE
SUBJECT OF THE VALUABLE OR
REQUIRE TRAINING.
SO RIGHT NOW WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THAT MEASURE AND ASKED WE
ARE NOBLE THINK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ARCTIC QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE COMMENT.
I'D LIKE TO. GIVE YOU MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT. THAT.
FIRST OFF.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR AS WAS
INDICATED BY THE. OPPOSITION
THAT WE ALL AGREE THAT THE LGBT
POPULATION DESERVES.
GREATER UNDERSTANDING AND
SENSITIVITY.
AND.
WE WE NEED TO SUPPORT THAT
EFFORT VERY GENUINELY BUT I HAVE
TO TELL YOU THAT. POST FUNDS ARE
IN MAJOR JEOPARDY RIGHT NOW.
AND HAVING WHAT WE'RE HAVING A
VERY SERIOUS.
DIFFICULTY MEETING THE CURRENT
OBLIGATIONS THAT.
ARE ALREADY EXPECTED TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED AND SO.
MY OPPOSITION TO THIS IS MERELY
BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
THE PATHWAY IS NOT DOABLE AT
THIS TIME.
AND I THINK THE POST FUNDS.
.
ARE VERY PROBLEMATIC RIGHT NOW
IS THE FUNDING WITH WITH MANY
THINGS ARE. AT OUR GREAT STATE
BUT.
.
AND ALSO JUST AS A CONSIDERATION
PUSH FUNDS ARE USUALLY.
USED FOR TRAINING.
FOR PUBLIC AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
LGBT IS PART OF OUR PUBLIC AS
WELL.
BUT I THINK.
PART OF THE FOCUS OF I
UNDERSTAND IT CORRECTLY USED TO
ALSO ADDRESS.
THE INNER WORKINGS WITH THOSE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE LGBT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO TO FOCUS ON. BUT I'M NOT SURE
THE POST FUNDING IS THE WAY TO
DO THAT AND SO I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU MAY BE AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT A PATHWAY
THAT.
MIGHT BE A LITTLE MORE DOABLE.
BECAUSE I CERTAINLY THINK THE
TOPIC IS A LEGITIMATE ONE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEAR QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND OF IF AT
OF VIA THE CHAIR IF I MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
YOU'RE OF MISTER LIKE IT AS WELL
AS. THE EXPERT TESTIMONY VERY
BRIEFLY.
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS BUT
I'M JUST AS OF YESTERDAY THE
COMMISSION OPPOSE CERTIFIED A
COURSE.
THAT MET ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
AND THE TRAINING OF THE BILL AND
THE CONTENT IS COMPLETING CAN BE
DELIVERED.
WITHIN HOURS OF FOR THE BASIC
CAN CREEK ONE WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL.
SUB SUPPORT NEEDED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE FISCAL
CONSIDERATIONS BUT IF I MY BILL
TO ALSO AND GRIMACES TO ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THERE AS
WELL.%
THANK YOU. UP WE BELIEVE THAT
THE COMMUTER COLLEGE SYSTEM HAS
A FUNDING MECHANISM IN PLACE IT
ALREADY PROVIDES FUNDING TO PAY
FOR A GREAT DEAL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING SUCH AS
REQUIRED BY OTHER SECTIONS IN
THIRTEEN FIVE NINETEEN WE THINK
THIS ONE. IS ALSO APPLICABLE FOR
THOSE FUNDS THERE IS AN EXISTING
ONLINE COURSE THAT'S ALREADY
DEVELOPED THAT COULD BE EASILY
CERTIFIED AND DELIVERED.
BY LOCAL TRAINING PROVIDERS
WITH LITTLE OR NO IMPACT ON THE
CALIFORNIA POST.
THANK YOU.
BOB BEGIN I WANT.
RUSSIA CLOSE BUTTERY.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF.
THE CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING LIVE
VOTE DO WE GET MOTION.
I'M.
DEVOTION
THE BILL IS REMOVED AFFECTED IN
THAT FACTORY CALLED ROYAL. AB
TWENTY FIVE OF FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER I TOLD
HER I LACKEY. LACKEY NOCARDIA.
CAVIAR AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
I QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES REGULATIONS.
AND.
FINALLY ITEMS OUT TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY. AND TWENTY NINE FORTY
EIGHT.
THE CRICKET.
THIS YEAR WE TOLD YOU LIKE
FIRST.
.
DO IT IN AMERICORPS TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY.
YOU'RE MUCH.
THIS BILL REMOVES A SET OF
OWNERS FIREARMS REGULATIONS ON
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS BY
REPEALING THE MISGUIDED AND
MISLEADING. UNSAFE HANDGUN LAW.
THE SAFETY OF A FIREARM IN IS
AND HOW IT IS USED NOT IN ITS
MANUFACTURE OR ITS DESIGN.
GUN CONTROL MEASURES LIKE THE
UNSEEN GUN LAW DO NOT MAKE THE
PUBLIC SAFER. THEY MAKE GUN
CONTROL ADVOCATES FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING.
BUT IN REALITIES THESE LAWS ARE
ONLY MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR LAW ABIDING CITIZENS TO OWN
A FIREARM. AND THEY DO
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO STOP
CRIMINALS.
THE TRAGEDY THE FLORIDA HIGH
SCHOOL THE WE ALL WE READ THAT
WELL RECENTLY WITNESSED ACROSS
THE NATION.
WAS THE FAILURE OF GOVERNMENT IF
EXISTING LAWS IT BEEN ENFORCED
THE TRAGIC WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED.
IF DEPUTIES ACTUALLY DONE THEIR
JOB WHEN THEY WENT TO THE THIS
TROUBLED TEENS HOUSE THIRTY NINE
DIFFERENT TIMES THIS TRAGEDY
WOULD NOT OCCURRED. IF THE FBI
HAD DONE ITS JOB IT WAS NOTIFIED
THAT THERE WAS AN UNSAVED PERSON
WITH UNSAVED DESIGNS.
THIS TRAGEDY WOULD NOT HAVE
OCCURRED IF THE ARM TO GET BT.
THEY IT WAS OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL AND DID NOTHING TO HELP.
THE STUDENTS IN DANGER.
IF HE HAD ACTUALLY ACTED.
NONE OF THESE THINGS WOULD
HAPPEN.
BUT LET'S BE VERY CLEAR.
LAWS THAT HAMPER LEGAL GUN
OWNERSHIP WHICH PROTECT
PROTECTED BY THE SECOND
AMENDMENT DO NOT MAKE US SAFER.
THE UNSAFE HANDGUN LAW PROVIDES
THE ILLUSION OF SAFETY.
WHILE VIOLATING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL FREEDOMS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY RESTORE
SOME THAT LIBERTY BY REPEALING
THIS MISGUIDED UNCONSTITUTIONAL
AND ULTIMATELY INEFFECTIVE LA.
THANK YOU YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANNE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON NOW.
AMANDA WILCOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE.
MY PREDECESSORS WORKED EXTREMELY
HARD IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES TO
GET THE ORIGINAL.
UNSAFE HANDGUN ACT.
S. B. FIFTEEN IT WAS THEN.
PASSED.
AND WE HAVE FOUND THAT LAW TO BE
STUNNINGLY SUCCESSFUL.
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TRUE HOPE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THAT RATE
OF ACCIDENTAL SHOOTING DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA FELL BY MORE THAN
FIFTY PERCENT.
ACCORDING TO CDC DATA THERE MAY
BE MANY REASONS FOR THAT BUT I
WOULD OFFER ONE OF THE REASONS
IS HANDGUNS ARE NOW SAFER.
DID THE ORIGINAL ACT.
REQUIRE THAT HANDGUNS MEET
BASIC CONSUMER SAFETY STANDARDS
SUCH AS PASSING A DROP TEST.
AND AND MISS OF FIRING TESTS.
COMMONSENSE REQUIREMENTS FOR
GUNS AND I THAT ACT WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN.
REMOVING THE.
.
THE NUMBER OF VERY CHEAP JUNK
CONSOLE CALL JUNK GUNS FOR SARAH
NIGHT SPECIALS THAT WERE VERY
PREVALENT AT THE TIME. AND
COMMONLY USED IN CRIME SO I
WOULD SAY THE LAW HAS BEEN A
SUCCESS.
IN ITS ORIGINAL INTENT
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY NINE OTHER
PROVISIONS WERE ADDING COLLUDED.
ARE OTHER REQUIREMENTS WERE
ADDED INCLUDING THE REQUIREMENT
FOR CHAMBER LOAD INDICATOR OR
MAGAZINE.
.-MAGAZINE DISCONNECT AGAIN TO
PREVENT ACCIDENTAL SHOOTINGS AND
THEN LATER THE MICROSCOPIC
REQUIREMENT WAS ADDED.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE TO
FURTHER PREVENT ACCIDENTS
SHOOTINGS AND ACTUALLY TO HELP
IN TERMS OF SOLVING CRIME. AND
APPREHENDING ARMED CRIMINALS
BEFORE THEY DO MORE HARM AS
WE'VE DISCUSSED ALOT THAT EARLY.
EARLIER HEARING REGARDING THE
MICROSCOPIC REQUIREMENT.
THERE'S DEBATE ON THAT OF WE
DISAGREE ABOUT THAT.
WHETHER IT CAN BE DONE OR NOT.
AND IS CURRENTLY IN THE COURTS
AND.
MY RECOMMENDATION IS TO LET THE
COURTS DECIDE ON THIS AND LET IT
PLAY OUT WE STILL BELIEVE THAT
IS VERY GOOD POLICY WANNA SEE
THAT ON FUTURE FIREARMS.
FOR SALE IN CALIFORNIA ARE AND I
THEREFORE ASK YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
IF
UP HAVE OF GIFFORD'S LAW CENTER
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE MEANS
ARE FAIRLY ALSO RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. A FEDERAL LAW
IMPOSES NO DESIGN SAFETY
STANDARDS ON DOMESTICALLY
PRODUCED FIREARMS AND THEREFORE
EFFECTIVELY CREATES A PROTECTED
MARKET FOR JUNK GUNS DO TO POOR
CONSTRUCTION ARE DESIGNED CAN
OFTEN JAN MISS FIRE OR
MALFUNCTION. THREATEN THE SAFETY
OF OF THE SHOOTER AND BYSTANDERS
ALIKE.
RESEARCHERS FROM A REPORT ON
THIS TOPIC FROM JOHNS HOPKINS
CENTER FOR GUN POLICY AND
RESEARCH CONCLUDED THAT QUOTE
ALTHOUGH UNINTENTIONAL
ACCIDENTAL SHOOTINGS ACCOUNT FOR
A SMALL SHARE OF FARM RELATED
MORTALITY AND MORBIDITY. THESE
DEATHS AND INJURIES ARE HIGHLY
PREVENTABLE THROUGH PROPER
DESIGN A FIREARMS.
WE ARGUE THAT THE DATA SHOWS AS
AMANDA MENTIONED THAT THE ANSWER
CAN CONNECT TO IN CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN IMPACTFUL.
WE BELIEVE ARE STATES PROGRESS
IN REDUCING THE INCIDENCE OF
EXCEL SHOOTING SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED AND BUILT UPON NOT
UNDERMINED.
OR REPEALED IN ITS ENTIRETY
WHICH IS WHAT THIS BILL PROPOSES
AND SO WE ARE REGRETFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ARE. THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE WITHOUT PAYING
VERY MUCH VALUE TO SEARCH
UNPROVEN CONTENTIONS
THIS IS NOT ABOUT DROP TESTING
UNSAFE HANDGUNS. WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT IS ABOUT RESTRICTING?
FIREARM SALE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE MANUFACTURER FEELING TO
PAY A FEE TO PERMIT THEM TO
CONTINUE TO BE SOLD OR BECAUSE
THE POSTER TO OUR TWENTY
THIRTEEN MAKE AND MODEL DOES NOT
INCORPORATE MICROSCOPIC
TECHNOLOGY.
LADIES A JOURNALIST A VERY CLEAR
THE UNSAFE HANDGUN ROSTER IN
CALIFORNIA DOES NOTHING BUT
LIMIT OUR ABILITY OF WHAT HAS
LAW ABIDING. SECOND AMENDMENT
HOLDING CALIFORNIA CITIZENS TO
ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN OUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS DO NOT RIGHTS.
THAT'S EXCUSE ME THESE NOT
PRIVILEGES THESE OUR RIGHTS THEY
SHALL BE INFRINGED.
THIS LAW IS NOT ONLY.
WRONG.
IT IS INEFFECTIVE AND IS OVER
AND CONSTITUTIONAL.
I URGE YES ONE TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY.
FROM FROM MR ALLIED JUST BEEN.
IF YOU READ YOUR BILL AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY HAS INTRODUCED
TRAVIS ALLEN FARMS AND SAFE GUNS
EXISTING LAW SUBJECT TO
EXCEPTIONS.
GENERALLY MAKES IT AN OFFENSE TO
MANUFACTURE SELL A HANDGUN THAT
IS NOT SAFE.
EXISTING LAWS STABS CRITERIA FOR
DETERMINING IF A HANDGUN IS
UNSAFE.
IS LISTING LAW GENERALLY
REQUIRES MANUFACTURERS TO SUBMIT
SAMPLES OF NEW HANDGUN MODELS
FOR TESTING TO DETERMINE IF THEY
ARE UNSAFE OR MAYBE APPROVED FOR
SALE AS SPECIFIED.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE COME TO
COMPILE A ROSTER LISTING ALL THE
HANDGUNS THAT HAVE BEEN TESTED.
AND DETERMINED NOT TO BE SAFE.
THIS BILL.
WHAT REPEAL ALL THESE
PROVISIONS?
SPECIFICALLY THIS IS ABOUT
UNSAFE GUNS.
YOU KNOW I.
I MET MY GRANDFATHER.
IN.
JUNE OF NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
I LOST MY FOR GRANDFATHER IN
AUGUST OF NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
BECAUSE HIS SATURDAY NIGHT
PISTOL FELL ON THE GROUND AND
KILLED THEM.
YET UNSAFE WEAPON.
OBVIOUSLY THIS ISN'T NO FOR ME
FOR PERSONAL REASONS BUT I ALSO
KNOW FOR EVERYONE THAT.
I'M NOT TRYING TO RESTRICT OUT
THINK THIS COMMISSION RESTRICT
ANYONE FROM HAVING.
A FIREARM.
BUT WE DEFINITELY DO NOT WANT
UNSAFE FIREARMS UP THERE SO
CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE.
THOUGH.
THERE IS A MOTION.
AND CHAIR CHLORAL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER NO JONES
SAWYER NO LACKEY VOTING. LACKEY
NOT VOTING GUBBIO.
GOTTA YA KNOW GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
THE MEASURE FAILED.
THE NEXT ITEM.
ITEM AB TWENTY NINE FORTY EIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN SB FIFTY
FOUR MADE CALIFORNIA ANY LEGAL
SANCTUARY STATE. IT CUT
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY INTERFERE
WITH OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES
DOING THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY.
IT HAD AN UNDULY AND HAS AN
UNDULY.
RESTRICTIVE DEFINITION OF WHICH
OFFENSES ARE INCLUDED WORK
COMMUNICATIONS ARE PERMITTED.
IT IS A LOUD LOW ROGUE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LIKE SAN FRANCISCO
TO TO IMPOSE EVEN STRICTER
RESTRICTIONS ON COOPERATION. AND
IN DANGER THE REST OF OUR STATE
BY PERMITTING INDIVIDUALS A
SERIOUS FELONY CONVICTIONS TO
REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA.
S. B. FIFTY FOUR VERY SIMPLY IS
MADE CALIFORNIA A HAVEN FOR
CRIMINALS WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY
AND IT SHOULD BE REPEALED.
A WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
ANNE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FOUR MINUTES TWO MINUTES A PIECE
OR AFFECT WHERE I'M SURE MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
ANGELINA ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING SOME
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY A TWELVE MEMBER OF. THE
STATE WHY I THOUGHT OF
CALIFORNIA COALITION WHICH
STRONGLY SUPPORTED SB FIFTY FOUR
AND ROSA SPONSORS OF CHOI SECOND
SHIFT OCT AND A BETWEEN A FORTY
EIGHT IT'S CONTRARY TO EXISTING
LAW THAT SETS LIMITS ON LOCAL
ENTITLEMENT. WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND RAISES CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS STARTING TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA BEGAN
DISENTANGLE IN STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC. SAFETY RESOURCES I FROM
JUST BETTER ALL THE PETITION
SYSTEM OF RECOGNIZING THAT THIS
ENTITLEMENT UNDER CUT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES CONFIDENCE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND UNDERMINE THE
PUBLIC FIFTY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
UP IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN TO
TRUST ACT ENSURE THAT PEOPLE OF
LOW LEVEL NONVIOLENT MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSES. WERE NOT UNNECESSARILY
HELD FOR TO PETITION PROVIDE
ELEAZAR WITH DISCUSSION TO NOT
USE.
SCARS TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON
IMMIGRATION DETAINEES.
I'M NOT SURE THAT LEGISLATION
GOVERNOR BROWN CAME TOGETHER TO
ENACT CALIFORNIA VALUES OCT
WHICH AMONG OTHER REFORMS
INCLUDING ABSOLUTE PROHIBIT XIN
ON ELLIOTT HONORING IMMIGRATION
RETAINERS.
AYE WELL TRODDEN MISSION HAS
RECENTLY FILED A LAWSUIT CHARLIE
SHEEN PORTIONS OF AS BEFORE. IN
FEDERAL COURT THIS LAWSUIT
RIDLEY DOES NOT CHALLENGE
PROVISION OF AS BEFORE DEPENDS
ON IMMIGRATION HOLD REQUESTS.
I'M CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY
EXPERIENCED DEVASTATING FISCAL
AND SOCIAL IMPACTS OF ON
IMMIGRATION CHRISTIAN CANNERS AS
WELL AS NOTABLY THAT FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT ON OUR
COMMUNITY THINGS REALLY HARMED
OUR COMMUNITIES. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VALUES OCT A
CALIFORNIA'S FULLY WITHIN ITS
RIGHTS TO KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER
RESPECT DUE PROCESS RIGHTS TO
PROTECT
AGAINST RACIAL PROFILING IT'S
WRONG WASTEFUL TO USE OUR LOCAL
RESOURCES. TO HELP THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENT IT'S
PEOPLE WHO ARE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY IS CONSEQUENTLY WE
REMAIN STRONGLY OPPOSED.
GOOD THAT AFTERNOON MR CHEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JIM AT THIS OF
A GOVERNMENT FAIRS MANAGER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER ALSO A MEMBER OF THE US
AT A CALIFORNIA COALITION. AND
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
I'M REGARDLESS OF A PERSON'S
BACKGROUND OUR INTERACTION WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WE
BELIEVE IN THE HUMANITY OF ALL
PEOPLE. AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
DUE PROCESS AND THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SECOND CHANCES SADLY THIS
BILL RUNS CONTRARY TO CALIFORNIA
VALUES BY UNDERMINING WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
ACCOMPLISHED LAST YEAR. OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE STORY OF THE STORY
OF DANIEL MORROW WHO TESTIFIED
EARLIER TODAY. AND THERE ARE
OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS LIKE HIM
WHO MADE MISTAKES BUT THEN TOOK
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TURN THEIR
LIVES AROUND AND HAVE BECOME
VITAL TO THE FABRIC OF OUR
STATE.
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE STRONGER
WHEN WE BELIEVE IN COMPASSION
AND SECOND CHANCES THIS BILL
WEAKENS OUR STATE AND FEEDS INTO
THE ANTI IMMIGRANT HYSTERIA AT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS USED
TO DIVIDE THE NATION. IT IS FOR
A REASON FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU KNOW
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION NAMING ORGANIZATIONS.
IN TO ASSIST OF THE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ALSO IF JUSTICE COALITION
OPPOSITION.
FIRE HUSSEIN WITH THE FULL
RIGHTS EMPOWERMENT AND EQUALITY
COALITION IN SAN FRANCISCO ON
THE CONTRA COSTA ADVOCATE RIGHT
SLIDE STRONG OPPOSITION.
YOU.
ANGELA CHAT WITH ICE OUT OF
CALIFORNIA COALITION A COALITION
OF SEVENTY FIVE LABOR CIVIL
RIGHTS EMIGRATE ORGANIZATION
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
RICK YOU MODY WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
NOTED SALAS WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
AND THE WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION AND IMMIGRANT YOUTH
COALITION STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SABRINA CROWE SAID HE WITH ALL
OF US ARE NONE BAY AREA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
THAT'S KIM I OPPOSE AS A
COMMUNITY MEMBER AQ.
MARGOT GEORGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WERE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
OPPOSITION.
CAROL STRICT MAN LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PERSONS WITH CHILDREN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
AND LIKE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
BODE WELL.
SECOND.
YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND YOU
MAY CLOSE MISTAKE VERY MUCH AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY EIGHT IS A
SIMPLE BILL IT RESTORES THE RULE
OF LAW.
AND ENFORCES FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
LAW IN CALIFORNIA IT RECOGNIZE
THE VERY SIMPLE FACT THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS SUPREMACY OVER ANY
STATE CONSTITUTION. AND
FURTHERMORE IT PROTECT EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIA CITIZEN WHO'S
BEEN ENDANGERED BY THE SEA LEGAL
SANCTUARY STATE LAW. A VERY
SIMPLE STORY VERY BEAUTIFUL
YOUNG GIRL PRETTY WAS KATE'S
TIMELY.
SHE WAS WALKING DOWN THE PIER IN
SAN FRANCISCO WITH HER FATHER.
ON A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
CHIU SHOT IN THE BACK
BY SOMEONE WHO'D BEEN DEPORTED
FIVE TIMES PREVIOUSLY AND WAS A
SEVEN TIME FELON. THIS PERSON
NEVER SHOULD'VE BEEN ALLOWED
BACK IN OUR COUNTRY HE NEVER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN RELEASED BY THE
SHERIFF OF SAN FRANCISCO. BUT HE
WAS JUST A FEW MONTHS EARLIER
AND YOU TO THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA JUSTICE SYSTEM. IS
UNFORTUNATELY BROKEN.
POTENTIALLY BEYOND BEYOND REPAIR
THIS PERSON DIDN'T EVEN GET A
MANSLAUGHTER CHARGE DO YOU GET A
MURDER CHARGE HIS ONLY CHARGE
WAS POSSESSION.
OF A FIREARM.
THIS.
IS THE SAD TRAGEDY THAT IS
HAPPENING CALIFORNIA BUT THIS IS
NOT AN OLD STORY IS A STORY THAT
NOW AFFECTS US EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WITH THE ILLEGAL ACTIONS
OF HOT HERE MISTER THE CRIMINAL
ATTORNEY GENERAL CALIFORNIA.
WHO HAS TOLD CALIFORNIA'S
CITIZENS CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
OWNERS THEY'LL BE PROSECUTED? IF
THEY TRY TO ASSIST FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES DOING A
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY. TO THE
DEMOCRAT MAYOR OF OAKLAND LIBBY
SCHAAF WHO IS NOW GUILTY OF OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED COUNTS OF AIDING
AND ABETTING CRIMINALS WHEN SHE.
DUE TO S. B. FIFTY FOUR WARNED
THEM THE ICE WAS COMING. THESE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN OUR STATE
ILLEGALLY THEY'RE COMMITTING
CRIMES WHILE THEY'RE HERE. WHAT
IS BE VERY CLEAR THIS IS NOT
ABOUT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION?
THIS IS ABOUT.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME HERE
ILLEGALLY WHO ARE NOW COMMITTING
CRIMES WHILE THEY'RE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE NOW BEING
SHELTERED UNCONSTITUTIONALLY
WITH CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS.
THIS LAW IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT
WILL BE OVERTURNED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THERE IS
ALSO A GOVERNOR'S RACE AND AS
THE NEXT GOVERNOR OF STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WILL ALSO RIVERS
THIS LAW. GRAPHICAL LET ME TELL
YOU VERY SIMPLY WRAP IT UP NOW
THAT OKAY THAT LIBBY SCHAAF.
AT LIBBY SCHAAF YOU MAKE THE
DEMOCRAT MAYOR OF OAKLAND.
IS NOW GUILTY NOT ONLY OF EIGHT
HUNDRED COUNTS OF AIDING AND
ABETTING CRIMINALS.
SHE IS OUT NOW ALSO GUILTY OF
THREE CHARGES MISTER ALEX S.
RITUAL CRIME DO DO JUJUR
COMPLICITY. WITH S. B. FIFTY
FOUR ALRIGHT S. B. FIFTY FOUR IS
A MOCKERY OF JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA TO MOCHRIE THE US
CONSTITUTION AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY EIGHT WOULD REPEAL S. B.
FIFTY FOUR PACKED AND I URGE
YOUR PASSING WITH TODAY.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE.
.
I'M NOT EVEN.
GANDHI JUSTIFY THOSE COMMENT.
MEANT SECRETARY CALLED ROLE AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
NO JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
GOTTA YA KNOW GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO DEL.
THAT MEASURE FAILED.
YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL NOW DO ADD ONS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY THREE BY MISTER BONTA
LACKEY.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY THREE BY.
MISTER BONTA LACKEY.
.
NOT VOTING.
LACKEY NOT VOTING GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER CHAIR WITH THIS
MOTION WAS TO HOLD THE SPILLING
COMMITTEE EP NINETEEN ELEVEN
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT PUTTING.
AB TWENTY TEN WAS A HOLDING
COMMITTEE. FOR LACK OF MOTION AB
NUMBER FOUR I'M SORRY ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY FIVE OF
FOR.
WELL WHEN I.
ON A BE NINETEEN ELEVEN VOTE
CHANGE GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT
VOTING TO AYE.
I DON'T THREE THAT BILL WAS
HELPING CAMILLI FOR LACK OF
MOTION.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY FIVE
OH FORM. IT'S BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY BY MISTER COOPER. LACKEY
AYE LACKEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX THIS ITEM WAS ON
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WAS
ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY NINE BY MISTER HOLDEN
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TEN WAS ON CONSENT
ITEM ELEVEN ON CONSENT. ITEM
TWELVE ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY MISTER SANTIAGO
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY THREE BY MISTER
NAZARIAN.
LACKEY.
LACKEY I.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR WITH TESTIMONY ONLY
TO SAY.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FIVE BY MISTER BONTA
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT VOTING
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
I DIDN'T.
ON ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT
BODINGTON I.
ADAM SEVENTEENTH ADAM WAS JUST
DISPENSED WITH ITEM EIGHTEEN
WITH SUNKEN FAT.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN THIS ITEM
HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY WAS ON
CONSENT. ITEM TWENTY ONE WITH ON
CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY TWO WAS PULLED BY
COMMITTEE.
ITEM TWENTY THREE THIS MEASURE.
IS ON CALL GOT.
AB THIRTY TWENTY SIX BY MISS
MELENDEZ GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SALAS FLETCHER NO.
THAT BILL FAILS.
DATE TOPO.
ON RECONSIDERATION JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY
AYE CARDIO.
CARILLO NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
THE MOTION FAILS.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR A. B. THIRTY
FORTY BY MISTER NAZARIAN LACKEY.
I.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
CUTTING YOUR AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
I AM TWENTY FIVE IS PULLED BACK
COMMITTEE. I DON'T TWENTY SIX
WAS ON CONSENT.
I DON'T TWENTY SEVEN WAS ON
CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT WAS PULLED BY
COMMITTEE.
ITEM TWENTY NINE WAS ON CONSENT.
I AM NUMBER THIRTY WITH HOUSING
COMMITTEE FOR LACK OF MOTION.
THAT CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEETING THANK YOU